COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE CALL THAT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS TO
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW. THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVEN'T MADE IT. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE RVERS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. 1-677-226-8152 AN
ACCESS CODE IS. SIXTEEN FORTY
EIGHTY TWO AGAIN THAT'S. ONE
SIX FOUR ZERO EIGHT TWO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES STONE WORKS
PLEASEREFER TO THE SENATE OR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN TAKE A SHORT WHILE. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER HE
WILL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
MUTE UNMUTE IT AND YOU. ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEET FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND WE HANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE HEARING ALL THE
BILL'S SPONSOR OUR SCHEDULE.
AFTER INITIAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE. AGAIN
THAT'S FIFTEEN MINUTES PER
SIDE. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICES OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED AND THAT ALSO
GOES TO FOR ANYONE HERE. IN
PERSON. WATER RETURN FOR HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINING
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARING AND IF THAT'S CLOSE TO
THE SAME MANNER AS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON
OUR AGENDA TO BILLS ARE UP FOR
CONSENT. AND THEY ARE S. B.
THREE EIGHT FOUR BY SENATOR
CORTESE AND SB SEVEN TWO ZERO
BY AYE CHOI BOGUE. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION ON THESE
BILLS WE MUST FIRST ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BRADFORD HERE BRADFORD
HERE CHAU VOGUE HERE OBAMACARE
COM LONGER COM LONGER HERE
SKINNER WIENER. WIENER HERE
QUORUM ESTABLISHED A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISH. LET'S NOW
DISPOSE OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WE NEED A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS THERE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR CHOI
BALK. CAN WE CALLTHE ROLL
CONSULTANT ON CONCERN COUNTER
CONSENT CALENDAR BRADFORD HI
FOR DIETRO VOGUE HI HI THE
CHOKE I CALM LONGER CALM LONGER
AYE SKINNER WIENER. WIENER AYE.
STE THE MEASURE AS FOR VOTES
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND NOW WILL
MOVE TO OUR FIRST ITEM ON THE
AGENDA AND IT'S- BY YOURS
TRULY- WE'RE DEALING WITH S. B.
TWO ON ONE HAND GAVEL OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR TOOL.
OKAY AND- I WILL FOLLOW HER
INSTRUCTIONS. CONSIDER BRADFORD
GLAD TO SEE YOU'RE WELL AND
READY TO CHAIR OUR OUR MEETING
AT AND YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR- SB
TWO. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND-
AUDIENCE AND CHEER I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB TO THE KENNETH ROSS
JUNIOR PLEASE TO CERTIFICATION
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE LET ME
FIRST STATE CAN OF ROSS JUNIOR
WAS A YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALE WHO LIVED IN THE CITY OF
GARDENA. AND WAS GUNNED DOWN-
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SHOT
TWICE IN THE BACK BY A GUARDIAN
A POLICE OFFICER. HE WAS ON
ARMED- HE LIVED IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF REGULARS TO BUY
REAL ONE IN THE COMMUNITY SO
THIS IS- WHO THIS BILL IS IN
MEMORY OF. THIS BILL IS BEING
JORDAN AUTHORED BY OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS
OF MYSELF AND I THINK ALL THE
CO AUTHORS WHO'VE COME ON BOARD
AND IT ALSO HAPPENS TO BE A
PRIORITY OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. THIS BILL DOES TO
SIMPLE THINGS FIRST BILL MAKES
CHANGES TO STRENGTHEN THE TOM
BAIN CIVIL RIGHTS ACT HE
CLARIFIES THAT GENERAL INTENT
TO INTERFERE WITH A PERSON'S
CIVIL RIGHTS IS SUFFICIENT TO
BRING A SUIT UNDER THE BAN
AKKOR AT SPECIFIC CONTENT. IS
THE CURRENT STANDARD TODAY A
STANDARD THAT IS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET WITHOUT
ADMISSION FROM THE OFFICER WHO
COMMITTED THE MISCONDUCT. TO
INSURE THAT A FAMILY MEMBER OF
THE PERSON KILLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ALSO ABLE TO
ASSERT A CALLS OF ACTION AND
FINALLY CLARIFIES THAT THREE OF
THE MOST EGREGIOUS IMMUNITIES
CALMLY ASSERT ASSERTED. BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE NOT APPLICABLE
TO THE CLAIMS BROUGHT UNDER THE
BANNER ACT THESE INCLUDE
PLANTING EVIDENCE OR FRAMING
SOMEONE INJURING A PRISONER.
FOR FAILING TO PROVIDE MEDICAL
CARE. TO PRISONERS IN THEIR
CUSTODY. THESE ARE. THAT ARE
VOTE OF AND- TO AND POLICING.
ABILITY AND RESTORE COMMUNITY
TRUST AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SECONDLY THIS BILL CREATES A
STATEWIDE PROCESS TO REVOKE THE
CERTIFICATION OF AN OFFICER
AFTER THE CONVICTION OF A
SERIOUS CRIME. OR TERMINATION
FROM EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
MISCONDUCT. WE'RE NOW ONE OF
ONLY FOUR STATES IN THE NATION
THAT DOES NOT HAVE A SYSTEM FOR
DECERTIFYING BAD OFFICERS AND
I'M GONNA RESTATE THIS IS FOR
BAD OFFICERS NOT THE MAJORITY
OF MEN AND WOMEN WHO PUT THE
UNIFORM ON AND BACK INTO THEIR
JOB CORRECTLY EACH AND EVERY
DAY. WE WANT TO THANK THEM A
RECOGNIZABLE THIS IS FOR THE
BAT OFF ACTORS THAT WE KNOW
EXIST AND ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO REVOKE
THE CITRIX CERTIFICATION OR
LICENSE OF A BACK TO BACK
DOCTORS. ABOUT LAWYERS. BRAD
BARBERS AND COSMETOLOGISTS AND
WE CAN EVEN REMOVE BAD
POLITICIANS BUT WERE UNABLE TO
DE CERTIFY POLICE OFFICERS WHO
HAVE BROKEN THE LAW AND
VIOLATED PUBLIC TRUST. FOR
EXAMPLES BARBERS CAN LOSE THEIR
LICENCE ARE HOW ONE REVOKED FOR
INCOMPETENCE GROSS NEGLIGENCE
NEGLIGENCE OR DRUNKENNESS OR
EVEN FALSE AND DECEPTIVE
ADVERTISEMENT. FOR OFFICERS WHO
DON'T REQUIRE ANY FOLLOW UP
AFTER THEIR INITIAL. BUT IF BUT
ALFS IS DAMAGED REQUIRE ANY
INITIALLY. RECEIVE THEIR
CERTIFICATION AND FOLLOW UP I
SHOULD SAY AFTER INITIAL
CERTIFICATION WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE A PROCESS FOR REQUIRING
DEPARTMENTS TO COMPLETE AN
INVESTIGATION AFTER OFFICER HAS
REASON RESIGNED OR BEEN FIRED
DUE TO MISCONDUCT. IN FACT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM INCENTIVIZES
OFFICERS TO LEAVE AN APARTMENT
BEFORE THEY ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND TO MOVE TO A DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY WE CALL THIS THE WASH
RINSE REPEAT CYCLE THAT HAS
GONE ON FOR FAR TOO LONG- AND
AGAIN THE MOTHER CHAPEL WAS
AGAIN THE OFFICER WHO SHOT.
KENNETH ROSS JUNIOR HE HAD.
BEEN INVOLVED IN THREE
QUESTIONABLE SHOOTINGS IN
ORANGE COUNTY. AND HE LEFT THAT
DEPARTMENT BEFORE BEING FIRED
ONLY TO BE HIRED BY THE CITY OF
GARDENA. THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE
IN CALIFORNIA STATE THEIR
PRIDES ITSELF IN BEING A LEADER
ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE. AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY HAVING ADVOCATES
RECOGNIZE AND AGREE. THAT THIS
IS A PROBLEM HOWEVER WE ALSO
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY IS
INSUFFICIENT. UNITY'S KNOW WHO
THE BAD OFFICERS ARE BETTER IN
THEIR- IN THEIR LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE MANY OF
THEM ARE SIGNED TO BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES OR
COMMUNITIES OF LOW INCOME. IT
IS SO RARE THAT THESE OFFICERS
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN COURT
OR HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY THEIR
OWN DEPARTMENT. IF THEY'RE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE THIS WILL BE. BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT THESE BAD
OFFICERS WILL NOT TAKE THIS
MISCONDUCT TO ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT IN ANOTHER COMMUNITY.
FAR TOO OFTEN THESE GUYS GO TO
THE SMALLER- DEPARTMENT WE DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO ALLEN
ACADEMY AND- TRAIN THEIR OWN
OFFICERS SO THERE I WILL GLADLY
TAKE OFFICERS WHO HAVE COME
FROM A BIGGER DEPARTMENT
DESPITE THEIR BACKGROUND IN
HISTORY. THIS IS DOROTHY IS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
CREATING AN EFFECTIVE THE
CERTIFICATION SYSTEM. WE WILL
ALSO BE CREATING AN ADVISORY
BOARD WITHIN POLLS THAT WOULD
MAKE INITIAL RECOMMENDATIONS ON
WHETHER POST SHOULD DECERTIFY
AN OFFICER AND FINALLY THIS
BILL ALLOWS THE COMMISSION TO
DEFINE BY REGULATION THE
SPECIFIC GROUNDS OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT CONDUCT THAT WOULD.
BE CONSIDERED FOR
DECERTIFICATION SYRUP SYRUP
SEVERAL OF THESE EGREGIOUS
GROUNDS ARE LAID OUT IN THE
BILL SUCH AS SEXUAL SAW.
DISHONESTY AND ABUSE OF POWER
AMONG OTHERS ULTIMATELY THE
COMMISSION HAS AUTHORITY TO
DEFINE WHAT EXACTLY IS
MISCONDUCT THAT CAN BE THAT CAN
LEAD TO DECERTIFICATION. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL IS
STILL WORK IN PROGRESS AND WE
REMAIN COMMITTED. TO ENGAGE
WITH THE STAKE HOLDERS BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITY
AT LARGE BUT CHANGE MUST COME
TO POLICING IN CALIFORNIA AGAIN
WE'RE ONE OF ONLY FOUR STATES
IN THE NATION IT'S NOT HAVE A
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS.
MEANINGFUL REFORM NOT JUST
SUPERFICIAL CHANGES TO KEEP THE
STATUS QUO IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS
POLICE. TO BE ACCOUNTABLE ONLY
TO THEMSELVES. THIS IS WHAT
CALIFORNIA ACROSS OUR STATE
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
ARE DEMANDING AS WELL AS THE
NATION. CALIFORNIANS DESERVE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY CAN
TRUST WILL TREAT THEM FAIRLY.
AND WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
WHEN THE ABUSE THAT TRUST. THIS
BILL IS A PRIORITY ONCE AGAIN
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IS
SPONSORED BY COMEDIAN
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS AND
SUPPORTED BY THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE LOOKING
TO US TO PASS MEANINGFUL
REFORMS IN THIS AREA.
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF.
OUR TO INDIVIDUALS WHOSE LIVES
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY BAD OFFICERS
WHO TOOK THE LIVES OF THEIR
LOVED ONES. BUT HE'S A ALAMO
GROUP. OUR MOTHER OF CAN THE
FRONT JUNIOR. PAN MACHIKO
MONTERROSA SISTER SCHON
MONTERROSA WILL BE TESTIFYING
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE THEM
BOTH FOR TEARING ABOUT SHARING
THEIR STORIES AND TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. I BELIEVE- MISS MON TO
ROSE IS HERE PRESENT TODAY AM I
CORRECT YES WE'LL START WITH-
AND- I. WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
HELLO EVERYONE I'M HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO WHICH
WOULD CREATE A MECHANISM FOR
DECERTIFICATION THIS CERTIFYING
OFFICERS WHO ARE UNFIT TO WEAR
A BADGE. I AM MICHELLE
MONTERROSA ALONG LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE SURVIVING SISTER OF MY
BROTHER SHOT MONTH THAT ALSO.
WHAT OUR FAMILY HAS BEEN PUT
THROUGH BY THE VALLEJO POLICE
DEPARTMENT WOULD TAKE MORE THAN
THE TIME I HAVE HERE TODAY I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT. THE
WAYS IT ILLUSTRATES THE NEED
FOR SB TWO. ON JUNE SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY SEAN WAS UNARMED
KNEELING WITH HIS HANDS UP WHEN
OFFICER JERK TIME. THE VALLEJO
POLICE DEPARTMENT SHOT THROUGH
THE WINDSHIELD UNMARKED PICKUP
TRUCK BUT THAT THEY ARE
FIFTEEN. JOHN WAS KILLED
INSTANTLY. THESE ARE THE ONLY
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT CANNOT BE
DECERTIFIED FOR UNETHICAL AND
HARMFUL ACTIONS. VIRTUALLY
EVERYONE ELSE FROM BART BARBERS
TO LAWYERS WILL LOSE THEIR
LICENSE IF THEY VIOLATE.
VIOLATE THE TRUST PLACED IN
THEM BY THE STATE. THIS IS ALSO
A PERSONAL ISSUE FOR ME AS IT
IS FOR MANY FAMILIES HAVE LOST
A LOVED ONE TO POLICE VIOLENCE.
THE OFFICER WHO SHOT JOHN
DETECTIVE JERRY TIME. HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN FOUR OTHER OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS IN THE PAST
FIVE YEARS. BEFORE TRANSFERRING
TO THE VALLEJOPOLICE
DEPARTMENT. OFFICER TIME WORK
FOR. PD MORE HE WAS INVOLVED IN
AT LEAST ONE SHOOTING THAT WE
KNOW UP. IMMEDIATELY AFTER
SHAUN WAS SHOT OFFICER TIME CAN
BE HEARD IN THE FOOTAGE SAYING
I DIDN'T NEED THIS TODAY. TO
WHICH A SENIOR COMMANDING
OFFICER RESPONDED BY SAYING
IT'S OKAY WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
THIS BEFORE. CHANGED SINCE
JOHN'S DEATH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE- VALLEJO POLICE UNION.
ORDERED THE DESTRUCTION OF
EVIDENCE IN OUR BROTHER'S CASE
BEFORE AN INVESTIGATION COULD
BE CONDUCTED. IT'S COME TO
LIGHT THAT THE VALLEJO POLICE
DEPARTMENT'S ACTIONS. FOR THE
MOST DEADLIEST IN THE COUNTRY.
WE'VE ALSO LEARNED THAT THE
POLICE UMBILICAL BENDER BADGES
TO MARK HOW MANY BODIES THEY'VE
KILLED. THIS IS IN NO WAY AN
ISOLATED CASE THERE ARE MANY
OTHER FAMILIES NOT JUST IN
VALLEJO BUT IT ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WHO HAVE SIMILAR
STORIES ABOUT THE WAYS THAT THE
POLICE HAVE SWEPT THE DEATHS OF
THEIR LOVED ONES UNDER THE
RENTS. POLICE SIMPLY POLICE
CANNOT POLICE THEMSELVES. SB
TWO WILL ALLOW POST TO CONDUCT
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATIONS WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES DISTORT OR
SUPPRESS EVIDENCE IS. LIKE THE
VALLEJO POLICE DEPARTMENT DID
IN MY BROTHER'S CASE. THERE IS
MORE OF OUR URGENCY FOR US TO
PASS S. B. TWO AND WE HOPE THAT
THIS IS THE YEAR WE CAN SEE
REAL ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT WITNESS. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY
GREAT. HI I AM THE MOTHER OF-
DRAWS JUNIOR I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL SB TO MY SON- CANNOT
WAS MURDERED BY OFFICER MICHAEL
ROBBINS ON APRIL ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. HE WAS SHOT
IN THE BACK WITH A R. FIFTEEN
MILITARY ASSAULT WEAPONS FOR
RUNNING AND DOING NOTHING JUST
BEING BLACK- THIS OFFICER. WAS
NEVER PROSECUTED- TO START YOUR
ROBIN OF GUARDIAN POLICE
MURDERED MY SON HERE AT SHAH.
THREE OTHER PEOPLE IN SEPARATE
INCIDENTS HE WAS REMOVED FROM
HIS JOB IN ORANGE COUNTY. BUT
TO GET ANOTHER POSITION IN
GARDENA THEY SHOULD HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED BUT IT HAPPENS ALL TOO
OFTEN WHEN THE POLICE KILL
HEARD IN ABUSE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. AND THEY'RE ALMOST
NEVER PROSECUTED AT THE VERY
LEAST WE SHOULD TAKE THEIR GUNS
AND BADGES. SB TWO WOULD DO-
WERE ALL IN EFFECT IN LAW IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MARKS
FROM TROUBLED STILL BE HERE
INSTEAD I'M TRYING TO GET THE
BLOG. IN ORDER MY SON JENNIFER
ARGUING HERE AND IN MANY OTHER
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN THAT
GAMES AND THE FAMILIES ARE ALL
YOUR DRINKS AND POLICE ARE NOT
BEING PROSECUTED. BY WHAT
THEY'RE DOING- I NEED LAW I
MEAN IT'S GOING TO BE PASSED.
OUT NOT JUST AN HONOR MYSELF
BUT ALL THE FAMILY THAT HAVE
BEEN GOING TO THIS AND ALSO TO
PER BATCH OTHER FAMILIES FROM
GOING. THEIR IN THEIR CHILDREN
BEING MURDERED OUT HERE AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO-
MISTER BRADLEY EVERYBODY ELSE
IS A PART OF THIS. BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO AN WANT TO TEST.
TO OF SB TWO. DO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE EACH SIDE-
WILL BE PERMITTED TO MINUTES
PER PRIMARY WITNESS ALL OTHER
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. FIFTEEN MINUTES WILL
BE ALLOTTED FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
WITH THIS IS TERRY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. TO HAVE ANY
MINISTER WITNESSES HERE IN FOR.
FORTY TWO OR THREE. YOUR IS
TESTIFYING SUPPORT OF SB TWO.
HELLO. THANK YOU HELLO WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE THIS MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. FEET TWO WILL
BEGIN. YES ONE CAN LEAVE DOWN
THE DO IS TO ACT AS A OF SB TWO
IS PRESSED ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MARK HE PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TIME NUMBER OF WAITING
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE. AT
THIS TIME WE ARE AT EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HE WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUAL WE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU THE FIRST TIME CAN BE
SEVEN OH NINE IT'S GO AHEAD.
I'M SURE MEMBERS THIS IS CURTIS
LANE WITH A CALIFORNIA NURSE.
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TIME YOU GO TO THAT IS NOT MY
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE IS TO
LEAVE THE SHOPPING OF THE OVER
TWENTY NINE. MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION AND
PRECOR I DON'T FEEL LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF. FOR THE TO CARRY OF
SANTA. THANK YOU. IT WAS A LINE
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY NINE. GO
AHEAD. I ONLY I'M IN FROM WE- A
STOCKWELL LIKE ROGER TOLD
SOMEBODY OUR INSTRUCT THE COURT.
THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER SIX
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KIM TOLD STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
NEXT ONE ONE NUMBER SEVEN
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYWAY MCCARTY ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT IN LINE
NUMBER SIX NINETY TWO GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MALIK BYNUM WHAT YOU W.
ASKING LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
WORKOUT COSPONSORS OF THE BILL
AND WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER OF SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WILLIAM APPEARED ON BEHALF OF
THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
AND THE COURT. AND NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER SIX THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT ARE YOU
DOING HERE MOTHER VERNA TRAINS
JUNIOR BURGER BY JOHN MEDIA JOT
AROUND TO GET THE DEER I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NUMBER
LINE NUMBER SIX THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ONE RUBALCABA ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT- IN
SUPPORT. NUMBER ONE NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON WAS A BIT OF A SILLY
CALIFORNIA ACTION CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT WALDRON
INTERESTED COMING IN A READ OFF
A LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ASKED ME TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
AS WELL I THAT SHOULD SPARK
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA- CHARGES YOU
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER JOURNEY THE
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIANS ARE
STATE THE INJUSTICE NACKSTRAND
CALIFORNIA VOICES FOR PROGRESS.
PROSECUTORS ALIGNED THE
CALIFORNIA HELLO BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES NORTHRIDGE
INDIVISIBLE. NATIONAL POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS THE CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION CONSUMER WATCHDOG
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE. WE
THE PEOPLE LESS DETAIL IS THAT
THE COMMUNITY S. B. THANK TAKE
MANY ASIAN SOLIDARITY
COLLECTIVE SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE AT THE- SHOWING
UP FOR RACIAL JOHN. NORTH
COUNTY SB ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER INITIATE JUSTICE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS. THE CALIFORNIA
INNOCENT COALITION IN POWER IN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES WERE JUST
THE MORAL GOVERNANCE. BEND THE
ARC JEWISH ACTION CALIFORNIA
ROOTS OF CHANGE ORANGE COUNTY
EQUALITY COULD HELP COALITION
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA. FRESNO BODY- TO
NATO'S. JEFF WITHIN NETWORK AT
NATIONAL LAWYERS GUILD AT THAT
AREA AND. SAN DIEGO PRIDE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT IN WILL
GO TO LINE UP SIX SIXTY SEVEN
GO OUT. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL WHY I'M A COMPOSER THE
COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO AND I'M IN
FAVOR TO SUPPORT. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER SEVEN THIRTEEN IS
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS CAROLYN
BROWN BLUE FOR ASSEMBLY.
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED
PROJECTED AND THE ALLEN COOPER
FOUNDATION MY SON WAS ALLEN DO
WAY INCLUDE FOR MURDER BY
OFFICER MIGUEL NATIONAL OUT OF
OAKLAND POLICE DEPARTMENT I AM
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO B.
CERTIFICATION. LAW THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER SEVEN OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
SHEILA DATE WITH BLACK LIVES
MATTER LOS ANGELES A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL CALLING TO
SUPPORT ENCOURAGE YOU GOT VOTE
I'M ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
H. P. P. P. THE ANTI POLICE
TERROR PROJECT YOU WITHOUT THE
PROPER CODE BONDURANT ALSO
URGING ABOUT. YES THANK YOU. IT
THANKS SIMILAR LINE NUMBER
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS CESAR
ESPINOSA PEREZ- WITH SALT
DECRIMINALIZE SEX WORK
CALIFORNIA COALITION AND I'M
STRUCK STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO THANK YOU. BUT. NEXT ONE
LINE NUMBER SIX EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW YOU DOING
MY NAME IS BLACK JACKSON DO YOU
JUSTICE COALITION UMBRELLA YOU
PROVIDING CLINICIANS- AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. TWO
NUMBER LINE NUMBER SIX NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.GOOD
AFTERNOON SIMILAR SUBCHANNEL
WITH YOU JUSTICE COALITION IN
SOUTH CENTRAL GUARDINO RESIDENT
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER SIX OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS ADAM WHAT A
KING I'M THE CHAIR OF THE
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE UNIVERSALIST
UNITARIAN CHURCH RIVERSIDE BOTH
OF ORGANIZER IN THE
CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE
ARE EAGLE CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
STRONG OR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER SIX FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'LL BE
GOING MY NAME IS CLONAL JOHNSON
A MEMBER OF THE MONEY COMMUNITY
CHURCH AND WITH PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WELL
NUMBER ONE SEVEN THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LAST HELLO
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL ALSO ON BEHALF OF YOUR
CALORIES INSTANCE STRONG
SUPPORT. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER SIX EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KHAN ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES UNITED FOR JUSTICE AND
THE MILD POTTSTOWN ASIAN.
AMERICANS THAN MY SON MILES
POSSIBLY SHOT MAMA CREEK POLICE
DEPARTMENT ON JAN SECOND. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND I SUPPORT
S. B. DECERTIFICATION R. SB TWO
DECERTIFICATION ARE THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE SEVEN FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ONE OF THE J. VAZQUEZ
POLICY COORDINATOR CONFUSION
ARTICLE WE STARTED YOU JUSTICE
I'M PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB TWO.
BUT WE REQUEST YOUR WILL THANK
YOU. THANKS ONE LINE NUMBER SIX
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
STATE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT. NOW THE LINE
NUMBER SEVEN OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ERICA I AM
FROM YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW CAN BE
ONE ONE SEVEN FORTY THREE USED
BY HEAD. BY CIARA MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OUTSTANDING AS
WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
SEVEN FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- I'M ARM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THREE TO
ANDERSON WITH THE ARK IN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT. IT AND NUMBER LINE
NUMBER SEVEN TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS YEAR CALL IN- IN SUPPORT
OF SB POINT. I AM A MEMBER OF
OPPOSITION ALSO CULTURE BY ON
NOT A ONE WAS KILLED THANKS TO
THE EIGHTEEN WHAT WILL PLEASE
OPTIONS OF THE ALSO IS BEING IN
CHARGE WITH A CAR IS DOWN THANK
YOU. NOW WOULD LINE UP SIX
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX
THIRTY LINE IT'LL- THAT NAME
YES PLEASE- MY NAME IS BOBBY
ACTORS THEY CAN BE WHAT-
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED THE
DEPTH OF THE LOVE NOT BLOOD
CAMPAIGN AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TO AS WELL AS
WE ARE CO SPONSORS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AT THIS TIME I
HAVE NO OTHERS IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SB. TWO
SACRAMENTO. YOUR PERSON IF YOU
WISH TO BE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT. SIX TWENTY
FOUR LINE NUMBER SIX ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. IN THE
DRIVEWAY AS A PICKLE CALIFORNIA
IN OUR- FEDERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND AIRBORNE I
PROJECT DELHI BOYS IN THE
VALLEY SACRAMENTO ACT BACK IN A
CLARA. HEY YOU'RE HEARD IN THE
COUNTRY PROTECT THE. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL ON
MY NUMBER SIX FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER SIX FIFTY
FOUR YEAR OPEN. NOW ANYONE
NUMBER SIX NINE HE. YES BOTHER
OF BROWN'S MURDERED BY OUR
REGION WHICH APARTMENT ON
SEPTEMBER FOURTEENTH TWENTY
FOURTEEN I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
BOB DOBBS SAID ABOUT ZERO ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE FAMILY UNITED
FOR JUSTICE THANK YOU. DO IT.
IS NOW IN YOUR LAN NUMBER SEVEN
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO- MY NAME IS AMANDA MY
UNCLE- I WORK FOR THE AND
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER ONLINE
CALLING A STRONG SUPPORTER OF-
S. B. CHIU MY BROTHER ERIC
SANTIAGO WAS MURDERED- ON JUNE
SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY- AND- THE-
DPW KERR THAT CHILDREN. ARE
MURDERED HIM AT ALSO DID THE
SAME THING FOUR YEARS AGO PRIOR
BARGES HENDERSON SCIENCE ON
CORNER ENTRY TO THE
DECERTIFICATION. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A NUMBERS FOUR NINE
PLEASE AHEAD. YES OCAL BOBBY.
THE UNCLE OF OSCAR. ASSEMBLY
UNITED BUT JEFF ARE CO SPONSORS.
AND WE AS A- OF THE NEEDS OF.
S. B. I ALWAYS. NUMBER YOU
ALLOW NUMBERS THIRTY IS GO
AHEAD WE HAVE NINE ONE YEAH.
LEADING CALL BE BY. I AM THE OF
BEFORE THAT WAS A- IS STOPPING
APPOINT BOB BAGWELL. AND I WILL-
THEM TO UNITED BUT AND LAW OF
THINK THE IN COURT. AND WE NEED
SOME AND. THREE TWO. RESTART
THE- THANK YOU. NEVER GONNA
LINE NUMBER SEVEN OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CENTER IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND- STRONGLY ADVOCATE FOR
YOU YES SIR THANK YOU. FOR. IN
ORDER TO GO LINE NUMBER SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME
IS VALERIE VARGAS ON THE ON
THE- ASKING YOU ARE YOU THANK
YOUNG WITH THE COURT SB TWO
BECAUSE OF THE CREATION. NOW
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE NUMBER
SEVEN FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PETER THOMSON. HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY. MY NAME
IS A CREATIVE THOMPSON- FROM
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED FOR
JUSTICE AND MY GRANDSON STEPHON
CLARK WAS MURDERED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. MARCH EIGHTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AND
I'M A SUPPORT OF THE S. B. P.
SB TWO. HOW DO YOU TO ONE OF
SEVEN FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME OF MOTHER EARTH DAY
FROM G. AND WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. I'M. I MET HIM 2% THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WE WILL NOT FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TO LEAVE OPPOSITION. I THINK WE-
AND JONATHON FELDMAN. IS
CALLING FOR WILLIAM ON THE LINE.
I AM. PLEASE GO AHEAD. BEFORE I
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO CONVEY MY
SINCERE GRATITUDE IN BEING
INVITED TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING MY NAME IS ALAN
COULD BE ALMA AND I SERVED AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE ALAMEDA
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION-
ORGANIZATION WITHIN THE GREATER
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATION. KNOWN AS KORAC OR
THE PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
CHIPS IT'S INCEPTION LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN IN A
CONSTANT STATE OF PERFORMANCE
AND PRACTICE BEEN A
LONGSTANDING LEADER THROUGH
THIS PROCESS ADVOCATING FOR
VICTIMS RIGHT. HIGHER TRAINING
AND RECRUITMENT STANDARDS
ELIMINATION OF QUOTAS AND MORE
COMMUNITY BASED POLICING TO
NAME A FEW H. CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE ABOUT
IMPROVING THE PRACTICE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT WE ALL SHARE
THE SAME GOAL. TO KEEP OUR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES STATE.
I AM PLEASED THAT YOU'VE
INVITED ME TODAY'S TALK ABOUT
SENATE BILL TWO. DEVELOPING
LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH A
LICENSURE PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
IS A PRIORITY FOR PORAC. NO ONE
WANTS TO SEE ABOUT OFFICERS
REMOVED FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
MORE THAN GOOD OFFICERS DO.
WHEN AN OFFICER ACTS IN A WAY
THAT IS GROSSLY INCONSISTENT
WITH THE MISSIONS AND GOALS OF
OUR PROFESSION IT GIVES ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT A BAD NAME. AND
ONLY HARMS OUR ABILITY TO BUILD
BACK THE COMMUNITY TRUST WE
NEED TO CARRY OUT OUR SERVICE
SHAPELY AND EFFECTIVELY.
HOWEVER SB TWO IS NOT THE RIGHT
APPROACH. SB TO CREATE A
POTENTIALLY BIASED PANEL TO
OVERSEE THE PROCESS OF REVOKING
AN OFFICER'S LICENSE TO
PRACTICE LAW ENFORCEMENT
IGNORING OUR COUNTRY'S
TRADITION OF DUE PROCESS AND
SUBJECTING OFFICERS TO A BIASED
REVIEW OF THEIR ACTIONS WERE
GUILT IS ASSUMED AND THE DECK
IS STACKED AGAINST THEM. SHE
WILL SB TWO IS BEING PRESENTED
AS THE POLICE REFORM MEASURE
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH A NEW
LICENSING PROCESS. THE TRUTH IS
THAT S. B. T. REACHES FAR
BEYOND THE POLICE LICENSING
PROCESS INCLUDES POLICIES THAT
WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO ALL
CALIFORNIA CITIES. COUNTIES AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. MY TESTIMONY
TODAY WILL FOCUS PRIMARILY ON
THE FLOOR LICENSING PROTOCOL
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS WHERE
WE WILL FIND THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER
TOWARDS FINDING A COMPROMISE
THAT WILL BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING BOTH
OFFICERS AND THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE. I ALSO WANT TO SHINE A
LIGHT ON THE FACT THAT AS
WRITTEN SB TWO WOULD OPEN THE
FLOODGATES OF LITIGATION
AGAINST ALL PUBLIC OFFICIALS
NOT JUST LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BURDENING CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COUNTIES WITH UNSUSTAINABLE
LEGAL COSTS FORCING BUDGET CUTS
FOR BIO. PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
WE CANNOT ALLOW OFFICERS TO
DAMAGE. GROSSMITH TAKEN TO BE
MA'AM OF THE COURSE PROFESSION.
THEIR LIVES IN MY BE REVOKED.
HOWEVER WRITTEN SB TWO WOULD
OVER RIDE DUE PROCESS.
ESTABLISHING A NINE PERSON
PANEL TO OVERSEE THE LICENSE
REVOCATION PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WITH NO REQUIREMENTS FOR
EXPERTISE OR PRIOR EXPERIENCE
IN THE PRACTICE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY OR LAW ENFORCEMENT. WITH
TO THE SEVEN HAVING BEEN
SUBJECT TO THE LONG FOR USE OF
FORCE OR RELATED TO SOMEONE
SUBJECT TO THE WRONGFUL USE OF
COURSE. AND ONLY TWO MEMBERS
WITH EXPERTISE OR PRIOR STREETS.
EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
IT'S AN UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY AND
EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS. INCLUDING THOSE
CHARGED WITH MAKING SPLIT
SECOND LIFE OR DEATH DECISION
TO HELP KEEP OUR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES STATE. UNDER
AMERICAN RULE OF LAW ONCE A
COURT OR TRIBUNAL HAS FOUND
ANNOUNCER INNOCENT OF THE
ALLEGED MISCONDUCT SHE OR SHE
SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECTED TO
DOUBLE JEOPARDY MEANING THE
CONCURRENT OR CONSECUTIVE
RELATED CATION OF IDENTICAL
FACTUAL. AND LEGAL DISPUTE. SB
TO IGNORE THIS BASIC TENET OF
FAIRNESS BY ALLOWING COULD BE
LITIGATING OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS. AND
WILL RESULT IN INCONSISTENT AND
INCOMPATIBLE LEGAL AND FACTUAL
DETERMINATIONS. THE PURPOSE OF
DOUBLE JEOPARDY IS TO PROTECT
CITIZENS FROM BEING PROSECUTED
FOR THE SAME OFFENSE SAME
OFFENSE AFTER BEING ACQUITTED.
THAT IS BECAUSE WE AND- HAVE
DETERMINED THAT IT WOULD NOT
SERVE THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE
TO PLACE SOMEONE TWICE FOR
LIBERTY IN JEOPARDY TWICE FOR
THE SAME OFFENSE. THE SAME
PRINCIPLE MUST APPLY TO THE
PROCESS THE POLICE LICENSURE.
IF AN OFFICER'S EXONERATED
THROUGH OUR PROCESS OVERSEEN BY
AN INDEPENDENT BODY IT WOULD
NOT BE RIGHT TO PLACE OUR
OFFICERS CAREER REPUTATION AND
LIVELIHOOD IN JEOPARDY TWICE BY
GRANTING THIS PANEL THE
AUTHORITY TO OVERTURN THAT
DECISION. THAT IS WHY PRICE
SUPPORTS GRANTING THE PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING%
COMMISSION AS AN INDEPENDENT
CIRCLING GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
FORTY TO OVERSEE THE POLICE
LICENSURE PROGRAM WHICH IN PART
WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PROVOKE AN OFFICER'S LICENSE
FOR SPECIFIC INSTANCES
APPROVING OFFICER MISCONDUCT
SUCH AS SUSTAINED MISCONDUCT TO
THE USE OF EXCESSIVE FORCE.
SHALL ANY CONVICTIONS OR
CONVICTIONS OF SPECIFIED
MISDEMEANORS. SEXUAL CALLED.
JOB RELATED TO. MR CUYAMA GONNA
PREVIOUS IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
JUST WRAPPING IT UP REALLY
QUICK WE ARE WE'VE GIVEN YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN THE TWO
MINUTES ALLOTTED. SURE WITHOUT
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE TIME- THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER AND I HOPE WE CAN ALL
JOIN TOGETHER AT THE TABLE TO
COME UP WITH A SPARE PROGRAM
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO PROTECT.
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR OBAMA- OUR
NEXT WITNESS IS JONATHON
FELDMAN IS MR FELDMAN ON THE
LINE. YES VENTURE PLEASE MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU AND I'LL BE
BRIEF- NOT TO REITERATE THE
COMMENTS ON THE CALL WITH CORK-
BUT I ALSO LIKE THANK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND
COME UP WITH THIS POLICY
FORWARD WE ARE ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO FIND A COMMON
GROUND. ON AN ISSUE THAT I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE- THE
CHAPLAIN TOLD. THE POLICE YOU
US. SUPPORTS TWO. HOLY I'D LIKE
TO START BY TALKING ABOUT THE
AREAS THAT WE FIND AGREEMENT ON.
WITHIN THE BILL. WE AGREE THAT
ANY OFFICER FOUND GUILTY OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT SHOULD NO
LONGER BE AN OFFICER WHICH
INCLUDES EXCESSIVE FORCE
FAILURE TO INTERCEDE SEXUAL
ASSAULT INTENTIONAL DISHONESTY
WRONGFUL ARREST ABUSE OF POWER
BIASED POLICING. OR ACTIVE
PARTICIPATION IN ORGANIZED
CRIMINAL CONDUCT I'M NOT THAT.
NO OFFICERS BEEN FOUND RIGHT
YES THAT SECRETARY CALL THE BE
POLICE IN OUR- AND THAT'S A-
HARD. DEFINITIVE BOB THAT
CENTER. AGENCY SHOULD ALSO WE
AGREE COMPLETE INVESTIGATE TO
MISS REGARDLESS OF AN OFFICER
RESIGNS IS TERM- PARTIALLY
THROUGH THOSE INVESTOR WHICH
SUPPORTED CALL LAST. THAT MAKES
ABSOLUTE SENSE ENSURE THAT NO
SHOULD POINT TO THE CRY. BUT WE
AGREE THAT THIS WHOLE PROCESS
NEEDS TO BE TRANSFERRED. WITH
PLACE REVIEW AND HOW AUDIT INTO
INVEST. AND THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD HAVE ALL CERTAINLY LED
BOARD WITHIN POST. PROVIDE THE
TECHNICAL. AND- CHOOSE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
REVIEW THE BACKGROUND OF EACH
OFFICER HIRING COME DONE SH
WHEN WE DO. ON THE BILL. IS-
USED CREATED UNDER THE BAN ACT
WHICH GOES BEYOND EVEN GENERAL
INTENT IN A LOWER THAN THAT
FROM SPECIFIC CONTENT. TO THE
STANDARD. BUT DELIVERED A TO
RECORD AND THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
A THERE'S A LOT OF KIND WITH
THAT STANDARD WE HAD A I THINK
OF CALL WITH SOME OF THE
SPONSORS BILL EARLY THIS WEEK-
AND I LOOKED TO CONTINUE THIS
CALL IN LOOKING IN- WHAT ABOUT
CHANGES IN THE- THAT WOULD MAKE
SENSE. WHEN WE THE OTHER BIG
ISSUES THAT WE DISAGREE THE
SCOPE AND- POWERS BILLING OR TO
CO. OP AS YOU CAN SERIOUSNESS
AGAINST FIRED REGULARLY. FINAL
DESTINATION TO THE BEST CASE
ARE MORE AND THOROUGH AND WE
DON'T THERE'S ANY. TO HIRE
UNDER OF INVEST- PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT POST DOESN'T
CURRENTLY ANY INVESTING TAKEN
OF DOING. REVIEWS AND THE
TECHNICAL THEY WOULD HAVE TO
HIRE. HUNDREDS TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF SB. NOT
ONLY WOULD YOU BE CA. TO COULD
HAVE BEEN. MEDICAL BEEN DONE
INSTEAD WE SHOULD RELAX. IN A
PART REVIEW FROM CHURCH. IN
THIS CROSS. ACTUALLY I'M NOT
SURE BUREAUCRACY. BUT STILL
MISSED PROCESS THANK THE OVER
THAT I MAY BEFORE WHICH WOULD
GIVE UNDERSTAND ISN'T. AND CAN
SOME OF THE LOS IN CERTAIN.
ANPING TEAM- THANK YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS-
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY ON THE
TRUMP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ERNEST FELDER. I APOLOGIZE WE
WENT- OVER TIME AND THE FIRST
WITNESSES SO IT DID GO INTO
THE- INTO YOUR TIME. LET'S MOVE
ON TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN. ROOM
FOUR THREE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO. C. NINE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO. C.
NINE. THANK YOU WILL NOW. MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCES
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO A TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION SB TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN OUR FIRST PURCHASE
WILL BE LINE SEVEN TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN SEVEN
TWENTY WOULD YOU PLEASE RE PROB
DON'T KNOW IT I YOU WENT OUT OF
Q. FOR SOME REASON WHAT WILL
MOVE ON TO SEVEN FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY NINE
THANKS FOR. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION SENATE
BILL TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO ONLINE. SEVEN SIXTEEN.
AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS NAOMI
PETRON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE OUTLINED SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PLEASE RE PROP AND
WE WILL GO TO SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. HI DEAR ALEUTIAN YEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE DEPUTY
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO
COUNTY- IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND SIX OH ONE YOU
ARE NOW UP. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RANDY PERRY WITH OUR REGION
SAYS IT'S ON BEHALF OF PORAC IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. AND NEXT WE
WILL ALIGN SIX THIRTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS AT
LEAST OUR CITY A COLONEL WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
SEVEN FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY READ ON BEHALF OF
KEEP CALIFORNIA SAFE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO. SEVEN
TWENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MADAM
CHAIR- ERIN READ REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN WERE IN
OPPOSITION ONE IDENTIFY WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY ALLEN
COULD BE I'M NOT AS WELL AS
JOHN FELDMAN QUICKLY WITH THOSE
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT A DECERTIFICATION BILL
AS LONG AS IT'S DONE IN A FAIR.
MANNER THANK YOU. THANK YOU S.
SEVEN FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
ROBERT JACK AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE ON TO A SEVEN TWENTY.
TRENCHER WITH RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION- AND
SANTANA POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA'S PLEASE
DOCTORS SUFFICIENT WALL IN
OPPOSITION SB TWO THANK YOU.
BRING ALONG SEVEN TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE CHAIR MEMBERS WILL BE IN
ABOUT THE ASSOCIATION ORANGE
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS ALONG
BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA KERNEL
OR POLICE CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION SACRAMENTO DEPUTY
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION. INSURE
COMPLETE BENEFIT ASSOCIATION
SAMBAR TO DINO COUNTY ALL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND IT FINALLY ROUTE REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN TO- GO
AHEAD TESTIFIED- AN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL SIMPLY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE. SEVEN TWENTY FOUR.
MADAM CHAIR ANDMEMBERS NOT
DECIDING ON BEHALF OCCASION FOR
LOS ANGELES DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIRMAN NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP. YOUR. OKAY A
MODERATE WOULD YOU MIND YEAH
WOULD YOU PLEASE CHECK THE
LINES AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. ABSOLUTELY AND AGAIN
IF YOU DO WISH TO ON TESTIFYING
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I'M SURE NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR- THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AFTER
ABOUT LONGER THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
REINTRODUCING THIS BILL- THE
ONE QUESTION HAD TO DO WITH THE
ARM. IT SAYS IN THE BILL THAT
IT WILL GRANT BECAUSE THE POWER
TO INVESTIGATE- AND SO I WAS
WONDERING IS THERE A LENGTH OF
TIME. IN THE BILL WITH REGARDS
TO HOW LONG AN INVESTIGATION
CAN BE GOING ON REGARDING A
POTENTIAL DECERTIFICATION. AND
I ASK BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES-
THESE EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME
FOR INVESTIGATION ARE ALSO USED
TO EITHER STALL OR TO DELAY-
DECISIONS OR- ACTIONS. THE
SPEAK TO SPECIFIC TIME BUT IT
IS OUR HOPES THAT THIS WILL BE
A EXPEDITED PROCESS THAT MAKES
IT FAIR TO THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE BEING INVESTIGATED NO
ONE WANTS TO PROLONG THIS SAME
TIME- WE WANT. JUSTICE TO BE
BROUGHT FOR THOSE FAMILIES WHO
HAVE CONCERNS AS TO THE CONDUCT
THAT IS UNDER REVIEW SO- IT
DIDN'T SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
TALK BUT- BERMAN HE IS IN AN-
EXPEDITING THIS PROCESS IS.
THIS TO ALL OF OUR BEST
ADVANTAGE. THE- OPPOSITION
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THIS BEING
DETRIMENTAL TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND- THE COST OPENING
THE FLOODGATES FOR- LAWSUITS-
BUT ALSO I THINK WHAT'S MAYBE
NOT WHAT WASN'T MENTIONED IS
THAT THERE ARE ALREADY TONS OF
COSTS THAT ARE LEVIED ON CITIES
AND COUNTIES I WITH REGARDS TO
THESE KINDS OF LAWSUITS
AGAINST- ROGUE LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S WHICH RESULT IN
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
LAWSUITS. AND SO I DON'T KNOW
I'M SURE YOU CAN SPEAK TO IT
BUT MAYBE THE OPPOSITION CAN
CAN SPEAK TO THE FACT THAT THAT
ALSO CURRENTLY GOES ON AND
WOULDN'T WE WANT- POLICY THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOW. FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO NOT HAVE
TO PAY OUT- THOSE- FEET THOSE
COSTS THOSE SETTLEMENT COSTS-
USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS- BY
COMING UP WITH A POLICY THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO.
EXPEDITIOUSLY LOOK INTO THIS
KIND OF MISCONDUCT AND PROVES
THAT PREVENTS CITIES AND
COUNTIES FROM HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THESE KINDS OF LAWSUITS.
IF ON THE I. VISION TO BUT I
WOULD LOVE FOR THEM TO MENTION
TO TALK ABOUT THIS. YEAH-
SENATOR COMMODITY JONATHON
FELDMAN WITH THE POLICE CHIEF
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I
THINK AGAIN THERE IS A LOT OF
AGREEMENT- THAT REMOVING BAD
OFFICERS HAS THAT BENEFITS NOT
JUST FOR THE COMMUNITIES AND
THOSE THAT THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY BE USED BUT ALSO
FOR THE CITIES ARE NO LONGER
LIABLE FOR THE BAD OFFICERS.
THAT'S WHY WE AGREE WITH
GETTING RID OF THEM. WHAT WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH IS CHANGES
TO THE CIVIL LIABILITY STATUTES
THAT LOWER THE STANDARDS TO A
POINT THAT. WE BELIEVE IT IS
DETRIMENTAL. A STANDARD THAT'S
BLOWN UP SAID IN AN OFFICER
ACTION SPLIT SECOND COULD STILL
POTENTIALLY BE CIVILLY LIABLE
FOR THAT THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT
IT WILL COMPLETELY CLOSED OFF
TO THE IDEAS OF CHANGING YOU
KNOW THE SPECIFIC INTENT
STANDARD WITHIN THE BANNACK-
BUT THE STANDARD PUT IN PLACE
CURRENTLY. WE HAVE CONCERNS
THAT AS WITH THE CITIES WHICH
NOTED BY THE WITNESS TO TESTIFY
AT FIRST- INCLUDES OTHER
PUBLIC- EMPLOYEES. OPERATING A
THEIR COULD THE PROFESSIONAL.
HUH WELL YOU ALSO MENTIONED
THAT DUE PROCESS WOULD BE
COMPROMISED AS A RESULT OF THIS
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
DECERTIFICATION STILL OFFERS
FULL AND FAIR DUE PROCESS PRIOR
TO ANY ADVERSE ACTION. DO YOU
AGREE WITH THAT. THAT I WOULD
SAY YOU KNOW WE HAVE LOOKS LIKE
TWO TRACKS UNDER THE BILL WE
HAVE THE LOCAL AGENCIES AND THE
LOCAL PROCESS AS BARGAINED WITH
THEIR PUBLIC EMPLOYEE UNIONS.
PRODUCE CROSSES INTO THE REVIEW
OF THEIR CONDUCT AND EDUCATION
THURMOND WHICH COULD INCLUDE IN
A COURT OF APPEALS- AND THEN WE
HAVE A SEPARATE PROCESS LAID ON
TOP OF THAT WE OPPOSE COULD
LOOK INTO IT EVEN IF THEY'VE
ALREADY GONE THROUGH THE FIRST
LOCAL PROCESS AND BEEN FOUND
YOU KNOW EITHER AND SUSTAINED
EXONERATED. BY THE COMPLETED
BEEN FOUNDED BY THEY COULD BE
RETRIED BY POST UNTIL DECEMBER
ALJ THAT ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE RUBIO- AND THEN FOUND
GUILTY AND THAT'S WHERE WE TALK
AND WE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
DOUBLE JEOPARDY OR CONCERNED
WITH- YOU KNOW BEING TRIED
TWICE THAT'S WHERE THE CONCERN
COMES. FROM THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE TWO SEPARATE. SIMILAR TO
THIS PROCESSES COULD BE. WOULD
RATHER SEE ONE STREAM PROCESS
THAT I DON'T. THE OFFICE WHO
ARE GUILTY OF MISCONDUCT THE
NUMBER THAT. I THINK IT ALLOWS
FOR- INVESTIGATION AND FULL
TRANSPARENCY. WHICH I THINK IS
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT-
YOU ALSO LAST QUESTION MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU WOULD INDULGE ME
IS THAT I ROMS. I RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT EVERYONE WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION THE KEY WITNESSES
SAID THAT IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET RID OF THOSE-
YOU KNOW ROGUE POLICE OFFICERS-
THIS IS A QUESTION MY
UNDERSTANDING AND PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IS
THAT- THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
VERY GOOD POLICE OFFICERS THAT
ARE WORKING. FROM IN THE FIELD
BUT THE ONES WHO ARE. ROGAN
COMMITTING THESE- WHERE THEY'RE
INVOLVED IN THESE INCIDENTS OF
GROSS MISCONDUCT. THEY'RE ABLE
TO ONCE THEY'RE TERMINATED OR
DISCIPLINED THEY ARE STILL ABLE
TO WEASEL INTO ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT- AND SO WHICH IS IN
ITS INFANT COMBIN UPON US TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO FERRET THOSE
BAD ACTORS OUT- BECAUSE THOSE
BAD ACTORS ARE NOT ONLY HARMING
THE PUBLIC BUT THEY'RE ALSO
DOING HARM TO THEIR PARTICULAR
DEPARTMENT- TO MAYBE TO THEIR
COLLEAGUES AND THEIR PARTNERS
INTO THE FOREST ARE WE IN
AGREEMENT ON THAT. YES WE ARE
IN AGREEMENT ON THAT AND THAT'S
YOU KNOW IN MY IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT I MENTIONED THAT YOU
KNOW. WE FULLY SUPPORT POLICY
THAT REQUIRES AGENCIES TO
COMPLETE THESE INVESTIGATIONS
REGARDLESS OF THE OFFICER
RESIGNS OR IS FIRED PART OF
THE- THE- FINAL OUTCOME. SO
THAT WE'RE NOT LETTING
INDIVIDUALS FALL TO THE CRACKS
AND ANY- REHIRED ELSEWHERE. SO
YOU KNOW AGAIN IN AGREEMENT-
YOU KNOW I THINK. ONE OF THE
ISSUES THOUGH. AND WE TALK
ABOUT ABOUT HOW LATERAL
TRANSFERS- OFFICERS BEING HIRED
ELSEWHERE- I THINK TO ALSO HELP
PREVENT THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT- INCLUDING OUR OUTREACH AND
RECRUITMENT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION OF PEACE OFFICERS
ENSURING THAT WE GET A MORE
DIVERSE MORE- REPRESENTATIVES
GROUP. COMING INTO THE
PROFESSION SO THAT WE'RE NOT
HAVING TO RECYCLE SOME OF THOSE
OFFICERS ARE PROBLEMS- YOU KNOW
RECRUITMENT HAS BEEN AN ISSUE.
FOR AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND
IT'S ONLY GETTING WORSE SO YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO DO A BETTER
JOB- BRINGING IN QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES INTO THE PROFESSION
AND ATTACHING THEM TO. THE
LEADERS IN THE SPACE. THAT'S
KIND OF WHERE WE WOULD SEE MORE
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE LONG
TERM- AND WE HAVE POLICIES THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE- THAT THAT YOU GET
TO SEE SAM- IN THE IN A MATTER
OF WEEKS- AND THE PART OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AS WELL.
THANK YOU I WANT TO SAY THAT
IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT JUST A
MATTER OF GETTING THESE FROM.
BAD ACTORS OFF THE STREETS
BECAUSE YOU CAN DO THAT AND
THEN THEY CAN STILL BE.
TRANSITIONED INTO DETECTIVE
STATUS OR SOME OTHER STATUS
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN WORKING AT
A DESK OR NOT REALLY WORKING
WITH THE GENERAL PUBLIC. BUT I
TELL YOU THAT GREAT HARM CAN
STILL BE DONE. BECAUSE THERE
ARE STILL OPPORTUNITIES TO
INTIMIDATE TO HARASS- TO IMPACT
THE CULTURE IN THAT DEPARTMENT.
TO FALSIFY RECORDS TO
INTIMIDATE WITNESSES AND SO IT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
BEGIN TO LOOK AT ALL OF THESE
ISSUES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
FROM THE STEM TO THE STERN SO
THAT WE CAN CREATE DEPARTMENTS
THAT. REPRESENT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
AND ALSO ARE ABLE TO REBUILD
THE TRUST WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THAT THEY ARE
ENTRUSTED TO PROTECT- AND SO
THIS I THINK IS WHAT THIS BILL
IS STRIVING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WECAN CREATE. THAT KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY- ON THE ONE END
SINCE WE CONTINUE TO ASK FOR
THOSE. WHO ARE LIVING IN THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
TO STEP UP WITH REGARDS TO- YOU
KNOW. THEIR OBLIGATION. TO BE A
PARTNER. I'M IN THIS THING WE
CALL PUBLIC SAFETY SO. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWERS
AND MADAM CHAIR FOR INDULGING
ME WITH THOSE QUESTIONS AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SENATOR I
BELIEVE I MISSPOKE WHEN I'M OFF
THE STREETS AND JOHN SORRY TO
INTERRUPT- I MEANT TERMINATED
FIRE DECERTIFIED NOT MOVED INTO
ANOTHER POSITION. ALL RIGHT IF
THE CLERK THAT REAL QUICK I WAS
JUST A COLLOQUIALISM. YEAH I
MEANT COMPLETELY REMOVED FROM.
THE PROFESSION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM.
SENATE WIENER I THANK YOU I'M
NOT SURE OF- WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'M PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL I JUST
THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE-
AND I'M SOMEONE WHO I'VE HAD.
EXPERIENCE WHEN I WAS THE
DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY- AND- YOU
KNOW AND THE KINDS OF CLAIMS
AND LAWSUITS THAT ARISE AROUND
PLACE AND I'VE SEEN THE GOOD
I'VE SEEN THE BAD AND I'VE SEEN
THE UGLY AND- YOU KNOW I THINK-
YOU KNOW THE IDEA. POLICING IS
A PROFESSION- AND IF SOMEONE IS
NOT GOOD ASSEMBLY IMPRESSION
ANYMORE AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO
JUST PUT FROM ONE DEPARTMENT TO
ANOTHER- AND YOU KNOW RESIGN
RESIGN IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
INVESTIGATION OR WHATEVER- AND
THEN AND THEN BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE ITS IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT
A GOOD GOVERNMENT AND IT'S NOT
GOOD FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OR FOR
THE COMMUNITY- AND SO- AS CO
AUTHOR AND- HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION I CAN'T
REMEMBER IF THERE WAS A MOTION
BUT IF NOT I MOVE THE BILL.
THERE ISN'T YET. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE OKAY SEE NO FURTHER
COMMITTEE COMMENTS I HAVE A FEW
THINGS I LIKE TO ADD- FIRST
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS TIRELESS EFFORT ON THIS
ISSUE. IT'S BEEN MADE CLEAR TO
ME THAT YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY ON THIS ON THIS
ENDEAVOR I'M OF INFIRM
AGREEMENT THAT IT IS WHOLLY
UNACCEPTABLE THAT WE ARE ONE OF
ONLY FOUR STATES RIGHT FOR
STATES THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
PROCESS IN PLACE TO HOLD THAT
OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE. I AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
STATEMENTS HE HAS MADE ON THE
SPELL OF ONE THAT IS
CALIFORNIA'S ABLE TO REVOKE THE
CERTIFICATION OF LICENSE. OR
LICENSES OF BAD OUT DOCTORS
LAWYERS TEACHERS AND EVEN
BARBERS BUT IS UNABLE TO DISH
THIS CERTIFIED POLICE OFFICERS
WHO HAVE BROKEN THE LAW. AND
VIOLATED THE PUBLIC TRUST THAT
IS UNACCEPTABLE. WE ENTRUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH GREAT POWER
AND AS SUCH IT IS REASONABLE
THAT THEY BE HELD TO A HIGH
STANDARD OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
HOWEVER I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL- THIS
BILL APPEARS TO MAKE THIS
CERTIFICATION MANDATORY FOR
BOTH. STATUTORY LIST OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND A SECONDARY
LIST OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. AS
DEFINED BY POST IN REGULATIONS.
THERE IS NO ANY INTERMEDIATE
ALTERNATIVE SANCTION FOR ANY
ACTION- SECTION FOURTEEN OF
YOUR BILL READS AS FOLLOWS. A
CERTIFIED P. PEACE OFFICER
SHALL HAVE THEIR CERTIFICATION
REVOKED AND IT UP WE CAN SHOW
HAVE THEIR OBLIGATION FOR CERT
DENIED. UPON A DETERMINATION
THAT THEY HAVE VIOLATED A SET
OF LIST OF OFFENSES IN THIS
BILL. SOME OF WHICH ARE WORDED
IN A PRETTY BROAD NATURE. OR IF
THEY HAVE BY LADY YET TO BE
DETERMINED REGULATIONS FROM
POST. FOR THE SHORT TIME I'VE
BEEN HRE ON THIS COMMITTEE
I'VE SEEN THAT THERE IS A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WE
ARE MAKING A MOVE AWAY FROM A
BLACK AND WHITE SENTENCING. AND
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT SOMETIMES
THERE IS A GREAT AREA. THE WAY
THIS BILL IS WRITTEN SEEMS TO
REQUIRE A LIFETIME TO
CERTIFICATION OF AN OFFICER
WITHOUT ANY REGARD TO
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING AN
INCIDENT. EVEN IF A LESSER
PUNISHMENT MIGHT BE MORE
APPROPRIATE HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
A MORE NUANCED APPROACH TO-
HERE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER THESE
PUNISHMENTS WITH REGARDS TO THE
SPECIFIC FACTS OF EACH CASE.
THAT'S WHAT THE BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATED THE INVESTIGATION
IT'S ALL ABOUT I MEAN THERE'S
SIX LAYERS TO THE INVESTIGATION
SO TO SAY THAT THERE'S A
BLANKET. DISMISSAL ONCE YOU'RE
DETERMINED TO BE CERTIFIED AS A
FOR THE FARTHEST THING FROM THE
TRUTH. THE OFFICER EVEN HAS-
TO. THE FINAL HEARING. FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE EVEN
IF IT WAS DETERMINED THAT THEY
SHOULD BE TO CERTIFY THEY CAN
STILL TAKE THAT DECISION TO
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES OF
THEIR WRISTS SIX STEPS. THAT
HAVE TO HAPPEN BEFORE AN
OFFICER IS DEEMED. DECERTIFIED
AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT THERE ARE
PLENTY CHECKS AND BALANCES HERE
AND YES THERE ARE SOME NUANCES.
CASE IN POINT I INDIVIDUAL WHO
THE USERS OF THIS DESCRIPTION-
A YEAR AGO OR SO. THERE WAS A-
CRIMINAL WHO HELD A KNIFE TO A
WOMAN'S THROAT ANY WAS THE
BURDEN THAT SLIT HER THROAT AND
IN THE PROCESS OF SELLING IT TO
THIRD BAY TRIED TO SHOOT TO.
THAT THE SUSPECT AND THEY
KILLED THE WOMAN THAT OFF YOU
SHOULDN'T LOSE HIS JOB FOR A
SITUATION LIKE THAT SO THERE
WILL BE CLEAR. DELINEATIONS
ASKED WHAT IS DEAN ON LAWFUL
AND WHAT IS THE TEAM IN THE
LINE OF DOING THEIR JOB SO. I
THINK TO CHECKS AND BALANCES
THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT ARE
HERE IN THIS BILL AND AGAIN
POLES TO HOUSE THE FINAL SAY AS
WELL AS TO EVEN IF THE CITIZEN
REVIEW COMMITTEE. THIS ARE.
WELL TO THE SEARCHES TO REVIEW
BECAUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT ALSO
MADE UP OF THE REVIEW
COMMISSION. POLL STILL. HAS THE
FINAL SAY TO REVIEW THEIR
DECISION. SO THERE ARE THERE
ARE. SIX FOR A OFFICER CAN BE
DECERTIFIED IN YOU CAN REJECT
CERTAIN ALL THOSE BASED ON NOT
MEETING THIS CRITERION NO
CERTIFICATION AND GET ALL THE
WAY DOWN HERE AND AGAIN WE
STILL HAVE A FINAL STEP WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE. THANK
YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
SENATOR BRADFORD- ADDITIONALLY.
I'M A STRONG BELIEVER IN FAIR
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW IN OUR
COUNTRY WHICH COINCIDENCE
COINCIDENTALLY IS WHY SUPPORT
DESERTIFICATION PROCESS-
HOWEVER DO HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT
THE MAKEUP OF THE BOARD. I
THINK THAT ONLY HAVING TWO OF
THE NINE MEMBERS WHO UNDERSTAND
THE PERSPECTIVE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND CAN PROVIDE
THE VALUABLE INSIGHT CREATES A
SYSTEM THAT MIGHT BE PERCEIVED
AS UNFAIR- I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT AT NOT PROMOTE OUT MAKE UP
OF THE OPPOSITE. A BOARD WITH
SEVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT RELATED
SEATS AND TO OUTSIDE
ORGANIZATIONS AS THAT WOULD NOT
BE A FAIR PROCESS FOR THE
PUBLIC. HAVE YOU CONSIDERED ANY
WAYS TO MAKE THIS BOARD A
LITTLE MORE BALANCED AND FAIR
TO ENSURE THAT YES BUT OFFICERS
ARE TO CERTIFIED IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IS ALSO PROTECTED BUT
ALSO THEY BRING THE OFFICERS
GET A FAIR HEARING. I THINK
THIS IS FAIR WE TRUST TWELVE
LEHMAN FROM THE COMMUNITY SAID
IN A JURY BOX AND DETERMINE
ONCE A LIFE OR DEATH. EVERY DAY
AND TRIALS BUT WE DON'T TRUST
SEVEN CITIZENS TO REVIEW LAW
ENFORCEMENT ALONG WITH. TWO
POLICE OFFICERS TO PEOPLE WOULD
LAW ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUNDS WE
HAVE NEGOTIATED- THAT
COMBINATION OF WE'VE LAST YEAR
WE HAD OFFERED FIVE AND FOUR.
WE HAD SIX AND THREE NOTHING
THE AGREED UPON SO WE'RE
STARTING BACK WITH WHAT. OUR
SUPPORTERS AND I WANT AND NOT
SEVEN INTO WE THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE FAIR THESE THE SEVEN
CITIZENS ARE NOT. HELLO ARE YOU
KNOW JUST PEOPLE WITH NO
BACKGROUND WE WANT PEOPLE TO
HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE AT THIS
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT A
POLICE OFFICER DOESN'T MEAN
THEY CANNOT. RENDER A FAIR
DECISION THAT IS. COULD BE VERY
WELL FAVORABLE PORT OFFICER SO
I DON'T THINK BIASES IS THERE
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF
THE MAKE UP OF THIS COMMITTEES.
NON SWORN POLICE OFFICERS. I
THINK THE WAS MORE WE REGARD TO
THE BACKGROUND THE
QUALIFICATIONS THAT ARE BEING
OUT POSTED ON THERE- INDIA IS A
FULL TIME I THINK IT WAS JUST
MORE IN THE BACKGROUND OF THE
OF THE BOARD THIS IS. IN THE
BACKGROUND PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUND BE TO BEHIND THEM I
THINK THAT WAS MORE OF A
CONCERN. I MEAN. WE'RE JUST NOT
TAKING JOE BLOW OFF THE STREET
AND HOUSE IN THE SERVE ON THIS
COMMITTEE SO- ARE THEY ON THIS
COMMISSION SO. THERE WILL BE.
EXPECTATIONS OF QUALIFICATIONS
AN UNDERSTANDING IN ORDER TO BE
CONSIDERED BUT YOU KNOW. TO SAY
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND IN ORDER
TO SERVE ON THIS THING I
TOTALLY DISAGREE WITH THAT- AND
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE FOR
YOU IS WITH REGARDS TO
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY. HOW WOULD
YOU RESPOND TO THE CONCERN THAT
THIS IS PART OF THIS OF THIS
BILL AND THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED SEPARATELY I DON'T
AGREE WITH IT I THINK QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY I THINK IF YOU HAVE
SKIN IN THE GAME IT'S GOING TO
CHANGE YOUR- BEHAVIOR. IF WE
ALL KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE HELD
SO. PERSONALLY LIABLE FOR THE
ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE. ARE YOU
SURE YOU WE WILL THINK TWICE
BEFORE TAKING BOTH WORLD
ACTIONS. NOT THOSE ACTIONS THAT
ARE SPLIT DECISION THAT
REQUIRES YOU TO DO AND COMMON
PLACE. LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT WHAT
WE'VE SEEN. JUST IN THE LAST
TWO DAYS. WHAT WE'VE SEEN. IN
THE LAST SIX MONTHS. THE
SITUATION IN WINDSOR. OF
VIRGINIA I THINK WE WOULD ALL
AGREE YOU HAVE A MILITARY
OFFICER IN UNIFORM AND TO BE
TREATED IN A WAY THAT HE'S BEEN
TREATED IF THAT OFFICER WAS A
MILITARY OFFICER WAS PERSONALLY
INJURED IN THAT SCRIMMAGE WHY
SHOULD THAT OFFICER BE HELD.
PERSONALLY LIABLE WHEN IT
WASN'T BASED ON POLICE CONDUCT
AND COLD WHY SHOULD YOU BE
LIABLE FOR ANY INJURY THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL CITIZENS.
ENCOUNTERING DURING THAT
ENCOUNTER I THINK I JUST THINK
IT'S JUST. IT'S PART OF I THINK
NEARING THE SCOPE OF BEHAVIOR
IF YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA BE
PERSONALLY LIABLE FOR. FOR YOUR
ACTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD AND LAST THE CONCERN
WITH REGARDS TO- THE PROCESS-
LET'S SEE HERE. SOME MAY
CONSTRUE THIS THAT THE PROCESS
MAY NOT BE MIRROR OR SHARE I'M
AS APPLY TO OTHER PROFESSIONS
DO YOU FEEL DO YOU PERSONALLY
FEEL THAT THIS PROCESS MIRRORS
THAT OF OTHER PROFESSIONS IN
THERE THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. I THINK IT'S MORE
SAFEGUARDS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT IT IS FOR BARBER OR BARBER
CAN SHOW UP DRUNK. AND LOSE
THEIR LICENSE. THAT DOESN'T
APPLY TO A POLICE OFFICER RIGHT
NOW YOU MIGT BE SUSPENDED
MIGHT BE YOU KNOW DISCIPLINE
BUT A BARBER CAN LOSE THEIR
LICENSE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
SHOWEDUP AND DROP A BARBICAN
LOSE THEIR LICENSE FOR FALSE
ADVERTISEMENT. BUT A CERTAIN
FOR YOU KNOW FOR TO. EVIDENCE
AND YOU KNOW. IT'S TOUGH TO LIE
AS WE LL KNOW THE WHO KNOWS
SOME DUDE. AND THEN THEY SHOULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE THAT SO I
THINK THE SAFEGUARDS FOR- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS FAR AS- BEING
CERTIFIED AS FAR STRICTER THAN
THAT AGAIN OTHER A BARBER A
DOCTOR A LAWYER TO BE DISBARRED.
IT SHOULD BE EASIER TO SAVE FOR
THOSE FOLKS TO LEGALIZE AND
THEN OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSON AT. THE DECISION A LIFE
AND DEATH IN THEIR HAND ON THE
DAILY BASIS. SO I'M SORRY JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES YOU
BELIEVE THAT THE PROCESSES ARE
SIMILAR. IN THEIR SIMILAR AND
THEN THEM BUT I THINK. IT'S
MORE LEAD WAY WITH A LOT LAW
LAW LAW ENFORCEMENT RIGHT NOW
THAN IT IS WITH BARBER CITING
AN APPARENTLY OBVIOUSLY WE DO
HAVE A PROBLEM YEAH YOU DO HAVE
A DOUBT. AND I AGREE WITH YOU I
CONCUR WITH THAT- I ALSO NOTED
THAT. YOU ARE CURRENTLY UNDER-
NEGOTIATIONS WITH- BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR SAFETY OFFICERS
IN REGARDS TO MAKING THIS BILL
MORE- WHAT'S THE WORD MORE
BALANCED OUT WITH THEM IS THAT
CORRECT. I AM IN CONSTANT
DIALOGUE WITH THE FOLKS WHO
WANT TO HAVE A EARNERS
CONVERSATION AND MOVING THIS.
LEGISLATION FORD BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY COMING UP WITH A
FAIR WAIT A TRANSPARENT WAY OF
GETTING RID OF BAD COPS AND IF
THAT SUBJECT OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT SUBJECT OF
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY I'M OPEN
IN NEGOTIATIONS BUT MUCH OF THE
DISCUSSION THAT IS SHARED
AROUND THIS ISSUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS IT BEEN ABOUT A
REAL FAIR AND TRANSPARENT OPEN-
PROCESS IT'S BEEN VERY ONE
SIDED AND SO I'M OPEN TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT DIALOGUE
I. HAD A VERY URGENT THE
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY WITH A
REPRESENTATIVE OF PPL STILL-
I'M WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH
ANY OF THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION TO GET TO
THAT COMMON GROUND OF SOMETHING
THAT FEAR THAT PROVIDES TO
PROCESS- TO LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT
IT STOPS IS TRUST IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LACKING RIGHT NOW TRUST
SPECIALLY IN PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
THE COMMUNITIES OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR SO THAT'S WORTH. LOOKING
TO FIND A BALANCE. THE YOU
SENATOR PER A I RESPECT AND I
CAN HEAR THE PASSION. IN YOUR
VOICE. I'M A NEW MEMBER FROM
THIS AND PUBLIC SAFETY AND I
HAVE TO SAY- IT'S BEEN A
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR ME AND
WORKING WITH- WITH ALL OF YOU.
I AM NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT IT'S CURRENTLY WORKING IN
IN PROGRESS BUT I WOULD LOVE TO
BE A PART OF YOUR OF YOUR TEAM
AND WORK TOWARDS THE BALANCE OF
THIRTY BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE DO NEED REFORM. AND I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THE FOUNDATION OF
THIS BILL AND WHERE IT'S MOVING
FORWARD TO AND I WOULD VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE TO BE A PART OF
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD YES SENATOR KAMLAGER
THINGS M. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO- IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASKED WHICH
I THINK ARE REALLY GOOD
QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW AS YOU
WERE- ASKING ABOUT THE
BACKGROUND OF- THE MEMBERSHIP
OF THE COMMISSION IT STRUCK ME
THAT THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY OF US THAT SERVE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND VERY FEW OF US
COME FROM A BACKGROUND OF
LEGISLATIVE WORK. WHAT WE DO IS
WE ARE A DIVERSE GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS. THAT REPRESENT ALL
OF THE DIVERSITY OF THIS STATE
AND WE BRING OUR UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVES. AND ARE DIFFERENT
WORK HISTORIES AND EXPERIENCES
TO THE TABLE AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE USE. THOSE EXPERIENCES ON
THOSE VERY DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS. TO REALLY COLOR IN
THE DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE AROUND
POLICY. AND I THINK THAT IS. A
SIMILAR INTENT FOR THIS
COMMISSION. I THINK IT ALLOWS
FOR THERE TO BE MORE OPEN
MINDED DISCUSSIONS AND FOR
THEIR TO BE FRESH APPROACHES TO
HOW DIFFERENT INVESTIGATIONS
ARE REVIEWED- AND EVEN
INVESTIGATED AND DISCUSSED.
OFTEN TIMES WHEN YOU HAVE
EVERYONE YOU KNOW FROM THE
SAME- SPACE TALKING WE END UP
HAVING GROUP THINK WE END UP
USING ACRONYMS AND WE FALL INTO
A COMFORT ZONE THAT DOESN'T
ALLOW FOR DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES TO BE SHARED. I
THINK YOU KNOW HAVING SOMEONE
WITH A SOCIAL WORKER EXPERIENCE
OR SOMEONE WHO IS A NURSE OR
SOMEONE WHO IS A CAREGIVER FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS A PASTOR- COULD
PROBABLY BRING A DIFFERENT AND
FRESH PERSPECTIVE. TO THE
DISCUSSIONS WERE HAVING AROUND
WHAT PUBLIC SAFETY MEANS WHAT
EXCESSIVE FORCE LOOKS LIKE HOW
IT IS PERCEIVED SO I THINK WE
SHOULD AND I'M ALSO SAYING THIS
TO THE OPPOSITION PUT A LITTLE
FAITH. IN THE PUBLIC THAT WE
ALL WANT YOU KNOW THE SAME.
GOOD TO FEEL SAFE AND THAT
HOPEFULLY WHEN YOU HAVE A
CONSTELLATION OF DIFFERENT
IDEAS AND PERSPECTIVES- LENDING
THEMSELVES TO THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS- FOR THIS
COMMISSION THAT SOMETHING WILL
HAPPEN THAT IS FAIR- I ALSO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR. THE
OPPOSITION TO REMEMBER THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IT COMES FULLY
CLOAKED WITH FULL
REPRESENTATION THEY ARE UNION
MEMBERS THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT
OF THEIR UNION THEY OFTEN ARE
GIVEN ACCESS TO COUNCIL
IMMEDIATELY- WHEN AN
INVESTIGATION IS STARTED- POPE
ARE IS STILL VERY MUCH IN
AFFECT. AND SO THE SYSTEM AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS REALLY STILL
DOES AIR ON THE SIDE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO GIVE THEM AMPLE
PROTECTION BECAUSE I THINK IN
THE GRAND DESIGN IN THE
BEGINNING PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD
THAT THESE ARE- DANGEROUS JOBS-
AND THAT FOLKS WHO ARE
COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO DO THEM.
ACTUALLY DO DESERVE SUPPORT AND
SO I ALSO WANT US TO BE REALLY
MINDFUL OF THAT AND THE GOAL IS
NOT TO. RELIEVE FOLKS OF ANY
PROTECTIONS BUT IT IS TO ADD
ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF
TRANSPARENCY AND- UNBIASED
OBJECTIVE INVESTIGATION INTO
OFTENTIMES IT'S THE SAME SMALL
GROUP OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS VETERAN TO ENGAGE. IN
THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY THAT
ULTIMATELY- SPREAD I THINK FEAR
AND DISCONTENT AND LOW MORALE
BOTH IN THE COMMUNITY BUT ALSO
WITHIN THE RANKS AND SO HOW DO
WE FIND A WAY TO INCISIVE LEO
ATTACK. ON THOSE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS DEALING WITH IN A WAY THAT
KEEPS DEPARTMENTS HOLD BUT ALSO
GIVES PROTECTION OFTENTIMES TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO DON'T HAVE
THE COURAGE OFTEN TO HANDLE THE
BAD ACTORS THAT ARE IN THEIR
OWN DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE OF THE
CULTURE. THAT IS REALLY SO
PERVASIVE AND SOMETIMES
OPPRESSIVE SO I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THOSE THOUGHTS IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU REYES TO THE
CHAIR. AND THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL. SENATOR FROM LARGER I IF
YOUR HEARING AND I ATE AN EGG-
I YOUR STATE YOU'VE MADE THANK
YOU- AND YET COMMENTS. CAN IN
THE EFFORTS OF TIME WE'RE GONNA.
WE HAVEN'T FROM SENATOR WE TO
MOVE BILL- CONSULTING YOU MIND
CALLING THE WORLD PLEASE CAN I
CLOSE SORRY I APOLOGIZE HE SAID
HEARD ABOUT. AND ABOUT WHICH
ART I WOULD HAVE ALLOWED US
CALL AUGUST TO SERVICE MY
CLOTHES BECAUSE I THINK SHE HAD
TO KNOW ON THE HEAD. BUT I DID
TO ADDRESS QUESTION I MISSED
THERE IS A YEAR ONE FROM THE IN
THE- STARTS TO IT HAS TO BE.
TILL AGAIN. THAT'LL THAT'LL
THAT BATTLE TIME BIG CHAU- IT'S
NOT WE'RE THIS TO OFFICERS DOWN
GET A CHANCE IS THEM SO. BUT AS
USED. THIS DOES NOT COME FROM A
POSITION OF ANTI COP WHATSOEVER.
THE IS A- POLICING. MEASURE
THAT MAKES OUR COMMUNITY SAFER
WE ALL WE WILL. MEN WHEN WHO
FOR THE UNIT. THE CITIZENS AS
AS A WHOLE. WHY SAFE
TRUSTWORTHY POLICE OFFICER
INTERNET. THAT ALL WE'RE FOR
HERE. AND I COME FROM LEVEL OF
ITS- THAT NO I'M NOT A LONG
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON. BUT I HAVE
FAMILY WHO FUNDING IMPACT UNCLE.
THIRTY PLUS. MILITARY OFFICER.
I AM I. BEST FRIEND FROM. JUNE
HIGH JUST READ FROM A- AFTER
THE FIVE. PRESIDENT THE. SURE
DORSEY IF LAPD OFFICER- GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE- GO ON AND ON
AND ON I HAVE FOR WHO ARE LINE
FOR IN THE ALL. THE HARDER
THING TO IN LAW FOR IS TO GET
RID OF A BAD COP. THE STAFF THE
HARDEST THING TO DO IS TO GET
RID OF A BAD COP AND MAKE ALL
ADS ARE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
STATED. BAY TO WANT TO GET RID
OF BAD COPS. BUT THE- BARRIERS.
THAT EXIST MAKE IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF THIRTEEN HUNDRED
PLUS. SHOOTINGS IN THE LAST
DECADE DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
BROUGHT UP ON CHARGES. TEN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED SHOOTINGS TEN
OF THE STAND HOW MANY WERE
CONVICTED. ONE TELL ME WHAT
PROFESSION GET TO THE RIGHT
THAT MANY TIMES THAT OFTEN NO
DOCTOR NO LAWYER NO TEACHER NO
ELECTED OFFICIAL NO ONE GETS A
DIRECT SO AGAIN THE BARRIERS TO
PROTECT OFFICERS HAVE BEEN NEAR
IN THE CONTINUE TO BE THERE AND
ALL WE'RE SEEING IS LET'S RESET
THIS. MORE GOALS IN OBJECTIVES
REALLY TO GET RID OF BACK
CAUGHT HERE IS A METHOD IN
WHICH WE CAN DO IT. IS A
PERFECT NOW BUT WE'RE WORKING
AT THAT WOULD BUT WHAT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW IS FAR FROM PERFECT.
AND IT'S TRULY NOT TRUSTWORTHY.
AND ESPECIALLY IF YOU COME FROM
A- COMMUNITY OF BLACK AND
BROWN. AND I WOULD JUST IN WITH
THIS. OSCAR GRANT RODNEY KING
HE'S L. FOR STOP ON CLARK RON
SETTLES YOU WILL LOVE THE JOHN
KINSEY ANDRES GUARDADO KENNETH
ROTH JUNIOR CHAU MONTERROSA
ERIC SAGA. THIS IS JUST A SHORT
OF BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN KILLED WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF RODNEY KING BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT BE WAS BRUTALIZED
TO THE POINT THAT HE SUFFERED
FROM MENTAL ISSUES TO WRESTLE
LIFE AND PRIDE LED TO HIS
MYSTERIOUS ACCIDENTAL DROWNING
IN HIS OWN BACKYARD. SO WE CAN
GO ON ATCHISON CALIFORNIA. THEN
WE CAN GO TO YOUR GARDENER FROM
CAMANCHE. TO MEMORIZE A YEAR
CLEAN AND UP WORK BY HIMSELF
AND HE'S GUNNED DOWN WITH THREE
SO OF A- PULLING UP TELL ME
WHAT WHITE NEIGHBOR WITH THAT
HAPPEN. REALLY TAYLOR. I AM TO
SLEEPING IN OUR- AND GUNNEDAH
AND THEY'RE STILL THERE THAT'S
JUST. DANTE RIGHT AS WE JUST
SAW THIS WEEK. TWENTY MINUTES
OUTSIDE OF MANY OUT. SAYS I WAS
REACHING FOR MY TO. EVEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO ON YOUR SIDE GUNS ARE
YOU DON SIDE. HOW DO YOU CAN IT
THE DIFFER WAIT BETWEEN AGO IN
A TWO. I'M A EIGHT TO TEN
OUNCES. BUT PHILANDO. REACH FOR
HIS IDEA IN HIS CAR WITH HIS
WIFE AND HIS YOUNG IN THE BACK
HE'S GONE DOWN OR JACOB LAKE
WITH THREE TO IN CAR SHOT SEVEN
TIMES IN THE PAST. MOST OF
THESE OFFICERS THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME. BUT THEY'RE STILL
ON POLICE DEPARTMENTS BUT THE
MAJORITY OF THE FOLKS THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN THESE. INCIDENTS
AND ALL WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
SAY IS HOW DO WE GET RID OF THE
BAD APPLES SO THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO PUT ON THAT UNIFORM EVERY
DAY WHICH IS 99% OF THOSE FOLKS
WHO. TAKE THE OLD TO DO THEIR
JOB HOW ARE THE- ALLOWED TO BE
TRUSTED. AND MAKE THEIR JOB
EASIER AND MAKE THEM SAFER WHEN
THEY'RE ON THE STREET AND I
THINK. BY GETTING RID OF BAD
OFFICER TO ALLOW OF SERVICE.
ASK HER. WHAT CAN. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE PASSIONATE WERE.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CAL THE ROLL.
SB TWO TWO DO PASS TO JUDITH
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE SHOW BOTH
ABSTAINED AB. FROM. COMMA AYE
SKINNER WE- WIENER HI SO HOLD
ROLE OF A FOR SOME SKINNER. ALL
THE ROLE OPEN FOR SOME. WILL BE
HOLDING THE ROLE OPEN OUR APPS
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. FOR NOW
PASS IT ON TO. CENTER BRADFORD
THANK YOU VERY SHARE AND NOW
WE'RE MOVE ON TO- ITEM NUMBER
TWO WE HAVE B. TH FIVE A CENTER
BURKE I SEE HERE AND READY TO
GO- WE YOU'RE READY. THEY WERE.
A COUPLE AREAS THOUGH WHERE WE
HAD SOME GLITCHES AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
DO IS TO REMEDY THOSE FEW
GLITCHES. ONE GLITCH WAS WITH
RESPECT TO- DROP BOXES THAT
WERE MARKED AS OFFICIAL THAT
SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN MARKED AS
OFFICIAL BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
OFFICIAL DROP BOXES. ANOTHER
ISSUE IS PEOPLE BEING HARASSED
AS THEY WAIT IN LINE- TO VOTE
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
EXPANDS THE NO ELECTIONS
ELECTION HEARINGS ON.
SURROUNDING POLLING SITES TO
TWO HUNDRED FEET IN PROVIDING
AN ADDITIONAL. OPTICS IS THE
VOTERS WAITING TO VOTE LINE
LONGER THAN TO LEARN FEET SO
THEY CAN'T BE HARASSED IS THERE
WAITING IN LINE TO VOTE. AND
CLARIFYING THAT MAIL. BALLOT
VOTERS TO TURN ON THE BALLOT IN
THE DROP BOX OF THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS THOSE WHO VOTED
A SATELLITE LOCATION ELECTIONS
OFFICE THE POLLING PLACE THOSE
WORDS IF YOU WANT TO VOTE. PUT
YOUR BALLOT THE DROP BOX PEOPLE
CAN'T SURROUND THE DROP BOXES.
THEY CAN- TALK TO YOU BE YOU OR
RESCUE BEFORE YOU DROP YOUR
BALLOT. BUT PROTECTING VOTERS
IN THE ELECTIONS PROCESS BY
CLARIFYING THAT IS NOT
PERMISSIBLE. TO MARK AN
UNAUTHORISED BOAT COLLECTION BY
WITH THE WORDS OFFICIAL. THIS
BILL APPLY TO. WILL ALSO PLAY
EXIST PENALTY FOR INTER. WITH
THE PLACE COLLECTION ARE
COUNTING OF BALLOTS. TO THOSE
WHO SAY TO SEE VOTERS MARKING
ON OF. ABOUT BOXES. AS A FISH-
I YOUR DRIVER. THANK YOU. NOW
LET MOVE TO HELLO I'M SORRY AND
I HAVE A TWO IN THIS THAT ARE
PRESENT TO TESTIFY ON THE PHONE
MISS NATALIE A DONUT NEVADA
COUNTY ASSISTANT CLERK RECORDER
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AND ALSO
ESPERANZA S. B. MARTINEZ OF
VOTE CENTERS SUPPORT LEAD FOR
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER
VOTERS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FIRST PRIMARY WITNESSES READING
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES TOTAL YOU
MAY BEGIN. MR DONAHUE PRESENT.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES.
THANK YOU DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK MY NAME IS NATALIE
IT DOWN- AND I REPRESENT NEVADA
COUNTY ELECTIONS WHICH SUPPORT
SB THIRTY FIVE. NEVADA CAN IS
ONE OF THE COUNTY BUT- A
LECTURE UNDER VOTERS CHOICE.
FUNDED BCA OFFER SEVERAL TO
RETURN A VOTED. INCLUDING THE
AND ASSESS DROP. IN ABOUT
ACCOUNT APPROX FIFTY OF OUR
ABOUT FROM TWO TWENTY ELECTION
WILL. TO BE A DROP BOX. SB
THIRTY FIVE PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED BECAUSE- AND AFFORD DROP
BOXES BACK TO PROTECT AND A
LIKE. ALL TO MAKE THAT A LOT
OFFICIALS LOOKED AT WAS STRUCK
BOXES AND NO WAY ELSE. DURING
THE EARLY VOTING LAW YEAR I
WOULD. SATURDAY RALLY EVER
THREE FROM SUPPORT GATHER IN
THE COUNTY. LOT BLOCK AT TO THE
DRUG BOX OUR PARTY LOT WHICH
HAS THE ENTRANCE OUT OF THE ONE
BUT ELECTION BOPPERS. BOB TO
GAUGE AND TRANSFORM CRICKETER
ELECT. LARGE FLAG WITH THE CAN
NAY AND LIKE DECORATING EVERY
CAR THAT HAPPENED BENDER BALBOA
MICHAEL SPEECH THAT I COULD
HEAR THE SECOND FLOOR OF MY
OFFICE. UPSET NOTED THAT TO THE
STATE THE BAKER ACT THE DRAW
BOX WHAT BUILT INTO THE DATA
PRO THE DRAW BOX THE RALLY
WOULD TAKE PLACE. ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE TO BE ABLE TO DROP
THEIR BY MAIL IN A CALL ALMOST
NON. A PHOTO SHOULD NEVER
DEALING WHEN A AND SHOULD NOT
BE FORCED TO FIND A LOW THAT.
AN THIRTY FIVE HELD BY EXTEND
THAT NO ONE REMARKABLE ONE TO
TWO HUNDRED FEET. PROVIDING BUT
ACCESS AND- TO ALL OF OUR DROP
BOXES. I THINK FIVE HELPED MY
OFFICE PROTECT ALL OUR VOTERS
CANADA. BY ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
CONSIDER VOTING IN FAVOR OF SB
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SKINNER BUGGY ONLY ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS GIVE ANOTHER
WITNESS- MISS- S. B. MARTINEZ
FROM THE ORANGE COULD RESTORE
VOTERS. OUR TEAM IS ARE YOU
READY. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU CHAIR BRADFORD AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARTINEZ ARE
YOU IN THE CENTER SUPPORT LEAD
FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER
VOTERS PREPARING TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY FIVE
BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL BRING
MUCH NEEDED CLARITY AND
PROTECTION FOR BOTH BOATERS AND
OTHER ACTION WORKERS. FOLLOWING
THE TWENTY TWENTY OF ACTION TO
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CONVENED A MEETING
SENATOR UMBERG WHERE WE
REVIEWED HOW THE ELECTION WENT
AND FLAG POTENTIAL ISSUES WITH
ON THE FIELD WE DISCUSSED WITH
SENATOR I'M BURKE SOME
CONFUSION THAT OCCURRED AT THE
HONDA CENTER WHICH SERVES AS A
BOTH A NEW SUPER SITE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. WHERE THE ISSUE OF THE
ELECTION BUT- NEEDED CLARITY
THERE WAS A LOCAL CANDIDATE
THAT WAS UNCLEAR. ABOUT
ELECTION. A LOT OF. OVER ONE
SPEED FROM THAT VENUE. THE
ENTRANCE TO THE BILL AROUND.
AND ADDITION TO ROUTE ORANGE WE-
MULTIPLE ISSUES ARE. AN ALTAR
BALLOT DROP BOXES HOPING AT THE
SPECIAL AND THEY CAN'T ARE THAT
TO AN UP CALL PLAYS. FROM
CENTERS WE ALSO WITH ISSUES
LONG LYING YOU SO THIS DIDN'T
BEING PROTOCOL. WHERE VOTERS
WERE STEP. TO ELECTIONEERING
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN LINE
EXTENDED BEYOND THE HUNDRED
FOOT BUFFER I BELIEVE THAT
CLARITY AND THE LAW AND ADDED
PROTECTION WILL MAKE IT WILL BE
AN EXPERIENCE BETTER FOR BOTH
VOTERS AND ELECTION WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
HEARING MY TESTIMONY TODAY I
APPRECIATE. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ARE. THANK YOU
pROOM FOR TWO OLD ARE THERE ANY
WITH HERE- TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTY FIVE. SHE
NINE IN THE ROOM LET'S GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM AT TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANY WITNESSES
THERE I DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE.
MODERATOR NOW LET'S MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES- WITNESSES- WANTING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. ONE MORE
CRITICAL WITH FROM FIRST ONE.
BRINEGAR LINE NUMBER SIX FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATOR
BRADFORD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COUNTY TO GUERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. HE FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. OUR
NEXT ONE'S GOING TO BE THE LINE
OF SEVEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HM NUMBER SPROUT MORAN
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. TWENTY ONE NUMBER
SEVEN FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
COULD AFTERNOON DELIGHT THEM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA OUT WE ARE- SUPPORT
IF AMENDED OUT WE- RECOGNIZE
THE PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF THE
BILL PROJECTED VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES BETWEEN LIKE
MINDED BOTH BY EXTENDING THE
ELECTIONEERING BACKER TO TWO
HUNDRED FEET. ARMS AND THAT AND
THE CURRENT VERSION- SAYS
IMMEDIATELY SENATE HE AND SO WE
STRONGLY JOURAGE-
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL.
WE BELIEVE THAT- THE ORIGINAL
TWO HUNDRED FEET BOPPER-
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED THEM WITH
THE ABILITY FROM. THE
LECTIONARY ACTIVITY THANK YOU.
CEMEX WOULD LINE NUMBER SIX
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ENGINE MUSICIAN WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
OUR POSITION IS SUPPORT IF
AMENDED- WE ARE WE HAVE THE
SAME CONCERNS AS DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA PROGRAM AS
YOU KNOW THE BILL AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE DECORATIONS CREATING NEW
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR THE
ILLEGAL CREATION AND
PUBLICATION OF THE USE OF
UNOFFICIAL ABOUT TRUMP BOXES.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH DOCTOR TO CONTINUE.
IMPROVING THE BILL THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME I'M SHOWING NO
FURTHER IN Q. IS MY
REGISTRATION TO FLAUNT ONE MORE
TIME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY I HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THERE'S NO TAKERS NOW WE'RE
GONNA FOR THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IS
THEIR PRIMARY WITNESSES AND-
POSED TO. SB THIRTY FIVE I SOON
SHAKING THEIR HEAD THERE ARE
NONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM AND OPPOSITION OF CARE WE
SEE YOU WE SEE. YOU CAN.
PROCEED TO THE PLEXIGLASS THERE
WITH A MICROPHONE AS YOU GIVE
YOUR NAME AND YOU HAVE. SHE TWO
AND A HALF MINUTES TO TESTIFY-
I GET TWO AND A HALF MINUTES TO
TESTIFY. I DIDN'T REALLY HAVE
ANYTHING PLANNED. YOU STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION AND WE
CAN MOVE ON. I NEED YOU TO MOVE
ON I CAN FILL IT OUT OR IF I
NEED TO YOU ONE OF OUR SO YOU
CAN USE CAN HAVE TWO AND A HALF
MEN YES YOU CAN LET'S AND YOU
HAVE NO PRIMARY WITNESS. AND
YOU JUST DISPARAGED CONNIE
LEYVA WERE YOU IN THE ROOM.
WHEN THEY DISPARAGED TRUMP
RALLY AND SAID THAT THEY HAD
INTERFERED. WITH VOTING.
PRIMARY WITNESS I DIDN'T CATCH
HER NAME SHE CALLED ON THE
PHONE. CAN CAN ANYBODY FILL ME
IN ON WHAT THE NAME. OF THE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. I DIDN'T CATCH THE
NAME. YOU'LL ARCHIVE THIS LATER
WON'T YOU. I'LL BE ABLE TO SEE
THE VIDEO. BECAUSE IT SEEMS A
LITTLE ODD TO ME THAT THIS IS
GETTING LEGISLATIVE TODAY. AND
YOU DON'T HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. BECAUSE
I'M NOT REALLY EDUCATED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS ELECTIONS
ISN'T MY- WE DON'T HOUSES SO TO
SPEAK. BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE. I
KNOW THAT THE CONSTITUTION
STILL MATTERS I KNOW THAT THERE
WERE A HUNDRED PEOPLE WAITING
IN LINE TODAY OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING TO GET INTO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND YOU
DENIED THEM ENTRANCE TO THE
BUILDING WHICH IS WHY I'M
STANDING HERE SUDDENLY ACTING
AS YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS. ON A
BILL. THAT IS NOT GETTING ANY
REPRESENTATION WHATSOEVER SO
MAYBE YOU SHOULD TELL ME WHAT'S
GOING ON. WITNESSES WILL BE
ALLOWED TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION SAME AS ANY OTHER
ONES THAT THEY HAVE NO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WHY ARE
YOU DOING THIS AT ALL AND WHY
ARE YOU HERE THEN IF YOU'RE NOT
A PRIMARY OPPOSITION. WAS
DENIED ENTRANCE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BECAUSE
THEY SAID SIXTEEN WAS AWFUL ARE
YOU NOT HERE ON SB THIRTY FIVE
YES I'M HERE WELL THEN I'M
AGAINST THIS OKAY AGAINST
ANYTHING THIS LEGISLATURE IS
DOING UNTIL THEY OPEN THE
BUILDING AND LET THE PEOPLE IN
SO THERE IS MY TESTIMONY THANK
YOU. ENJOY YOUR DAY. I'M NOT
LEAVING BY THE WAY. YOU'RE NOT
JUST THE FINAL SO. LET'S GO- WE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR ABOUT THREE THIRTY
FIVE IT. YES THANK YOU BEIJING
JAN A MINORITY IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE CAN
IF YOU'RE NOT POSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND CURRENTLY I HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. OKAY I WOULD S. DISTRICT
LINES NE MORE TIME SO WE CAN
GIVE THOSE HUNDRED OR SO PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO TESTIFY.
OPPOSITIONISTS OPPORTUNITY TO
THE PHONE AND- YES THANK YOU
ONE CAN MAYES GENTLEMAN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND CURRENTLY HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP THANK YOU MODERATOR
HAVING NO TAKERS WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS SENATOR WIENER. I
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK FILTER ALL THE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY ONE THING I DO
JUST WANT TO MENTION AYE AYES
HAVE MEANT TO CALL YOU- AT THE
TIME I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT.
HAVING A OPPORTUNITY. WHICH IS
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER- I
TOTALLY SUPPORT WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO DO. WITH THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY. WE HAVE- A
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A VERY.
ODD TIMES PART OF CALIFORNIA-
FREQUENTLY THE LEGISLATURE
SETS. DISTANCES THAT ARE.
IRRESPECTIVE OF DENSITY AND
THAT FRANKLY ARE. MORE FLEXIBLE
AND MORE SUBURBAN. SETTINGS AND
THAT MAY HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN VERY DENSELY
POPULATED. URBAN AREAS AND SO
WE SEE THIS IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CONTEXTS. TWO HUNDRED
FEET AND- DENSE URBAN SETTING.
CAN ACTUALLY BE QUITE.
SIGNIFICANT IT'S DIFFERENT THAN
SAY A SUBURBAN SETTING WHERE
YOU'RE VOTING AT A SCHOOL OR A
CHURCH OR OR WHATEVER WERE IT
DOESN'T IF YOU'RE STILL IN THE
PARKING LOT BY THE TIME YOU GET
TO TWO HUNDRED FEET. AND IN A
DENSE URBAN SETTING IF YOU HAVE
A- A DROP BOX OR A BOAT OR A
VOTING- STATION. THAT IS NEAR
LIKE A COMMERCIAL CORPORATE OR
IT COULD MEAN PATERNITY COULD
EVEN INTENDS INTO AN AREA WHERE
EVERYONE WOULD WOULD SAY THAT
THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE PLACE TO
CAMPAIGN OR EVEN TO REALLY
CENTRAL AREA WHERE WE WOULD
FRANK YOU WANT PEOPLE. TO BE
CAMPAIGNING SO I JUST WANT TO
PUT THAT OUT THERE IF YOU COULD.
TO CONSIDER I MAYBE YOU AND I
COULD. TRY ABOUT AT SOME POINT
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S SOLVABLE.
IN THIS BILL BUT- THAT'S AN
ONGOING ISSUE. IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS AND I SEE IT
POTENTIALLY BEING A PROBLEM
HERE. MISTER SHALL RESPOND
RESULT IF YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
TO THE CHAIR YES. SURE THE
SENATE LEADER I TAKE YOUR POINT
PARTICULARLY IN PLACE LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO- THE CHALLENGES IS
THAT IN THE LAST ELECTION WHERE
WE HAD FOLKS WHO ARE LINED UP
TO CLEARLY LATE IN THE EVENING.
BEYOND A HUNDRED FEET U TO TWO
HUNDRED FEET OF AND THE FOLKS
THAT YOU KNOW THE HUNDRED FIFTY
FOOT MARKER BEING HARASSED SO-
IF YOU IF YOU'VE GOT A FORMULA
FOR DENSE AREAS UP I'M HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN IT. BUT THE PURPOSE
OF THE BILL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING IN
LONG LINES AREN'T BEING
ACCOSTED BY THOSE WHO HAVE A
PARTICULAR POINT OF VIEW- WITH
RESPECT TO THAT ELECTION. YEAH
AND  DON'T KNOW JACK TO OPEN
MY EYES I THINK UNLESS I'M
MISINTERPRETING THE BILL EVEN
IF NO ONE IS ONLINE AT THE TIME
THE TWO HUNDRED FEET WOULD
STILL. APPLY AND SO. WE CAN
TALK AND- IT MIGHT NOT BE
SELLABLE AND MORE THAN ANYTHING
I'M JUST LOGGING- THIS ISSUE
AND WE CAN. CHAT ABOUT IT LATER
I APPRECIATE. THANK YOU. VERY
IN ADDITION QUESTION OR
CONCERNS. SENATOR OF TROUBLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAD A
QUESTION IF I'M ACTUALLY MORE
OF A CONCERN SO I'M THINKING OF
MY COMMUNITY- AND JUST BEFORE I
GO FORWARD- WITH REGARD TO
SENATOR AT WINNERS- QUESTION OR
CONCERN- WOULD IT BE FEASIBLE
TO DO SOMETHING WITHIN THE BILL
THAT SAYS ONE HUNDRED OR TWO
HUNDRED FEET FROM THE LAST
PERSON IN LINE THAT WAY IT
ACCOMMODATES THAT. WHATEVER THE
DISTANCE MAYBE- WITHOUT GET
CONSIDERATION THAT MAYBE REPORT.
IT WHAT WE DID CONSIDER THAT
THE CHALLENGES THAT. IT DOESN'T
GIVE THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS A
CLEAR DEMARCATION LINE SO FOR
EXAMPLE AT TEN O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING IT MAY BE TWO HUNDRED
FEET FROM THE ENTRANCE TO THE
BUILDING IN WHICH THE VOTE IS
HAPPENING WHERE YOU'RE CASTING
YOUR BALLOT. AREAS LATER ON IN
THE DAY IT MADE IT MAY BE
DIFFERENT AS PEOPLE LINE UP
OUTSIDE SO IF YOU ADJUSTED BY
THE LENGTH OF THE LINE- WEEK WE
COULD CERTAINLY CONSIDER WE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT BUT- THE
REGISTRARS NEED CLEAR
DEFINITION. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO ENFORCE THE- ENFORCE THE
LAW. SO IF THERE'S SOME OF THAT
THERE'S SOME OTHER PERMUTATION
THAT WE HAVEN'T CONSIDERED I'M
OPEN TO IT. SOME MAY BE WITHIN
A HUNDRED FEET UNLESS YOU KNOW
THE LINE EXTENDS FURTHER THAN
THAT THEN IT'S TWO HUNDRED FEET
OR A HUNDRED FEET FROM THAT-
JUST TAKE JUST A CONSIDERATION
AT GOOD POINT THOUGH I AND- I
DIDN'T HAVE CONSIDER THAT BUT I
DO CONSIDER- LOCATIONS SUCH AS-
AROUND MY NEIGHBORHOOD WE HAVE
A SENIOR. FACILITIES THAT-
BECOME- DROP OFF PLACES FOR
VOTING PLACES FOR POLLING
PLACES FOR OUR COMMUNITY. AND I
NOTICED ENSURE THAT WITHIN THIS
BILL IT SAYS THAT- YOU WOULD.
POTENTIALLY NOT BE ABLE TO DO
ANY SORT OF PRESENTATIONS
CAMPAIGNING OR ANY OF THE
SEARCH FOR THIRTY DAYS PRIOR
TO- UNDERSTANDING OUR SENIORS
AND THE COMMUNITIES WHICH
WHICH- OBVIOUSLY- DUE TO THE
TIMING AND- TYPE OF INFORMATION
THEY NEED INFORMATION AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND AS- YOU
KNOW SOON BECAUSE OTHERWISE IT
JUST BECOMES VERY DISTANT AND-
AND- YOU KNOW THEY FOR THE
FORGET- IS THERE A WAY THAT YOU
COULD TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS TO THE
FACILITIES. SUCH AS SENIOR FOR
CITY FACILITIES- IN THE IN THE
IN THIS IN THIS BILL- MISTER
CHAIR TO THE CHAIR. IS YOURS
FONG- THE PURPOSES SO FOR
EXAMPLE- THE- STATE DEMARCATION
IS FOR EXAMPLE FOR DROPBOX IF
YOU'RE DROPPING OFF THIRTY DAYS
AHEAD OF TIME IT'S NOT FOR A
VOTE CENTER WHICH MAY ONLY BE
OPEN FOR DAYS AT A TIME BUT
WE'LL LOOK AT IT TO MAKE SURE.
BUT WE DON'T WANT IT IS WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE STANDING
BEFORE AND AROUND DROP BOXES-
TWENTY NINE DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION WHEN PEOPLE ACTUALLY
ARE TRYING TO CAST THEIR BALLOT
THAT SO WE DON'T WANT. AND AS
AS WAS ILLUSTRATED BY THE-
WITNESS FROM A NEVADA COUNTY
THE THAT THAT IS A REAL
CONSIDERATION. OKAY AND- YOU
SEE. AND AS FAR AS MAKING- SO
THE OTHER CONCERN THAT I HAVE
HERE IS THAT IT CRIMINALIZES-
ELECTIONEERING BEAT WITHIN TWO
HUNDRED FEET AND ARE ON THE
BALLOT DROP BOXES BUT MORE
CONSISTENT MORE- TO THE POINT
IS THAT. THEY'RE CERTAINLY
GOING TO BE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT AWARE OF THE
ABERRATIONS WHO FINDS US WEEKS
LATER BEFORE AN ELECTION
WEARING. OTHERWISE JUST PLAYING
YOU KNOW- CANDID OR CAMPAIGN IT
PARAPHERNALIA ADAM. BUT THERE
THE FINES AND THE IS THERE LIKE
A WARNING THAT YOU MAY BE ABLE
TO GIVE SOMEONE BEFORE MOVING
FORWARD WITH PENALTIES. WELL
THIS DOESN'T CREATE NEW
PENALTIES WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
FURTHER DEFINES SO FOR EXAMPLE
INTERFERING WITH ELECTION. SAME
THING WITH THE ZONE IT EXPANDS
UP FROM ONE HUNDRED FEET TO TWO
HUNDRED FEET IT DOESN'T CREATE
A NEW STATUTES WITH NEW
PENALTIES. BOB CAN'T CAN FOLKS
BE GIVEN A WARNING AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE. TOO MUCH
DISCRETION TO THOSE WHO WOULD
BE ENFORCING THE LAW. BUT THERE
THERE THERE IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH HERE SO. IF FOR
EXAMPLE SOMEONE IS A HUNDRED
NINETY NINE FEET AWAY FROM A
DROP BOX TWENTY NINE DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION THERE IS
NOTHING ELSE GOING ON AND THEY
HAPPENED WE WEARING IT NUMBER
BUTTON. I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY
WOULD BE ARRESTED BUT THE
DEMARCATION LINE THE DISTANCE
ACTUALLY DOES GIVE. THE
REGISTRAR'S OF THOSE ARE
CONDUCTING ELECTION A- A
DEFINITE SORT OF RADIUS SO THAT
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN BE AWARE OF
WHAT AREAS WHICH THEY CAN
ELECTION YEAR WHAT YEAR IS THE
CAMP ALEXION IN- AND SO THAT TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT. YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY RUNNING AFOUL OF THE
LAW NOT BEING AWARE. OF
REGISTERED VOTERS CAN ACTUALLY-
DESIGNATE WHAT AREAS. YOU
CANNOT ELECTION HERE. OKAY AND
I'M KIND OF CURIOUS- I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DO HAVE IN
OPPOSITION FROM THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
HAVE YOU BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
IN IN WITH BECAUSE WITH THEIR
WITH- WITH REGARDS THEIR
CONCERNS TO THE BILL- I HAVE
NOT. OKAY- CAN I ASK WHAT THE
CONCERNS ARE THAT YOU'RE AWARE
OF EIGHT OF THEM. IT'S A IT'S A
POINT IN TIME I'M SURE THAT
WE'LL FIND COMMON GROUND ON ON
SOME ISSUE- BUT THE GROUP
BELIEVES THAT THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN THE GROUP BELIEVES IT
WAS RAMPANT FRAUD THE GROUP
BELIEVES THAT THERE ARE. YOU
KNOW LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS A
REGISTRY LEGALLY AND I
TYPICALLY DON'T BUY INTO THEIR
THEIR THEIR VIEWS BUT I'M SURE
AT SOME POINT TIME WILL FIND
COMMON GROUND ON SOMETHING.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BYE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
M. C. NINE SENATOR UMBERG WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- GINGIVAL
THANK YOU MEMBERS WERE SEEKING
A MOTION A DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SCISSOR AND
MOTION ON SB THIRTY FIVE. THE
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
SKINNER. THE CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON SB THIRTY FIVE
I DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SB
THIRTY FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD
I'D SHOW BOTH HI JOE BOAKAI COM
LONGER SKINNER. SKINNER I'D
WINNER WIENER AYE LEAVE IT
ALONE FOR NOTHING WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR- ABSENT
MEMBERS AND BEFORE WE TAKE OUR
NEXT AUTHORS SENATORS LABOR
WITH SB TWO NINE NINE THANK YOU
SENATOR I'M BURKE I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU TO OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CALLER ABSENT
MEMBERS. SKINNER IN ARRIVE. THE
MEASURES OUT FIVE ZERO NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM THREE S. B. TWO
NINE NINE BY SENATOR LEYVA. I
THOUGHT. HELLO YES AND WE WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON S. B. TWO FOUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. DINNER SKINNER
I IT'S FOUR ZERO K. THAT
MEASURES UT FOUR ZERO THREE
TWO ZERO FOUR ZERO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL AND HELPFUL
WORK ON THIS BILL IT IS MUCH
APPRECIATED. SB TWO NINE NINE
REMOVES BARRIERS FACED BY
VICTIMS OF POLICE VIOLENCE AND
OTHER VIOLENT CRIMES IN
ACCESSING CALIFORNIA'S VICTIMS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM CAL B. C.
B. CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIM COMPENSATION CATION
BOARD. CAN DENY APPLICATIONS IF
IT DETERMINES THAT THE VICTIM'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THE EVENTS GAVE
RISE TO THE APPLICATION GIVING
SIGNIFICANT WEIGHT TO THE
OPINION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SURVIVORS MAY BE DENIED FOR NON
COOPERATION WITH THE POLICE AND
FOR MOST VICTIMS CAL BCB CANNOT
APPROVE AN APPLICATION FOR
ASSISTANCE WITHOUT A POLICE
REPORT. QALBI CB CAN ALREADY
USE OTHER EVIDENCE TO ESTABLISH
A THE CRIME OCCURRED FOR
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT OTHER VICTIMS
SUCH AS THOSE WHOSE INJURIES
RESULTED FROM POLICE VIOLENCE
ARE NOT AFFORDED THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY. MEMBERS SB TWO
NINE NINE WILL IMPROVE ACCESS
TO VITAL RESOURCES FOR VICTIMS
OF POLICE VIOLENCE AS THEY
RECOVER FROM THE PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL INJURIES CAUSED TO
THE ACTIONS OF A POLICE OFFICER
PLEASE OR IN THE CASES OF
INDIVIDUALS KILLED BY POLICE.
PEOPLE TO BURY THEIR LOVED ONES
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT. THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS STRAIGHT
FORWARD BUT IF ENACTED WILL
MAKE AN IMPORTANT IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF VICTIMS OF POLICE
VIOLENCE. HERE WITH ME TODAY
ALL THE REMOTELY. IS MS.
STEPHANIE HATTEN WHO IS THE
MOTHER OF A VICTIM OF POLICE
VIOLENCE WITH CRIME SURVIVORS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND DR
GINA CASTRO RODRIGUEZ. WHO IS
THE CHIEF OF VICTIM SERVICES
DIVISION OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. IN
ADDITION MS RODRIGUEZ AS A- AND
HER ROLE AS THE DA'S OFFICE SHE
IS A PSYCHOTHERAPIST IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE AN ADJUNCT PROFESSOR
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. MISADVENTURE READY
YOU CAN BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY
YOU'LL HAVE. FIVE HELLO BOB
PREMIER WITH JUST FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL SO YOU CAN SPLIT THAT
MUCH TO BE. HEY THANK YOU
SENATOR LEAVES- QUARTER OUR
ECONOMY YOU ARE READY TO
CONSIDER IT. NINE NINE ON YOU
LIVE TWENTIETH. I DO LIKE
TWENTY TWENTY AND FLOM WORRIES
YOUR WAS SHOT DOWN BALLOT. WELL.
AUTHOR GARRISON AND OFFICER
GRANTED III PROBLEM THOUGH
SMALL OVER THE STATE BY. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY- FOR BY HER
OWN WITH HIS WIFE HE'S ONLY. AN
AVERAGE G. O. INCLUDE TO WITH
OVER ALL THE BRANCH SHE WORKED.
EIGHT AND NO DOUBT HIS YOUNG-
MY EATING. LIFE FOR ME TO BE-
IS LYING IN LEADING. AND I AM
PLEADING FOR A CONSIDER SO THAT
YOU KNOW ELSE. CAN GO. I WAS
READING AT A MILITARY HOLD ON
WAS. AND WE NEED TO WALK END OF
THE. NINE YEAR OLD SON WHO HAD
BEEN IN A STUDENT OUR GOAL
EASILY SHUT YEAH- HI I. YOU'RE
ANGRY ISRAELI. IT'S HARD
AVERAGING A MERE. AND EVEN
MENTAL STATE IS GONNA HE HAD
WAITED AN AGREEMENT. HOLD I
NEED HIM I NEED TO START. SO I
DON'T REMEMBER HIM NEARLY FROM
DON'T GRAND BECAUSE EITHER KNOW
HOW MY WILL BE A. IN ORDER TO.
AND YEAH I'M READING HIGH
SCHOOL MEDIA GRAD. IN STATE
COLLEGE MORE. SHE WAS. RIGHT
NOW- AND I NEED. HOW SIXTEEN
YEARS SO THERE'S NO MONEY IN
THE SYSTEM WHO WERE BORN IN
TRANSACTION EDUCATION. I MEAN
TO REMOVE HER OUT. NEIL IS. FOR
ALL INVOLVED. WE NEED SO. WE
OUR IN OUR COMMUNITY SO WE CAN
THEM SAFE- RESTRAINING UNDER.
THIS MESSAGE I'M GOING TO DOWN
THE- I'M SORRY BERMAN NEED YOU
TO COME YOUR TESTIMONY. WHAT
THANK YOU. YES WE HAVE WE MORE
ANYTHING HERE THE A PRIMARY
THEY SHOULD FOR MINUTES TO SO
WE WANT TO GIVE A DOCTOR
RODRIGUEZ OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON SB TWO NINE NINE ON
JUNE NINTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY CHANCE OF THE
GAME FORMALLY IMPLEMENTED THE
SURVIVOR OF VIOLENT QUALITY
INTERPRETERS CAL WHICH PROVIDED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO VICTIMS
OR THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS SINCE
THAT TIME WE'VE ONLY HAD A
HANDFUL OF REQUEST FOR THE
POLICY AND ONLY PAID ONE
FUNERAL BURIAL IN THE AMOUNT OF
SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ALL OF THE REQUEST WITH
YOUR SERVICES THAT WERE
PROVIDED BY COMMUNITY RESOURCES
OR THE PERSON WITH ALREADY
QUALIFIED FOR CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION. SB TWO NINE NINE
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE SERIOUS
INJURY OR LOSS OF LIFE AND A
HUGE PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL AND
FINANCIAL. IMPACT ON VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. ONE BURIAL
EXPENSES AVERAGED THAT DOLLARS
AND MEMBER ARE OFTEN FORCED TO
RE. QUARTERLY REPORT GO FIND ME
OR OTHER FUNDRAISER ACTIVITY TO
BURY A LOVED ONE. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OR ANOTHER BY. YOUR
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THE- GRIEF
AND LOSS PROTECT THEM.
TREATMENT CAN MITIGATE RISK
FACTORS FOR WHAT THE FUTURE
VICTIMIZATION AND FUTURE
VIOLENCE. SB TWO NINE NINE
EIGHT MENTAL THE DISPARITY IN
ACCESSING VITAL REJECTED
RESOURCE FOR ALL THAT. MANY
PEOPLE MAY NOT HAVE EVEN-
APPLIED FOR CAL B. C. B. AND IF
THEY IF THEY ALREADY QUALIFY
FOR CAL B. C. B. THAT WE USE
THAT FIRST. ONE FIRST REMEMBER
THAT CATTLE BE IS PAIR OF BLACK
THREE. WE EXHAUST ALL OTHER
RESOURCES LIKE INSURANCE
WORKMAN'S COMP. I'M CAPACITY TO
PAY FUNDRAISERS EVEN CIVIL
LAWSUITS BEFORE WE ACT THAT
THAT ON. INCLUDING I WANT TO
SAY THERE'S A REAL HARM WHEN
POLICE USE FORCE EVEN WHEN IT'S
LAWFUL FORCE. INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. THAT
HARM AFFECTS ON A ROAD THE
TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
PARTICULARLY FOR BLACK
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO
ARE MOST AFFECTED BY CRIME. S.
B. Q. NINE NINE SHORT CRIME
VICTIMS OF SURVIVOR FAMILIES
GET THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
HEAL AND. RECOVER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO THE RIGHT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESS INTO. OF SB TWO NINE
NINE HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEN NINE. NOW LET'S MOVE TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY
FORTY. NO WITNESSES THERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINE NINE
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES AND KEEP YOU COULD
LET US KNOW I MEAN WE HAVE BEEN
Q. WILL TAKE THEM. IN ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BURKE
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE. AND ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. IN A
LINE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. ANYONE WITH
SEIU CALIFORNIA IT'S A MUCH. AB.
ONE EIGHT HUNDRED SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THANK YOU ALEX
KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
NINE SEVEN HUNDRED FIVE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. THANK YOU MRS
GABRIEL GARCIA WITH YOU TO LIVE
WE ARE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
ON THIS BILL IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME WE HAVE COMPILED A LIST OF
SUPPORTERS THE CHURCH FOR
MISSION I LIKE TO READ THE BOOK.
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO WE HAD
ACTUALLY ARE NOT ENOUGH IF YOU
KNOW YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOU
THINK UNITY JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES UNITED FOR JUSTICE.
WHEN YOU PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION CENTER ON JUVENILE
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE ALLEN BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
EMPOWERING PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES FATHERS AND
FAMILIES OF SAN JOAQUIN. FRESNO
BIOSIMILARS. A JUSTICE. ROAD
MAP TO PEACE INITIATIVE SAN
FRANCISCO. SEGMENT DATA GIANT
MUTANT FAMILY SERVICE SINCE THE
UNITY COUNCIL WE THE PEOPLE SAN
DIEGO AND YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM
AND ISSHIN TO UTILIZE
COSPONSORED WE ALSO HOBBY
CALIFORNIA STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY YEE CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE PROSECUTORS
ALL ACTION CALIFORNIA AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CHECK IT WOULD ENCOMPASS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BELIE EIGHT ONE MY IT'S OPEN.
FIND A HOTEL. WHERE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT. THE LINE
SEVEN HUNDRED HERE MIKE IS OPEN.
THE DAILY MAIL LET COLIN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BLIND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CLARK
I'M SURE I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION. RECOUNT THE
BY THEIR NOT WORKING ON THE BY
THE GUN VIOLENCE AND I'M NOT
BREAKING MY SUPPORT FOR AT THE.
TWO NINE NINE. THE LINE SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YEAH MIKE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
KATHERINE VON. A WOMAN ON
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING
INSTRUCTIONS SB. THE LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. EIGHT LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY YOUR MY KIDS THAT MONEY.
WELL. WHERE WE ARE YOU. OH OKAY
YEAH. I'M THE MOTHER OF THE
FRIDAY AND EXECUTED BY OPPOSITE
DAVID WELLS I AM STRONG IN
SUPPORT OF TWO NINE NINE- TWO
ONE BECAUSE- MY- IN MY- MEMBERS
THEY NEEDED- SUPPORT. YOU
MENTALLY AND THEY NEEDED
SUPPORT FINANCIALLY AND LIKE
TOWARDS MY FAMILY MEMBERS LAW-
HOUSING BECAUSE THE BLAST HAD
BEEN AND IT WAS JUST A HARDWARE.
THE EXPERIENCE FOR OUR FAMILY
SO YEAH I OF- ED B. HELLO NINE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THERE BE
ABLE TO CONVERSE. THANK YOU.
LINE SEVEN FIFTY YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
NICOLE THROUGH I'M A RESIDENT
OF DANVILLE CALIFORNIA IN A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND I SUPPORT S. B. TWO
NINE NINE. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT. YEAH
SHE CHECKED THE LARGEST WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL WITNESS
CAN SUPPORT. JERK IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT COMING
THROUGH THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN THAT LARRY MORSE.
MODERATORS GTD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION S. B. TWO
NINE NINE WHICH WOULD EXPAND
THE UNIVERSE OF CLAIMANTS
ENTITLED TO RECEIVE PAYMENTS AS
VICTIMS OF CRIME FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RESTITUTION FUND TO
PERSONS WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
CRIME SB TWO NINETY NINE WOULD
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF CRIME
TO INCLUDE ANY USE OF FORCE BY
A PEACE OFFICER THAT RESULTS IN
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY OR DEATH
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE PEACE
OFFICER IS ARRESTED FOR CHARGED
OR CONVICTED OF COMMITTING A
CRIME. IN FACT THIS BILL WOULD
DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA
RESTITUTION FUND AWAY FROM
CRIME VICTIMS FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE ITS CREATION IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE SINCE THE
BILL WOULD NOT REQUIRE THAT A
CRIME HAS BEEN CONVICTED
COMMITTED IN ORDER TO MAKE
RESTITUTION AS DRAFTED THE BILL
DOORS THE REALITY THAT USE OF
FORCE BY PEACE OFFICERS IS MOST
OFTEN LAWFUL AND JUSTIFIED NOT
CRIMINAL AS WE READ THE BILL A
CLAIMANT SERIOUSLY INJURED BY A
PEACE OFFICER IS ENTITLED TO
VICTIM COMPENSATION REGARDLESS
OF THE CLAIMANTS CONDUCT IN THE
NET IN AN INCIDENT. UNLESS THE
CLAIMANT IS CONVICTED OF A
CRIME FOR INFLICTING GREAT
BODILY INJURY OR DEATH DURING
THE SAME PRINCIPLE AS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF HOME INVASION ROBBER
WHO RUNS OUT THE BACK DOOR
SHOOTS AT POLICE OFFICERS BUT
UNIFORMS AND GO IN TURN GETS
WOUNDED BY POLICE AND RETURNED
FIRE IS ENTITLED TO
COMPENSATION INTENDED FOR TRUE
VICTIMS OF CRIME SUCH A
SCENARIO STAND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS FUND ON IT AT. THE BILL
ALSO AUTHORIZES COMPENSATION TO
THE FAMILY OF A PERSON KILLED
BY A POLICE OFFICER REGARDLESS
OF THE DECEDENT'S CONDUCT IN
THE INCIDENT. THAT BROUGHT
ABOUT HIS OR HER DEATH. IN
CENTER THE TO THE FIFTEEN.
ASSAULT AND SAMBERG'S CAL. WERE
TO PERPETRATE MURDER OR PEOPLE.
THESE ARE ATTEMPTING TO ARREST
THE SHOOTER IS WORKING. WITH
GUNFIRE. AND SOME OFFICERS
WOUNDED BEFORE THE POLICE.
PREVAIL IN THE GUN BY. AGAIN AS
WE READ THE BILL. FOR VICTIMS.
ON BEHALF OF THE PERPETRATORS
WOULD HAVE TO BE PAID. THE
RESTITUTION FUND HAS BEEN
OPERATING UNDER A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT FOR SEVERAL YEARS. DO
WE REALLY WANT TO DENY PAYMENTS
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE TRULY
BEEN VICTIMS OF CRIME. IN ORDER
TO PAY THOSE WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
PERPETRATORS OF CRIME. AGAIN
THE BILL PROPOSES PAYING
PRESSURES AND INCREASINGLY
SCARCE RESTITUTION FUNDS TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN A
JUDGE BY ANY COURT. WHO HAVE
BEEN VICTIMS OF CRIME AND IN
FACT MAY HAVE BEEN PERPETRATORS
OF THE CRIME BECAUSE THEIR
INJURIES. BUT WAS NEVER THE
INTENTION OF THIS PROGRAM. AND
WE URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THE
WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OLD
THREE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO NINE
NINE. SCENE NINE LET'S MOVE TO
RUN TWENTY FORTY ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEN
NONE THERE NOW LET'S MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE CALLERS IN Q. AND
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO NINE
NINE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE GIVE THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER. AN OUTLINE EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTEEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. INSURE MEMBERS JONATHON
FELDMAN THE CALCUTTA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK. THE NUMBER OF
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. IT WASN'T FIGURE OUT FOR
THEIR ANY WITNESSES WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IN FORTY
TWO ALL THREE WERE YOU'RE IN
FORTY TWO ALL THREE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY YOU CAN
WALK UP TO THE MICROPHONE NOW
AND STATE YOUR NAME. OPPOSITION
WHY. NO NOT LISTED AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. THE
DIFFERENCE. YOU'RE GOING TO
STATE YOUR NAME. EIGHT EIGHT
THE YOU'RE GOING TO STATEMENT.
IN YOUR POSITION OUR WE HAVE TO
MOVE ON. WHY TRANSITION IS WHAT
MY POSITION YOU WERE NOT THE
PRIMARY WITH ANYBODY BEING
VICTIMIZED YOU WERE NOT LISTED
AS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO LET ME DO IT LAST
TIME. I GAVE YOU THE COURTESY
WELL I'D LIKE THE COURTESY THIS
TIME WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE.
AND YOU HAD TO LAST TIME WHAT
IS THE DIFFERENCE. I THOUGHT
YOU WERE THE PRIMARY WITNESS
LISTED IN OPPOSITION TO THE
LAST MEASURE WHY DOES IT MATTER
I'M STILL A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA. WHY WOULD YOU DENY
ME YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE WISHING
YOUR TIME YOU HAVE NOT UPDATED
YOUR NAME OR YOUR PREFERRED
HAVING A DIALOGUE BECAUSE THIS
ISN'T MY WHEEL HOUSE AND I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS I'M GIVING YOUR PROCESS
YOU CAN STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BUT I'M OPPOSED TO THIS IN A
QUALIFIED WAY I'M NOT OPPOSED
TO PEOPLE BEING VICTIMIZED IN
ANY WAY. WHAT I'M OPPOSED TO IS
YOU DENYING PEOPLE ENTRANCE TO
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE WE WERE
DENYING YOU INTERVIEW WOULD NOT
BE HERE RIGHT NOW. IF YOU
HAVEN'T DENIED BEING ENTRANCED
I'D BE IN THE JUDICIARY.
COMMITTEE ON OF NOTHING TO DO
WITH. THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACKAND FORTH. VERY MINIMAL
VISION WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON. YOU
COULD HAVE LET ME USE TWO AND A
HALF MINUTES LIKE YOU DID LAST
TIME. BECAUSE I'M NOT IN
SUPPORT OF PEOPLE BEING
VICTIMIZED WHAT I'M NOT IN
SUPPORT OF IS YOU LEGISLATING
THIS WHEN YOU CAN'T EVEN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO LET PEOPLE IN THE
BUILDING. WHY ARE YOU SING
TIME TO DO THIS IF YOU CAN'T
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LET
CALIFORNIANS INTO THE BUILDING.
OUR BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING SAFETY
PROTOCOLS AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
GONNA CALL FOR WHAT FOR A VIRUS
WITH A NINETY NINE POINT 9%
SURVIVAL RATE. YOU DID NOT I
DON'T HUNDRED PEOPLE ENTRANCE
TO THE JUDICIARY. WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE. MEMBERS BRIANNA
CALL FOR FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
YEAH.
I THINK IT WAS PROBABLY
THAT WE'VE WE'VE DONE THAT SO
CENTER LEVEL WITH WHICH YOU
KNOW I'M A BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS CENTER
WINNER. THE BILL. MOVED BY
CENTER WINNER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS WERE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- SENATOR. PUT
TO A VOTE. HELLO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORTH I HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES. WAS A
LITTLE DISTRACTED I APOLOGIZE-
WILL ALWAYS BE ON YOUR FEET IN
THIS JOB. FOR SURE- FIRST OF
ALL WOULD YOU MIND- I I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU WERE THINKING OF
BUT ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF
THE PRIMARY OPPOSITION THAT
WITNESS IS FAR AS- THE FUNDS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN THEIR
IN THE DEPLETION OF IT BECAUSE
OF THE FINES BEING DECREASE AND
SO FORTH. AND NUMBER TWO. IS
THIS- WITH THIS MEASURE.
ENTITLE SOMEONE WHO COMMITS A
CRIME UNDER- IN THAT VIOLENT-
THE- AND ASTOUNDING EVENTUALLY
GUILTY. OF THE CRIME WOULD THEY
BE ALLOWED TO RECEIVE THESE
FUNDS GOOD QUESTIONS I'LL
ANSWER THE SECOND ONE FIRST
THEY WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE IF
CONVICTED OF A CRIME THAT AROSE
OUT OF THE SAME INCIDENT TO
YOUR FIRST POINT OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION HAS NEVER REACHED
OUT TO US THEY'VE NEVER
CONTACTED MY OFFICE SO I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THEM. TO THEIR POINT ABOUT
THE MONEY THAT IS THERE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS ALREADY
COMMITTED THIRTY THREE MILLION
AND GENERAL FUNDS TO THIS
PROGRAM AND THEN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET THIRTY NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION EACH YEAR THERE
AFTER AND THIS BILL DOESN'T
CHANGE ANYTHING WITH CAL B. C.
B. THIS IS JUST ABOUT ACCESS
THIS ISMAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS EVEN THOSE
WHO WERE HARMED BY. THE POLICE.
THEY WERE HARMED BY THE POLICE
BUT NOT CONVICTED OF A CRIME
CORRECT IF THEY WERE CONVICTED
OF A CRIME THAT WOULD NOT BE
OUT OF THAT PARTICULAR
INCIDENT. NOT SOME OTHER CRIME
THEY WOULD THEN BE AT NOT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR COMPENSATION. OKAY
SO FOR THAT PARTICULAR CRIME
THEN THEY WOULD BE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT THAT'S ALL I HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS I COMMITTEES MEMBERS
HEARING C. NINE. CENTER LEYVA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
CHAIR A RESPECT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER
WE HAVE EIGHT TO PASS TO
APPROACH PERFORATIONS
RECOMMENDATION. CONSULTANT WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A
THREE TWO NINE NINE. SB TWO
NINE NINE BRADFORD BY EDWARD II
THE TROUBLED BY PROVOKE I COME
LONGER SKINNER. IN OUR AYE
WINNER WINNER HI FOUR VOTES WE
CAN LEAVE IT FOR THE MEASURE
HAS FOUR VOTES WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU CENTER LABOR FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR PARTICIPATION
HERE TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS. ARE I
DON'T SEE SENATOR JONES WHAT I
DO SEE CENTER CORTESE IF YOU'RE
PREPARED WE WILL. LET YOU
PROCEED NEXT. DO WE NEED TO DO
ANY HOUSEKEEPING- SERGEANT.
FIVE ARE FILE ITEM FIVE SB.
THREE EIGHT THREE BY SENATOR
CORTESE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS SOME I YES I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ON SB THREE
EIGHTY THREE THE JUVENILE
DIVERSION ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SB THREE TWO THREE SIX TO
EXPAND THE REHABILITATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUTHWHO
COMMIT NONVIOLENT FELONIES BY
INCREASING ACCESS TO DIVERSION
PROGRAMS BUT BY DOING THIS WE
CAN ENSURE THAT A SPECIALIZED
SOLUTION IS PROVIDED FOR YOUTH
INSTEAD OF A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH. IN TWO THOUSAND THE
PASSAGE OF PROP TWENTY ONE
GREATLY LIMITED ELIGIBILITY FOR
JUVENILE DIVERSION HOWEVER
MODERN DAY RESEARCH ON
ADOLESCENT BEHAVIOR AND BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT CONFIRM THE- YOUTH
MATTERS IN THAT YOU SHOULD BE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY THAN ADULTS
SB THREE EIGHTY THREE FALLS
THIS RESEARCH BY MAKING USE
CHARGED WITH FELONIES THAT ARE
NOT SERIOUS AND NOT VIOLENT.
ELIGIBLE FOR INFORMAL
SUPERVISION ADDITIONALLY SB
THREE THREE ENSURES A YOUTH
ALLEGED TO HAVE SOLD OR
POSSESSED FOR SALE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE ARE NOT EXCLUDED.
FROM RECEIVING INFORMAL
SUPERVISION SB THREE EIGHTY
THREE ALSO REMOVES UNNECESSARY
PROCEDURAL BARRIERS. TO ALLOW
USE COUNTY OF RESIDENCE TO
CONDUCT AN ANALYSIS OF THE USE
NEEDS AN APPROPRIATE OFFER
INFORMAL SUPERVISION THROUGH
DIVERSION PROGRAM. FOR SB THREE
THREE ENSURES THAT INDIGENT
YOUTH ARE NOT DENIED
ELIGIBILITY FOR DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. SIMPLY DUE TO THEIR
INABILITY TO MAKE RESTITUTION
PAYMENT. MANY OF THESE LAWS
STEM FROM A TOUGH ON CRIME
PERIOD WHERE THESE YOUTH WERE
OFTEN LABELED AS SUPER
PREDATORS. AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WE NOW KNOW THE HARSH
SENTENCES INCREASED PUNISHMENTS
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUTH DOES VERY
LITTLE TO MITIGATE CRIME.
INSTEAD OF THESE KIND OF LAWS
THE CURRENT LAWS CREATE A
COMMERCIAL SOCIETY THAT
DEHUMANIZES THOSE HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF CRIMES WE MUST
CONTINUE TO RIGHT THIS WRONG.
HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY- OVER THE
PHONE OR MULTIPLE OPEN THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THEM I SHOULD SAY
AND JUDGE LYNN EDWARDS LETTERED
AND WORDS I SHOULD SAY WAS ON
THE LINE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE. MISTER CHAIR THAT
WOULD CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION-
CENTER PRESHEAF PRESENTATION
MISS RELOAD ARE YOU PREPARED. I
AM THANK YOU SENATOR I AM MIKE
BELOW DONE BEHALF OF THE
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A SECTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION ALSO WITH ME TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT LEAST
WITH ME REMOTELY IS JUDGE PLAN
EDWARDS OF VERY RESPECTED
JUVENILE COURT JUDGE FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. ABOUT SORT OF
CORTESE NOTED THERE'S REALLY
THREE ELEMENTS OF THE BILL- OUT
TO BE THE SPONSOR AND VERY. TO
HAVE ACHIEVED THE SUPPORT BY A
DIVERSE RANGE OF THE GROUPS
INCLUDING C. A. C. J. AND THE-
CHEAP PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA BUT REALLY THREE
ELEMENTS FIRST- CLEANING UP THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FOR A USER
WHO IS. A RESIDENT OF ONE
COUNTY AND IS ARRESTED IN
ANOTHER THAT ALLOWING THE
COUNTY OF RESIDENCE. ORDER
DIVERSION IN APPROPRIATE
CIRCUMSTANCES SO THAT YOUTH
DOESN'T GET LOST BETWEEN THE
TWO COUNTIES. SECOND CLARIFYING
THAT MERE INDIGENOUS IS NOT A
BASIS FOR DENYING INFORMAL
PROVISIONS FOR FINDING THAT THE
U. FAILED TO COMPLETE
SUPERVISION. AND FINALLY
ALLOWING FOR IN CERTAIN FORMAL
SUPERVSION OF NONVIOLENT NON
SERIOUS FELONIES. IN
APPROPRIATE CIRCUMSTANCES WE'VE
HAD A VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION WITH THE
REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT ON THIS
POINT. IF THERE IS ANY- THE
NECESSARY AMENDMENTS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS OUR INTENT
IS FIRST TIME NONVIOLENT NON
SERIOUS OFFENDERS IN
APPROPRIATE CIRCUMSTANCES. WE
THINK THIS WILL GIVE COURTS.
THE ABILITY TO MAKE THE RIGHT
TOUCH FOR YOU. IN A BEGIN- IN
ACCORD WITH THE NEW RECOMMENDED
PRACTICES. AND WE THINK IT WILL
ALSO REDUCE DISPARITIES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR- AND
AVOID OF SO CALLED JUSTICE BY
GEOGRAPHY PROBLEM. I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
REFER THEM TO JUDGE EDWARDS AND
WOULD AGAIN RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR AT NIGHT. THANK YOU. JUDGE
DREDD WHICH THREE. AM I ON MUTE
RIGHT NOW. WE CAN HEAR WE'VE
GOT- OUR- A SHOT AS YOU CAN.
GEORGE HAVE YOU TAKEN ME OFF
MUTE YET. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
SOMEONE PUT ME ON MUTE AND I
HAVE TO SPEAK TO YOU IS THIS
JUDGE- WORDS WE CAN HEAR YOU-
YOU CAN'T COLLECT GREAT. BOB
THIS IS THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL FOR THE JUVENILE COURT AND
THE YOUNGSTERS WHO APPEAR IN
THAT COURT- I'M SPEAKING FOR A
UNANIMOUS. UNIVERSAL COURT
JUDGE SUPPORT. WITH THESE OF
THE JUDGES WHO SEE THESE KIDS
COME THROUGH. AND FOR THE NON
VIOLENT YOUNGSTERS FIRST TIMERS
WE WANT THE DISCRETION TO KEEP
THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM. BECAUSE
THIS FULLY AS THE ANNIE E.
CASEY. REPORT CALLED THE
TRANSFORMING JUVENILE PROBATION.
RECOMMENDED THAT WE LOCKED
GATHER IN YOUNGSTERS WHO DON'T
NEED TO BE THERE. AND THE
INFORMAL SUPERVISION IS NEVER
THE LESS SUPERVISION BUT IT
DOESN'T GET THEM ENTANGLED IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND SO WE THINK THIS IS VERY
SENSIBLE. THIS IS A GOOD
STATUTES THAT JUVENILE COURT
JUDGES EMBRACE AND I SHOULD
JUST THAT AS A SIDE NOTE THAT
THERE IS NO ORE CONFUSING AREA
IN THE LAW THE JUVENILE COURT
LAW. THEN ONE. CRIME OCCURS IN
ONE COURT AND THE COURT IS
HERE'S IN ONE COUNTY AND THEN
THE COURT HEARS THE MATTER IN
ANOTHER COUNTY I GUARANTEED
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS CONFUSION
IN THOSE CASES THIS LEGISLATION
WILL HELP THAT SITUATION OUT.
SIGNIFICANTLY SO IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS I'LL BE GLAD TO
ANSWER THEM BUT I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL AND ASK
THAT YOU. VOTE HI. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE WELL
WITNESSES AND FORTY TWO OH
THREE- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. CENA AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO NOW TO TWENTY FORTY. WE
SEE NO ONE THERE AS AS WELL NOW
MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
PHONE LINES WERE LOOKING FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE EIGHT THREE MODERATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. THEN ZERO COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. LINE EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK
INSPIRATION- YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTION HELLO BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CONNECT WITH US.
BLINDLY EIGHT HUNDRED NINETEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. BLINDED SEVEN HUNDRED
ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
THEY'RE MAKING ON BEHALF OF AN
ISSUE JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
BLIND SIX HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
YOUR MY KIDS OPEN. BLIND. SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON BUCKLEY CALLED
LOW HOUSTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
IMPORT. BLIND SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. IS
THAT MEANS. THIS MONTH. YES IT
IS YOU'RE MICHAEL OKAY OKAY-
THE ADDRESS OF CALIFORNIA FILMS
AND TO THE LOVE OF THE CAMPAIGN
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU MIX
WITNESS. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
THIRTEEN HERE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO FROM THE STOCKBROKER'S
AVERAGE PROJECT SACRAMENTO
COURT. INCLINED SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
ONE SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY HEREBY
IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR MAIL.
YES IT IS. IT MEANS FIVE EIGHT
CALL. I AM DELIGHTED PROJECTED
AND WHAT'S YOUR FAMILIES
BETWEEN THE CORPORATE
STRUGGLING TO BRING. Q. NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GIVE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER. IN THAT
LINE EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. THERE S.
THE BRANCH INTERMENT IS CO AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE
EIGHTY THREE. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
AT THE TIME. REGIS ASHU CHECKED
ALONG ONE MORE TIME FOR ME
WITNESSES WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THREE EIGHT THREE.
SURE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. BUTTON ZERO COMMAND AGAIN
ONE. ZERO WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GIVE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER
PLEASE. AND IT LINE EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AT THREE
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU. N.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVED
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
PHONE WITH THIS IN OPPOSITION
LISTED NOW WILL GO TO ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE EIGHT THREE. SCENE NINE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL
NOW MR MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO
OUR PHONE LINES SEEKING
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE EIGHT THREE. FOR COMMENTS
AND OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE
EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL DO THAT ONE MORE PASS AT
THAT TO MAKE SURE. SURE FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO U. S.
B. THREE EIGHT THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND MISTER
KERR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU HAVING NO
TAKERS WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND- ANY
QUESTIONS- FOR THE AUTHOR BY
COMMITTEE SENATOR WINNER. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR WINNER
CENTER CHOI BOGUE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST- FOR THE
RETURNEES SPEAK I WOULD FIRST
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD. I HAVE A HEART FOR
PEOPLE AB FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
GET CAUGHT UP IN OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM OFTENTIMES THESE
CHILDREN ARE VICTIMS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT BRAINS ARE STILL
DEVELOPING AT THIS STAGE- I AM
A HUGE FAN OF DOCTOR RISEN DIE
WHO IS. FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
HAS WRITTEN SEVERAL BOOKS ON
THE MALE AND THE FEMALE BRAIN
AND EXPLAINS IN THAT BOOK. HOW
THE BRAINS ARE AFFECTED- THE
HORMONES AND CHEMICALS OF FACT.
THE BRAIN IN THE THOUGHT
PROCESS AT THAT STAGE- AND I AM
ALSO A STRONG BELIEVER IN THE
POWER OF REDEMPTION. AND
ESPECIALLY BELIEVE THAT
CHILDREN ARE WORTHY OF SECOND
CHANCES. GETTING CAUGHT UP IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM CAN
JEOPARDIZE EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING AND CAN ALSO CAUSE
TRAUMA STRESS AND HAVE
EFFECTIVE FURTHER PUSHING THESE
CHILDREN DOWN THE PATH OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR. I SUPPORT
THE INTENDED GOALS OF THIS BILL
SAID- BY THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS TO GIVE JUDGES THE
OPTION OF. OFFERING INFORMAL
SUPERVISION T. TO HAVE MADE A
FIRST TIME MISTAKE. HOWEVER I
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
BROAD THE BROAD NATURE F THE
OFFENSES THAT WOULD QUALIFY
UNDER THIS BILL. SPECIFICALLY I
HAVE CONCERNS WITH REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT FOR UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. FOR SOME OF THE
CRIMES THAT FALL UNDER WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE SEVEN OF
SEVEN B. INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
MURDER RAPE KIDNAPPING. WHICH
SEEM TO BE THE EXACT CASES IN
WHICH WE WOULD WANT TO ONLY
QUALIFY TO ONLY QUALIFY UNDER
UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCES- AND I
HAVE A QUESTION. WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO WORK ON LANGUAGE
MOVING FORWARD TO KEEP THE
CURRENT UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCES
REQUIREMENT IN PLACE FOR SOME
OF THESE MORE EQUALLY JUST
CASES. I'M SORRY IT'S SINKING
THE DIALOGUE GOING- I'M NOT
CLEAR OTHER THAN- CREATING
DISCRETION THAT THERE'S YOU
KNOW ANY RISK OF THE BILL OF
THOSE SERIOUS AND VIOLENT-
FELONIES YOU KNOW COMING UNDER
THE AUSPICES OF THIS DIRECTION
IN THIS BILL BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
BE. IF IT'S A- IT'S THE
TERRORISTS- PURVIEW TODAY I'M
HAPPY TO DEFER TO JUDGE PLAN
EDWARDS WHO- OF THIS WORKS
EXTENSIVELY UP AND DOWN THE
STATE IN THE SPECIFIC AREA THAT
YOU'RE- YOU KNOW THAT YOUR-
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SENATOR-
SO IF THAT'S WE CANNOT TURN TO.
A YES TO CHAIRED IN GEORGIA
WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
TO THE QUESTIONS. THE JUDGE TO
ONLINE OR. ONE MOMENT PLEASE SO
I WILL TAKE L. I WILL CHECK.
HELLO. THAT EDWARDS PLEASE GO
AHEAD OKAY THANK YOU BOB THAT
WAS A VERY GOOD QUESTION- AND
DOES SENATOR AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY RESPONSIVE TO THAT
YOU JUST AS UNDER CURRENT LAW
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT FELONIES ON
THE SEVEN OH SEVEN B. THE LIST
HAVE A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
OF THE INELIGIBILITY FOR
INFORMAL SUPERVISION UNDER SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE THE COURT
CAN REBUT THAT PRESUMPTION BY
FINDING THAT THE VERSION WOULD
BE IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE.
AND INTEREST OF JUSTICE
ANALYSIS IS PRACTICALLY DRIVEN
AND CASE SPECIFIC AND REQUIRES
AN ANALYSIS UP NOT JUST THE UK
NEEDS BUT ALSO THE INTERESTS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE VICTIM'S
PERSPECTIVE ONLY THE COURT CAN
READ BUT THE PRESUMPTION NOT
THE PROBATION OFFICER THIS IS
ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
PURPOSE OF THE JUVENILE COURT
LAW TO PROVIDE FOR THE
PROTECTION AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND EACH YOU UNDER ITS
JURISDICTION I REFER OF COURSE
TO WELFARE INCIDENTS
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION TWO
OH TWO WHICH IS THE PURPOSE
CLAUSE. OF THE JUVENILE LAW. SO
IF I MAY IF I MAY JUST FOLLOW
UP WITH A SENATOR AND SHEER
FUND QUESTIONS BUT IT CERTAINLY
WILL BE PART OF MY DIRECTION AS
WE GO FORWARD- TO- TO HELP-
CONTINUE DIALOGUE IN THIS AREA
TO MAKE SURE IT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR
BEFORE- HE WOULD HAVE TO VOTE
ON THE BILL AGAIN. PERFECT
THANK YOU. FIND. IN ORDER TO A
BURGER FINAL YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. KERN TINA AND WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR WARNER WE
HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
TO APPROPRIATIONS. ON S. B.
THREE EIGHT THREE CONSULTANT
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB THREE EIGHT THREE DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS BRADFORD BRADFORD
I IN TROUBLE. JOBO GUY COMMAGER
I AM LONGER AYE SKINNER SKINNER
I WIENER WIENER AYE THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES LATER THE MAJOR
APPS FIVE VOTES IT IS OUR
COMMITTEE CONGRADULATIONS THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN CENTER
SECRETION THANK YOU. NEXT UP
SHE SHE'S READY TO GO SENATOR
ALSO WITH SB. SEVEN THREE ONE.
IT GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
WILL BE PRESENTING SB SEVEN
THREE ONE AND I WANT TO START
BY TAKING AN AN AMENDMENT TO
CLARIFY THAT COURTS DA'S AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS HAVE ACCESS
TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S COMPLETE
CONVICTION RECORDS- JUST TO
MAKE THAT. EVEN MORE CLEAR.
FROM WHAT DOES SB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE DO IT CREATES AN AUTOMATIC
PROCESS TO PHASE OUT RECORDS OF
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS OVERTIME
IN TWO PHASES STEP ONE THE
PARTIAL CEILING ONCE SOMEONE
HAS COMPLETED THEIR SENTENCE
INCLUDING THEIR INITIAL POST
RELEASE SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT ANY
ARRESTS OR CONVICTIONS THEIR
CRIMINAL RECORD BECOMES
PARTIALLY SEALED. FOR BASIC
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING PURPOSES
STEP TWO IS A FULL FEELING IT
AFTER A PARTIAL CEILING THE
PERSON THEN MAINTAINS A FURTHER
PERIOD OF TWO YEARS. BEYOND THE
END OF SENTENCE IN SUPER VISIT
SUPERVISION DURING WHICH THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED OF A
NEW CRIME THEY WOULD RECEIVE
FULL CEILING OF THEIR
CONVICTION RECORD. I AM JOINED
BY A DIVERSE COALITION OF
ECONOMIC JUSTICE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE BUSINESS AND COMMERCIAL
GROUPS AND RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS ALL OF WHICH ARE
HERE TO CALL FOR AN END TO THE
SYSTEM SYSTEMIC.
DISENFRANCHISEMENT AN EXCLUSION
THAT AFFECTS AS MANY AS EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. AND MANY
MANY MORE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TODAY- THE LOS ANGELES CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ADDED THEIR
SUPPORT. SB SEVEN THREE ONE
WILL CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE
PROCESS TO SEAL CONVICTION AND
ARREST RECORDS- AS I SAID THERE
ARE. EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. LIVING WITH AN
ARRESTER CONVICTION ON THEIR
RECORD THEY ARE OUR SIBLINGS
OUR PARENTS THEIR NEIGHBORS CO
WORKERS FELLOW CHURCH GOERS
WHEN IT INDIVIDUAL COMPLETES
OUR SENSE THEY HAVE PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY AND ACCEPTED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. WHILE THEY ARE
INCARCERATED MANY OF THEM TOOK
CLASSES ARE ENROLLED IN
COUNSELING THEY PURSUED THEIR
REHABILITATION AND WORKED HARD
TO BE PREPARED FOR REENTRY INTO
OUR COMMUNITY AFTER THE RELEASE
INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO PUT
THEIR NEW SKILLS TO USE THE ARE
HIT WITH LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
RESTRICTIONS AND LIMITATIONS.
THAT KEEP THEM FROM BUILDING A
NEW LIFE CALIFORNIA MAINTAINS
AN INDIVIDUAL'S CONVICTION
RECORDS UNTIL THEY REACH A
HUNDRED YEARS OF AGE. A PAST
RECORD DENIES A NEW FAMILY FROM
MOVING INTO A NEW HOUSE. DENIES
MOTHERS THE CHANCE TO PURSUE A
CAREER IN EDUCATION AND DENIES
FATHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COACH THEIR CHILDREN. SOMEONE
WITH THE PAST RECORD CAN BE
BLOCKED FROM RECEIVING
FINANCIAL AID OR ACCESS TO
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. A
PARENT CAN BE DENIED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADOPT A FAMILY
MEMBER OR PREVENTED FROM
JOINING THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION. NEARLY 75% OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE STILL EMPLOYED
UNEMPLOYED A YEAR AFTER
RELEASE. OUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. INVEST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS YET ALL WE DO IS DRIVE
THOSE PEOPLE TO THE MARGINS OF
SOCIETY. RATHER THAN PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY BLANKET
RESTRICTIONS AND BARRIERS
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CYCLE OF
CRIME. OUR COALITION REPORTS
ARE AS MANY AS THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BEEN DENIED EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE
OF PAST RECORDS IN THIS LAST
YEAR ALONE. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS THE TOOLS
TO TURN THE PAGE ON THEIR PAST
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
A NEW AND BETTER LIFE- SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY
WILL BE FATHER GREG BOYLE AND
HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES AND AT
LITTLE. FROM CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. JOHN CUTLER
FROM CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
I URGE AND AIBEL. THANK YOU. MR
LOW READY OR ARE WE GONNA START
WOULD FATHER BOYLE. OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES MR LOW OR FATHER
BOYLE. MODERATOR YOU ONE OF
THOSE ON. OKAY. HELLO- NO NO.
I
DO NOT SEE EITHER WITNESSES
BEING CONNECTED. BY. THIS
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE CALLS IN
QUEUE OUR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
FOR OUR. OKAY. WITNESSES FOR S.
P. SEVEN THIRTY ONE ARE NOT
CONNECTED. LOOKS LIKE THEY
DIDN'T CALL IN. THE THIRD CHAIR.
THE WITH I'M SORRY MISTER CHAIR
FOR CAN- I'VE BEEN TOLD THE
WITNESSES SAY THEY ARE ON HOLD.
MR BY THEY WERE ON HOLD.
SENATOR SKINNER HI I KNOW THIS
IS NOT OUR- ACTICIN ORDER BUT
WHILE THIS IS BEING SORTED MAY
I SPEAK TO THE- OFFICE THAT OUT
FOR A LITTLE BIT CENTER YOU MAY
SPEAK TO THE BILL. THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE FOR THOSE WERE
LISTENING THAT USUALLY WE WOULD
TAKE TESTIMONY BEFORE SOMEONE
SPEAKS TO A BILL THAT I HAVE T
STEP OUT FOR ABOUT A HALF AN
HOUR FROM COMMITTEE. AND IN
RETURN SO I WANTED TO EXPRESS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRING US THE BILL AND HER
DESCRIPTION OF THE CUMBERSOME.
NATURE A COMMERCIAL I'M EVEN IF
IT'S JUST NOT EVEN APPROPRIATE
WORK. RATHER THE STIGMA. THAT
IS PUT ON A PERSON. ONCE THEY
HAVE A RECORD. NOW CLEARLY. IF
A PERSON HAS COMMITTED A CRIME.
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE CONVICTED
AND- GIVEN WHATEVER
APPROPRIATE- SENTENCE OR
PROBATION OR WHAT HAVE YOU. AND
THEY HAVE BEEN BEEN CRIME FREE.
THERE SHOULD BE NO MORE STICKY.
THEY'VE ALREADY KAY AND THEIR
FAMILIES ALREADY HAVE HAD GREAT
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES TO
THEIR- TO JUST THE WHOLE
PROCESS OF. YOU KNOW HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THE CONVICTION AND-
IF THEY HAVE TO GO TO COURT AND
THEN OF COURSE ANY TIME IN JAIL
OR PRISON. SO THERE'S ALREADY
GREAT GREAT ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES TODAY AND THEIR
FAMILIES. SO ONCE THEY ARE
CRIME FREE WE HAVE TO REMOVE
EVERY OBSTACLE FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO FUNCTION. AND THAT
RECORD. IS A BARRIER JUSTICE
THE AUTHOR SAID IN ALMOST EVERY
ASPECT OF LIFE. IT IS LIKE YOU
ARE. ARE MARKED FOR LIFE. AND
NEVER REALLY ALLOWED TO FULLY
FUNCTION. AND I JUST THINK THAT
IT IS. NOT SOMETHING THAT WE- I
WANT TO DO. AN WHEN WE ARE
THINK ABOUT. THAT IT IS
DISPROPORTIONATE WHO IS. STOP
ARRESTED CHARGED AND CONVICTED
FOR EXAMPLE I DON'T HAVE ANY
MEMBER OF MY FAMILY WHO ARE
SERVE TIME BUT I CAN TELL YOU
MANY MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY HAVE
COMMITTED CRIMES. AND THEY WERE
LET OFF FOR ANY NUMBER OF
THINGS. AND SO THEY DON'T HAVE
THAT STIGMA. SO I JUST FEEL WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ONCE A PERSON HAS IS CRIME FREE
TO GIVE THEM EVERY OPPORTUNITY
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT
THE AUTHORS GOING. ON AND I
WILL VOTE FOR THE BILL I WOULD
EVEN MOVE IT BUT I THINK IT'S
NOT APPROPRIATE TO DO THAT TO
HEAR FROM WITNESSES AND SUCH
BUT PERHAPS WE'RE IN THAT MODE
AND APOLOGIES THAT I HAVE TO
STEP OUT. BUT- I WILL RETURN.
THANK YOU NOW MODERATOR WILL GO
BACK TO OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
TO WE HAVE MISTER LITTLE OUR
FATHER BOYLE READY TO TESTIFY.
ADD A LITTLE OR FATHER BOYLE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO WE AN
IDENTIFY WHICH LINE IS YOURS
AND WE WILL ON MUTE YOUR MIKE.
THIS. A LITTLE. AT LITTLE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE NUMBERS OF SAN
PUBLIC SAFETY. MY NAME IS A
LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND I COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY
LIVING WITH SEVEN ONE WEST.
MISDEMEANOR OR FELONY
CONVICTION. HERE'S NEAR MERICAN
SAID LIVE WITH YES. THAT MORE A
PERSON PAYS GIPSON SOCIETY.
AFTERWARDS PERSONAGE THREE TO
MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES.
MICHIGAN ROAD SYSTEM SHOULD
SHOULD THAT ACTION IN THE WHAT
IS A RELEASE FORM. FOR ARE ABLE
TO STICKAGAIN EMPLOYMENT AND
STAY HOUSE. THE REALITY IS FOR
FROM THE START. THANK ACTUALLY
LIVE NEAR ME WHAT SHOULD A KIND
OF IN THE STATE OF. BECAUSE THE
STATE CHIEF THAT RIGHT AND SHE
MORE HUNDRED YEARS OF AGE. YES
WE SHOULD. ONCE A PERSON IS
COMING IN A CO OF LAW. WHAT
YOU'RE STATUS SHOWED STUDENTS
THE REALITY. YES GIVEN THE
LIKES. ONCE A PERSON COMES HOME.
THEMSELVES TO FREE FROM THE
CHECK THANK. THEY ARE NOT
FORCED TO WEAR THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES YOU LET TRYING TO
CHANGE THE CONVICTION. TRYING
CHANGED TO TWO O'CLOCK IN
TRIPLE CERTAIN IN A SOCIETY
WHERE ARE BASS. LEGALLY THE
FINEST FASHIONABLE ARE MARCHING
LIST PORTION WILL DEBT.
FASHIONABLE DEAD PERSON WE ARE
BOTH FROM ALL OF ENTRY. HOW
PROFESSIONAL. EDUCATION HOLDING
PUBLIC. MORNING OR A L. A. ADAN
A LAW LUNCH TO KEEP OUT OF CARE
LOADING YOUR RESEARCH AND SOME
CASES CORRECT CUSTODY OF OUR
OWN SHOULD. THE TO CALL LEFT
ASK. AND OTHERS FOR THAT.
DISENFRANCHISEMENT PEOPLE WITH.
DIDN'T STOP IN THE TWIN FIRST.
LET ME LAWS PRODUCTS IN THIS
THAT WILL BE A TOMORROW. AND
FOR. BLACK AND BLUE PEOPLE
SHOULD BE IN THE EIGHTEEN
CENTURY THANK ANY MOMENT GOING
THE GENERAL ERA. CLOSER TO.
METERS MOORLACH BROWN IN A
PEOPLE IN THIS ASK FOR TO BE.
IN TREATED AS SHE BEINGS. DAY
ACTUALLY ON THIS OF NEW HOMES-
OF MARGINAL CAL. ASKING TO
REMOVE THE ELECTRONICS. THAT
BIND THE AND PAY COULD PROVE
FOR LACK. SB SEVEN THREE ONE
SEVEN SIX INCOME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. BOB
BOYLE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO ON CALL
THE GRADE POINT ON THE SOUND
RECALL WE INDUSTRIES WE'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR THIRTY THREE YEARS
AND LAW CENTER COMMONLY CIRCLE
ONLY. WE ARE THE LARGEST KING
OF THE REHAB GRANT PRO ON
PLANET WE HAVE ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND FOLKS HERE WALK
THROUGH OUR DOORS WANTING TO.
REDIRECT THEIR LIVES AND
REIMAGINE SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
YEAH PLUG YOUR EFFORTS- IN SB
SEVEN ONE TO REMOVE THE GIRDERS
PEOPLE WHO LIVE WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION. AS MENTIONED
EARLIER EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS I HAVE A
CONVICTION ON THEIR RECORD AND-
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOUR
STRUCTURED AUTOMATED APPROACH
TO STEALING CONVICTION RECORDS.
SAVE A TON OF MONEY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT WILL
ADDRESS MASS INCARCERATION. IN
AS MUCH AS WELL. YOU WILL TEMP
THE RESEARCH RATE OF. ALLOW MEN
AND WOMEN TO BE PARENTS TO
THEIR CHILDREN. AND THE BECAUSE
CERTAINLY OLD CONVICTIONS AND
HAVE ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING. SO- MORE NUMBERS SO
GREATLY- HONORED REALLY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL SEVEN B. SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE. AND THAT IN
SO DOING YOU KNOW YOU WILL ALSO
ADDRESS- ECONOMIC DISPARITY IN
RACIAL EQUITY AND SETTLE AND BE
ASSIGNING THE SYMBOL REALLY FOR
OTHER STATES WHO ARE TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH A SIMILAR ISSUE SO
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE THOUSANDS
WHO COME THROUGH OUR DOORS AT
ALL OR INDUSTRIES WANTING TO
TRUST BE PRODUCTIVE. IN. TWO
PARENTS TO THEIR KIDS. I THANK
YOU YOUR SUPPORT. SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO OLD
THREE YEAH I SEE NO ONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SEVEN THREE ONE
WE'RE GO. OPERATOR NOW LET'S
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES AND FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THREE ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN THREE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. BLIND
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY NINE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN SENATORS THIS IS
ANTHONY MARTINO WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE.
KOLKHOZ WANTED SEVEN THREE ONE
JAMIE COMMITTEE TIME THE
TEACHER COMMISSION I WILL BE
READING UP ON THE OF
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO GAVE US OUR MISSION TO SAY
THEY ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WE THE PEOPLE SAN DIEGO. HELLO
TO THE COMMUNITY ASIAN
SOLIDARITY COLLECTIVE STRENGTH
DIGNITY SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE SAN DIEGO SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE NORTH COUNTY
SAN DIEGO SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER ELLA BAKER SAID BUT
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
MISSY FRANKLIN MARKETS HARISH
RENDON GARCIA AND ADRIAN DAQRI
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
THANK GOODNESS. POLITELY EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY YOUR MY KIDS
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
THIS WE CAN GET. YES MY NAME IS
JOSH FOR THIS I'M SPEAKING OUT
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. WE'RE DELIGHTED
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS BENJAMIN
TRAVON ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS REALLY SANCHEZ WITH
MILLER SAID BUT IT'S AN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF RESTORE
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BLIND SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. ONE SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOUR MY KIDS
OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR MAIL.
ONE EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
YOUR MY KIDS UP AND- MISTER
JOHN MEMBERS MELANIE SHINING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE. BLIND EIGHT
HUNDRED FORTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED SENATORS ISN'T AS WELL
KNOWN AS A PAINTER SET UP AS A
COALITION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
BONTA SAID THE COMMITTEE TIME
UP WITH A SHARPER PERSONS COME
A PERMISSION I WOULD LIKE TO
READ OFF A LIST OF SUPPORTERS-
WE HAVE. BEEN GIVEN THE
PERMISSION TO DO SO. THOSE
BEING DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA LEGAL AID AT WORK
CATHCART COUNSELING SERVICES
YOUNG WOMAN FREEDOM CENTER
TIMELESS GROUP. CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
THE CITY OF REFUGE CHURCH LA.
JOHN'S WELL CHILD AND FAMILY
CENTER ALEX NOT BOTTLENECK.
MARYAM SHOULD WOMEN BOB BRITTON.
AND ELIZABETH KING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CENTER YES. THE LION
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD UP. AB ONE
EDWARDS CALLING INTO VOICE
STARTING OVER IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU. A LINE EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE J. LAST YEAR'S
POLICY COORDINATOR FOR
COMMUNITIES DO NOT A STORAGE
JUSTICE AND URGE YOUR LIFEBOAT
SB. SEVEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
BLIND SIX HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
YOUR MY KIDS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. OR. LINE EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. ENTER NUMBER OF.
LOTUS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE AND IF THE
COURT. BY EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. DAN
GOLDSTINE RETIRED LIEUTENANT
WITH ON THE BEACH POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND EFFECTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MOM POSTED ACTION
FOR. ACTION PARTNERSHIP IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. BLIND. SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE YOUR MY
KIDS OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE. TIFFANY WHITE WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY ONE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. YOUR SHEER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RELIGIOUS ACTION CENTER OF
REFORM JUDAISM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED FOUR
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. THIS IS ADAM
WORKING CHAIRED OF THE SOCIAL
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE OF THE UNIVERSALIST
UNITARIAN CHURCH VERISIGN. YOUR
AVAILABLE IN THE PARKING EACH
NIGHT CHANGE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. BLIND
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY SIX YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON SENATORS MRS MICHAEL
GETS SLOWER WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORED SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. THE COMMITTEE TIME
WITH THE CHAIRS PERMISSION I
WILL BE READING OFF A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
HAVE GIVEN THEIR PERMISSION TO
STAY THERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. I HOPE WE'RE NOT AND
RECOVERY. AN ISSUE JUSTICE.
THERE IS AN THEIR ENVELOPES THE
MEASURE COUNTRIES ON THE FAST.
WE ARE COMMUNITY SAID THE GUY.
PRESENT BERRY SOON. TIME FOR
CHANGE FOUND. HELLO ALLIANCE
FOR YOU THANK COMMUNITY JUSTICE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
UC RIVERSIDE CHAPTER. MOLLY
CALHOUN ANTHONY CHAPA CRAWFORD
RICHARD SPIEGELMAN ANTI TAYLOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THIS.
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY ONE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. YOU COULD
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS OLD. AND YEAH.
BALAJI SACRAMENTO ACT IN A
CLEAR AT THAT SHOULD BE HEY
YOU'RE MIKE BE OVER SHOWN TO AT.
ALAINA SEVEN HUNDRED YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. SPEEDIER JIMENEZ
CALLED IT WAS SUPPORT AS SEVEN
ONE. BLIND SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS KATHERINE THE FINAL
I AM CALLING ON SUPPORT SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TORY
BERBER STYLE GUARD DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
IN FUL SUPPORT SB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM. AND
SHE SAID YOU. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS MICHAEL
WIFE THROUGH THE COMMUNITY SAN
DIEGO COLIN IS STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE SEVEN HUNDRED TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN- GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS MORALISTIC ON BEHALF OF BEND
THE ARC JEWISH ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SEVEN THIRTY ONE.
ONE EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. KIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE TREND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. BLIND SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE YOUR MY
KIDS UP AND. ONE HUNDRED HELLO
WE CAN AREA. THIS IS ALEX
MCLEISH WITH THE US PROSTITUTES
COLLECTIVE HEARING SUPPORT AT.
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THIS IS YOUR
ESPINOZA CARESS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. S. B. SEVEN THIRTY
ONE. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTEEN
HERE MIKE IT'S OPEN. ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTEEN HERE MY KIDS
OPENS. DEANGELO OUTREACH
PROJECT SACRAMENTO AND STRONG
SUPPORT. BLIND SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO. HELLO WE CAN AREA. YES
FIFTY FIVE THE NEXT FRIDAY CALL
AND- REPRESENTAN FAMILY UNITED
SUBJECTED AND YOU'LL FAMILIES
AND COOPERATED AND WE ARE ALSO
STRONG SB. SEVEN THREE ONE.
THANK YOU. BLINDS SIX HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. BLIND SIX HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE. BLIND
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY SIX YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
I WOULD QEDANI WHISTLING AND
SYNDROME QEDANI REPRESENTING
BOTH THE AMITY FOUNDATION AS
WELL AS THE COALITION FOR
RESPONSIBLE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BUT LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS FOR THIS
BILL AND WE ARE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER TERRY WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THIS IS A
RARE DISH- SHE CHECKED LINES
ONE MORE TIME FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF ITS P. SEVEN THREE
ONE. SURE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SEVEN THREE ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. IN A LINE EIGHT HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
YES THIS IS CARLA DELLA GRANDER
FROM PILLARS THE COMMUNITY SAN
DIEGO CALLING IN SUPPORT. BLIND
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY YOUR MY KIDS
UP AT. LET ME. YES IT IS. OKAY
THE ACTRESS WITH THEM IS NOT
THE BEST A PHONE LINE NOT
SOMETHING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
NINETY TWO YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
LATER AS THE COLORS OF THE
COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
SIXTY YOUR MY KIDS OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MAIL. LINE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA GENE ROBINSON I AM
WITH COMMUNITY KILLER DOT ORG
I'M A CO FOUNDER ALONG WITH HIM
REPORTS SHE- OPINION EMAIL .ORG
AND WHEN WE CAN USE EACH OTHER
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU.
WHY AN EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI MOM
WHAT BECAUSE OF THE COMMUNITY
SAID GIGGLE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. AN
ONLINE SIX HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. BLIND SIX
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN HERE MIKE
IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE.
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO OPPOSITION AROSE ARE THERE
ARE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF. THREE SEVEN
THREE ONE I SEE WE HAVE A
FRIEND C. KOEHLER AND WE HAVE
LARRY MARSH ARMS MODERATOR OR
EITHER OR BOTH OF THOSE. APPEAR
TO TESTIFY AT THIS MOMENT. WE
HAVE A LAYER OF EARTH. YEAH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR-
NUMBER READY CORY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE A PORTION OF
THIS BILL WHAT ARCHIVE FELONY
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS SO THAT
THEY WOULD NOT APPEAR ON STATE
OR FEDERAL COURT HISTORY
INFORMATION. AS WE RATE THIS
BILL A PERSON CONVICTED OF
EMBEZZLING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FROM
MULTIPLE ELDERLY VICTIMS AND
SENT TO PRISON FOR THOSE CRIMES
WOULD IF THE RELIEF OFFERED IN
THIS BILL WERE GRANTED THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR A
JOB AS A BOOKKEEPER OR CFO FOR
A LONG TER BOARDING CARE
FACILITY WITHOUT THE OWNER'S OF
THE FACILITY OR THE RESIDENTS
OR THEIR FAMILIES HAVING ANY
IDEA. OF HIS OR HER CRIMINAL
PAST. WHAT BURKE. DOES THIS.
OFFERED TO UNWARY BUSINESS
OWNER WHO HIRES A PERSON WITH A
HISTORY OF FINANCIAL CRIMES.
THAT BUSINESS OWNER HAVE NO
RIGHT TO PROTECT HERSELF FOR
CUSTOMERS. SIMILARLY A PERSON
COULD HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF A
FELONY FOR CORPORAL ABUSE OF A
CHILD AND THEN PETITION FOR THE
RELIEF OFFERED IN THIS BILL.
FIRST REMAINS TO. PREPRINT TWO
YEARS AFTER THE RELIEF WAS
GRANTED HERE SHE COULD THEN
APPLY FOR A JOB AT A DAYCARE
FACILITY. WITHOUT EITHER THE
OWNER OR OTHER PARENTS BEING
AWARE. OF HIS OR HER CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND. WE DO RECOGNIZE THE
SERIOUS EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
IMPEDIMENTS THAT CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS COMPOSED FOR A
PERSON WITH A FELONY
CONVICTION. AND OF OFFERED
REPEATEDLY TO WORK WITH
ADVOCATES TO ENSURE THAT ANY
CALLS. US TO THE RESTRICTIONS.
CARE SOME TANGENTIAL
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CRIME. OR
CRIMES COMMITTED AND ARE
NEITHER ARBITRARY NOR UNDULY
PUNITIVE. AS IS SO OFTEN THE
CASE CDA IS NOT OPPOSED TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL OBJECTIVE
UNDERLYING THIS BILL. BUT THE
SWEEP OF THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT
PROVIDE ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS FOR
BUSINESS OWNERS AND FAMILIES OR
OTHERS. WHO HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THEY HIRE. ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
POSITIONS OF TRUST WITH READY
ACCESS TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. AS WE READ THE
BILL ANY FELONY ARRESTS WERE
RELIEF WAS GRANTED UNDER
SECTION EIGHT FIFTY ONE. NINE
THREE WOULD BE ARCHIVED IF THE
DEFENDANT HAD NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF A NEW OFFENSE
WITHIN TWO YEARS OF RELIEF
BEING GRANTED. BACK TO BE
PROBLEMATIC FOR SEVERAL
REASONS. FOR EXAMPLE IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR FELONY CASES TO
TAKE TWO OR MORE YEARS TO
RESOLVE. THESITUATION VERY
LIKELY EXACERBATED IN THE
AFTERMATH OF COLORED NINETEEN.
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS GRANTED
RELIEF UNDER EIGHT FIFTY ONE
POINT NINE THREE OR ANY OF THE
OTHER IN HUMAN THERE THE NEW
OPERATED WILL LEAVE SECTIONS.
COULD HAVE A FELONY CASE
PENDING DURING THE TWO YEAR
PERIOD SINCE RELIEF WAS
GRANTED. CONSEQUENTLY AS A
MATTER OF LOS ANGELES-
INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE THEIR
PRIOR FELONY CONVICTION
ARCHIVES. BECAUSE THEY HAD NOT
BEEN CONVICTED UNTIL AFTER THE
TWO YEAR PERIOD EXPIRED. AS THE
STABENOW'S IS NOTED THERE ARE
STATE LICENSING AREAS BEYOND
THOSE ADDRESSED IN THE BILL
THAT COULD BE PROBLEMATIC IF
THIS BILL WERE TO PASS. THE
MEASURE IS JUST FAR TOO BROAD
WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. IN CHARGERS DRAFT
SOMETHING MORE NARROWLY. AND
MORE PRO PUBLIC SAFETY. AS
WRITTEN WE GREAT. ABOUT THE AND
RISK. I FOR A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE MOVED
TO MISS KOEHLER. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FRANTIC
COLOR AND I AM A TWO TERM PAST
PRESIDENT AND THE CURRENT
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS CHAIR OF
CALLIE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS CERTAINLY KELLY
SUPPORT A PROCESS TO GIVE
PEOPLE A SECOND CHANCE
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT INVOLVES
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. BUT
WE'RE CONCERNED HOWEVER THAT SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE IT'S NOT
STRIKE AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE ABILITY OF
CONVICTED INDIVIDUALS TO BUILD
A NEW LIFE AND THE PROTECTION
OF THE PUBLIC. HAS WRITTEN- THE
MEASURE WOULD PLACE LEGAL-
MEASURES ADDED AND VERY
DISADVANTAGED. I UNDERSTAND
STAND THEN THE RISE OF SAYS HER
BILL BEEN AMENDED AND DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS WOULD HAVE ACCESS. SO
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR SENATOR
ALSO AT THE END OF MY TESTIMONY
AND BAD IS GOOD A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY HAVE ACCESS TO
ANYONE. FROM ALL THE STREET. OR
IS IT JUST THEIR CLIENT-
BECAUSE THEY ARE MANY TIME THAT
COULD HOLD ATTORNEY WILL LOOK
AT CRIMINAL RECORDS REGARDING
YOUR OWN WITNESSES THAT THE
PROSECUTION OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
UP TO KNOW ABOUT AND MAYBE MAY
OR MAY NOT AND- I DECIDE TO
CALL THEM. SO IT RAISES ISSUES
WHICH SEEMS AT THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHAT HAVE. SPECIAL
EXPERTISE AND ABSENT A REFERRAL
TO THAT COMMITTEE I WOULD URGE
ARE WE WOULD URGE SAID- THERE
COUNCIL COULD BE CONSULTED.
ACCOUNT ALSO CONCERNED THAT SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE IS SO BROAD
THAT IT'S QUITE FORESEEABLE
THAT PROVISION COULD ENDANGER
PUBLIC SAFETY. NUMEROUS
SITUATIONS EXCEPT FOR
INFORMATION INDIVIDUAL
CONVICTED OF A CRIME CAN BE A
VIOLENT. COURT COURT USED TO
THE- I PROTECT THEM. OF ALL OF
THAT. SOME OF THESE. WHERE A
CONNECTION CURRENT CURRENT NET
NEUTRALITY. AND BACKGROUND
CHECK LIKE MR MORE STAD-
EVALUATED PRINT AND DIVORCE
CASE VALUE WITHIN COURT HOLDER
AND MARK AT AND BUSINESS
PARTNERS. LOOKING BE RELATIVES
FOR PROBATE MISTY AIR. THIRTY
EVALUATING VIOLENCE AND
INVOLVING ORDER AND I IN
INDIVIDUAL AND RUN RELATIONS.
THE TERM WHETHER COME WOULD BE
A RISK WHEN APPLE WITH
CONVICTED OF FRAUD AGAIN AS MR
MORE SAID THEY APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL POSITION. DETERMINING
WHETHER EMPLOYEES WOULD BE A
RISK WHEN AN APPLICANT HAS BEEN.
CONVICTED OF FELONY ASSAULT.
INDETERMINATES FINALLY WHEN
COMMUNITY WOULD BE AT RISK
TWENTY BILLION EMPIRE
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYMENT APPLICANT.
SO FOR THESE REASONS AND
ACTUALLY MANY OTHERS KELLY A
COUPLE OF THOSE SB THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE AND I WE ARE BACK TO
SENATOR PER DEVICE SO REGARDING
THE QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEY WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL CRIMINAL
RECORDS. AS THE PROSECUTION AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU
THINK. THANK YOU. NOW LET'S
MOVE TO OUR WITNESSES IN THE
ROOMS ARE THERE WITNESSES HERE
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY HI IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NINE HERE TWENTY FORTY I SEE
ONE THERE ARE NO ONE THERE
EITHER EITHER NOW MR MODERATOR.
LET'S MOVE TO THE PHONE ONLINE.
THANK YOU MAKE AMERICAN ENERGY.
AND THE SEVEN THREE ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO RECOMMEND AGAIN
ONE. ZERO AND WE DO HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER.
THE END LINE EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN.
W. SELLERS ON THE OWNER
OPERATOR OF THE SELLER'S
INVESTIGATIVE GROUP OF PRIVATE
INVESTIGATIONS FIRM OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. AN ALLIANCE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE OF MY KIDS
UP. I AM HOWARD DRATCH OF AN
OLD BERKELEY RADICAL BUT NOW
I'M LOS ANGELES GOVERNOR OF THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBER
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE INVESTIGATORS AND THIS
BILL IS WELL INTENTIONED BUT
IT'S STRONG WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING VITAL ROLE
PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS PLAY.
ENOUGH DID YOU SHIP JUDICIAL
SYSTEM SO I ENCOURAGE- RIGHT
NOW IT'S TOO BROAD ACCORDING TO
VOTE NO UNLESS THE BILL IS
FIXED NO ONE SAYS. SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. BLIGHTED
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME IS
SHERRY SELLERS WITH THE SELLERS
AND ASSOCIATES I'M A BUSINESS
OWNER AND OPPOSED. TO SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
TWELVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI
THIS IS A VALLEY INVALID-
CALIFORNIA LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR HE ADDED THAT IF
THERE IS THE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION BY BEGINNERS AND A
BUSINESS OWNER- I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED U. S. B. SEVEN THIRTY
ONE. BLINDED EIGHT HUNDRED TWO
YOUR MY KIDS UP AND. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROBERT
BERESFORD I AM A RETIRED DEPUTY
SHERIFF AND A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED INVESTIGATORS. I'M
CALLING IN TO EXPRESS MY
OPPOSITION SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE.
BECAUSE AS IT IS WRITTEN IT IS
TOO BROAD I TO BELIEVE IN
GIVING. PERSONS OF SECOND
CHANCE HOWEVER- THIS BILL NEEDS
TO BE ABOUT WHITTLED DOWN OR
NARROWED. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. BLIND SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOUR MY KIDS
OPEN. THE LADY TECHSTERS. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YOU CAN HEAR. I'M
SORRY HELLO MY NAME IS CARLOS
ABOUT THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATIONS FIRM HERE IN LOS
ANGELES I TOTALLY TOTALLY
OPPOSED ON AT SEVEN THIRTY ONE
TO THE FLAG THE WEEDS WRITTEN
IS. VERY BROAD AND IT WORKS
GREAT FOR FIRST OFFENDERS WELL
WHEN YOU HAVE MORE THAN THE
FIRST DEFENDANT ATTENDANCE. YOU
WILL WE'RE GONNA NEED TO. AND
THE SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND
BUSINESS HIS NUMBER ONE. THANK
YOU. BLIND SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS ROBERT JACKSON A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I'M OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTY ONE. AND MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT. YEAH
SHE CHECKED ON THIS ONE MORE
TIME TO SUIT OR ANY WITNESSES
STILL WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SAYS SB SEVEN THREE
ONE. SURE FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. SEVEN THREE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU SOME STANDING
THERE'S NO ONE I'D LOVE TO
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FROM
THE COMMITTEE AS IT RELATES TO
HAS THREE SEVENTY ONE THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR.
WIENER THE QUESTIONS WE HAVE
SENATOR CHOI BOGUE WITH A
QUESTION. HELLO THANK YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- I CAN A CURIOUS-
BEFORE YOU MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ONES BUT I HAD NOT THOUGHT
ABOUT THE CONCERN THAT THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER JUST HAD WITH
REGARDS TO THE MULTIPLE
OFFENSES- IN TAKING THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND- IN IN
GETTING RD OF EVERYBODY'S
PASSED- AS SOMEONE WHO
PERSONALLY KNOWS- PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPRISONED AND HAVE-
YOU KNOW. COME BACK AND DONE
REALLY WELL- WITH THEIR LIFE
INCLUDING A PASTOR BRIAN WHO'S
CURRENTLY A CITY COUNCIL IN IN
SCIENCE CENTER. I AM AND
SOMEONE WHO HAS ALSO VISITED A
WOMEN'S SHELTER WHO- WHOSE
FOCUS IN MY IN MY DISTRICT IS
TO YOU WE REUNITE WOMEN WHO
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AND GIVING THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY THIS GUILT AND
EVERYTHING TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THERE. I VERY MUCH RESPECT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORTH. BUT I
DO HAVE A CONCERN WITH REGARDS
TO- THE ABILITY TO HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT- TO CONSIDER WHETHER
OR THE OFFENSE IS RELEVANT TO
THE JOB. OFFENSE TOP TIME THAT
HAS PASSED WHEN IT COMES TO-
EMPLOYMENT- IN IN IN THAT
SECOND CHANCE. IS THERE ANY
POSSIBLE WAY THAT YOU COULD.
PERHAPS WORK THAT INTO THIS
BILL OR IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
YOU MAY CONSIDER I SHOULD
PROBABLY ASK FIRST IF IT'S
SOMETHINGTHAT YOU MAY
CONSIDER. THESE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE- WHAT THE
PAST OFFENSES ARE- AND IN
SAFETY MOVING FORWARD-AND I'M
TRYING TO THINK OF AN EXAMPLE
PERHAPS- AS SOMEONE WHO HAD.
MOLESTED CHILDREN FOR INSTANCE
AND TO THE REALITY TO YOU KNOW
APPLY FOR A JOB WITH ANYTHING
THAT RELATES TO CHILDREN WOULD
BE SOMETHING OF A CONCERN FOR
ME- OR- THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE
THAT'S COMING UP THE TOP OF MY
HEAD BUT- THOSE TYPE OF
SCENARIOS ARE WHAT CONCERNS ME
THAT WE DON'T ADDRESS- I DON'T
SEE. ANY SEE IT ANYWAY- BEING
ADDRESSED IN THE BILL AND IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU MAY
CONSIDER WORKING IN WITH WITHIN
THE SPELL. WELL MAYBE I COULD
START WITH THE- HI MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU GRANT- SENATOR- WITH
REGARDS TO THE VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTION AS FAR AS THE SIX-
CRIMES. ANYONE CURRENTLY ON THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY IS
INELIGIBLE FOR RELIEF SO JUST
USING THAT AS AN EXAMPLE ARE
YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE A NEW
FELONY CONVICTION IF YOU'RE
SERVING TIME FOR CURRENT
OFFENSE IF YOU'RE SERVING TIME
ON PROBATION OR PAROLE P. OF A
PENDING CHARGE. YOUR INELIGIBLE
SO- OUR OUR WHOLE. GOAL HERE.
IS TO GIVE TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
AFTER THEY'VE- SERVED THEIR
SENTENCE AFTER THEY'VE-
COMPLETED WHAT- SINCE THEY BEEN
GIVEN FOR THEIR PARTICULAR
CRIME THAT THEY DEVELOP THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SAY.
MY RECORD DOESN'T DEFINE WHO I
AM AS A HUMAN BEING WHO I AM AS
A PERSON. AND SO WE REALLY WANT
THAT TO AT SOME POINT HAS TO
MAKE A CUT. FROM THE PAST AND
ALLOW THAT INDIVIDUAL TO KEEP
MOVING FORWARD AND THAT'S THE
WHOLE GOAL HERE WE UNDERSTAND
THERE'S SOME CIRCUMSTANCES AS
WE JUST LISTED. WHICH WOULD BE
YOU KNOW L. MAKE THE PERSON
INELIGIBLE BUT THE WHOLE POINT
IS NOT TO ALLOW THAT PASSED
RECORD TO KEEP. HUNTING THAT
MIGHT KEEP COMING UP AND KEEP
UP PUSHING THEM AND IN THE OUT
YOU KNOW OUTSKIRTS OF OUR OF
OUR COMMUNITY- SO I. WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO KEEP PEOPLE- TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM MOVING FORWARD
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A WAY FOR
THEM TO GET OUT SHED THAT AND
MOVE FORWARD SO I DON'T- I
DON'T SEE WHY. I DON'T SEE
MYSELF RIGHT NOW MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION THAT YOU JUST SAID
ABOUT EXCLUDING PEOPLE WITH
MULTIPLE. THREE MILLION PEOPLE
WHO HAVE YOU KNOW SOMETHING ON
THEIR ON THEIR RECORD THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
I IN A OFFICE SYMPATHIZE WITH
THAT I DO ALSO. AS SENATOR FROM
ORDER POINTED OUT EARLIER IN A
IN A PREVIOUS BILL DO YOU
BELIEVE IN IN IN THE IN IN IN
PEOPLE AND IN THE GOOD WELL. I
KNOW THERE'S THERE WILL ALWAYS
BE PEOPLE THAT ARE NEFARIOUS
AND WON'T BE ABLE TO LOOK PAST
THAT BUT AS SOMEONE WHO.
PERSONALLY HAD A FAMILY MEMBER
WHO HAS EMPLOYED PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SERVED TIME BECAUSE HE
BELIEVES THAT EVERYONE DESERVES
A SECOND CHANCE. I AM CONCERNED
THOUGH THAT. PEOPLE WITH THE IN
CERTAIN. CRIME CATEGORIES-
APPLY TO CERTAIN JOBS THAT KIND
OF REFLECTOR UNDER ARE ARE
WHAT'S THE WORD I'M LOOKING FOR.
THAT COVER FOR- GIVE ME ONE
SECOND LET ME SEE IF I CAN
ARTICULATE THIS A LITTLE BETTER.
WHOSE CRIME. HIS CRIME-
AFFECTED OR REFLECTED EIGHT JOB
THAT THEY'RE PURSUING- SO AND
ACCOUNT FOR INSTANCE AND- IN
THIS IS PROBABLY A TERRIBLE
EXAMPLE BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT
IS THEIR LIVELIHOOD THAT IS OUR
SKILL SET BUT IF THEY ACTED IN
IT AND NOTHING UNETHICAL WAY
WHERE THEY HAVE TO SERVE TIME
AND THEY WERE TRYING TO RE
APPLY I GUESS YOU COULD ALWAYS
GO. INDEPENDENT ON THAT END BUT-
IF I CAN MAKE THAT JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE AS IS THAT BEING- KIND
OF A- YOU KNOW AS AN EMPLOYER I
WOULD HAVE YOU KNOW NOT FOR ME
PERSONALLY BUT FOR SOME MIGHT
HAVE HESITANCY AND HIRING
SOMEONE IT OF THAT OF THAT
BACKGROUND- IS THERE ANY SAFETY
GUARDS OR ANY- I GUESS SAFETY
GUARDS ARE SURE IS THAT WE
COULD GIVE THE PUBLIC. TO BE
MORE ACCEPTABLE OF. HIRING
SOMEONE THAT HAS HAD PRIOR
CONVICTIONS IN IN THEIR FIELD.
WELL AGAIN THE WHOLE POINT IS
TO HELP PEOPLE SHED THAT RECORD
FROM THERE SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T
HAVE A RECORD. COULD ALSO
COMMIT THAT CRIME. SO IT OUR
POINT IS HERE IS THAT LET'S
TREAT THEM. SINCE THEY MET
THEIR A GOOD CUPPA COMPLETED
THEIR SENTENCE THEY'VE GONE TWO
YEARS WITHOUT COMMITTING
ANOTHER CRIME THAT LET THEM NOW
MOVES FORWARD INSTEAD OF
HOLDING THEM BACK- SOMEBODY WHO
DOESN'T HAS NOT COMMITTED A
CRIME IS JUST AS ABLE TO COMMIT
A CRIME LIKE A BEZEL MEANT AS
AND S. WE WANT TO YOU'D TREAT
PEOPLE. AS EQUALS WHEN THEY
COME FORWARD AND SAY I'VE DEALT
WITH MY PAST I WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD. GIVE ME A JOB. I'M
GONNA WORK HARD FOR IT I TOOK
CLASSES I'M PREPARED. ALL THAT
IS IN PLACE SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. DO YOU
THINK THAT PERHAPS PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE AND VALIDATE THEIR
PAST AS WELL AS WHEN YOU'RE
HIRING HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT THE REASON I'M ASKING
IN THE CONTEXT IN WHICH I'M AT
STATING MAKING THAT STATEMENT
IS. PEOPLE LIKE MY FAMILY
MEMBER WHO HAS HIRED AT PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN OUT WHO HAVE SERVED
TIME I'M THINKING OF A PASTOR
BRIAN FROM SCIENCE CENTER WHO
HAS SERVED TIME IN OPENLY
DISCUSSES- YOU KNOW IT'S VERY
TRANSPARENT IN IN IN WHAT HE
HAS DONE AND YET HAS BEEN ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD. DO YOU DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS CURRENTLY-
CURRENTLY A REASON TO GIVE
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
TRANSPARENT AND ONLY AND IT
AND- IT AND VALIDATE I THINK
OUR LIFE EXPERIENCES MAKE US
WHO WE ARE AND GIVES THAT THAT
CHARACTER- DO YOU THINK THAT
THAT. BUT PEOPLE DON'T DESERVE
TO BE TRANSPARENT AND OWNING AB
ONE ON ONE SIDE WHAT THEY'VE
DONE IN THE PAST NUMBER TWO
HAVING THE ABILITY TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT I SEE YOU'VE DONE
THIS BUT I SEE THAT YOU'VE DONE
ALL OF THIS EXTRA WORK TO
BETTER YOURSELF AND MOVE
FORWARD IN YOUR LIFE SO MANY
GIVE ME THAT SHOT. I THINK THE
PROBLEM IS THAT. FAR MORE
PEOPLE HAVE USE IT AGAINST THEM
THEN THEY HAVE. USED IT AS A
WAY OF HELPING THAT PERSON MOVE
FORWARD. AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM
IS THAT THERE'S BEEN FAR TOO
MUCH DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE OF THEIR
RECORD. BECAUSE OF THE STIGMA.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING THAT GOES
ALONG WITH IT WE DEHUMANIZE-
FOREVER THEY HAVE THIS THIS
LABEL ON THEM. SO WHAT WE WANNA
DO IS. ALLOW THEM TO MOVE
FORWARD THAT'S THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU CENTER DATACENTER. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS THE COMMITTEE MEMBER
SENATOR CALM WATER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR. I'M I. I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT I THINK ARM.
I OFTENTIMES A CHALLENGE WITH A
LOT OF THE BILLS THAT ARE
BROUGHT BEFORE US IS THAT. WE
ARE ASKING PEOPLE TO- ACT IN
HINDSIGHT OFTENTIMES WE ARE
ASKING PEOPLE TO BE PERFECT-
AND WE ARE HOLDING FOLKS WHO
HAVE CRIMINAL RECORDS OR WHO
HAVE MADE BAD DECISIONS TO A
HIGHER STANDARD- IN OFTENTIMES
WE'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO. HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT- AND WE LEAVE NO SPACE
FOR THE FOLKS THE MILLIONS OF
FOLKS WERE OUT THERE YOU KNOW
COMMITTING CRIMES ARE DOING BAD
THINGS THAT JUST HAPPENED TO
NOT GET CAUGHT- AND AT THE END
OF THE DAY THEY PROBABLY ALL
DESERVE TO BE IN THE SAME
MARKET. YOU KNOW HOW ARE WE
WORKING TO. GIVE PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL
HOW ARE WE GIVING PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE AND HOW ARE
WE GIVING PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO NOT BE DEFINED. BY PAST
EXPERIENCES OR CIRCUMSTANCES I
AM SURE THAT SO MANY OF US IF
WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BACK IN TIME. WE WOULD HAVE
MADE A DIFFERENT DECISION ABOUT
A PARTNER ABOUT A JOB. ABOUT
SOMETHING WE SAID ABOUT HOW WE
TREATED SOMEONE. AND BUT WE'RE
NOT REALLY AFFORDED THAT- BUT
WE DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE AS
IT RELATES TO EMPLOYMENT. AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. AND
WHEN WE CONTINUE TO SHUT THOSE
DOORS. WE ACTUALLY FINAL PEOPLE
BACK INTO A RE AND CARCERAL-
PIPELINE. AND WE CREATE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO. ON RAVEL HERE ON THIS VERY
COMMITTEE- AND I ALSO THINK WE
HAVE TO HAVE DEEPER DISCUSSIONS
WITH OURSELVES ABOUT HOW MUCH
WE WANT TO KNOW ABOUT SOMEONE-
AND THERE'S A FINE LINE BETWEEN
GROSS INTRUSIVENESS. AND REALLY
FINDING OUT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT SOMEONE IN
ORDER TO EMPLOY THEM. AND WHEN
TOO MUCH IS JUST TOO MUCH- I
THINK THERE ARE PROBABLY A TON
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE PRO REALLY
GOOD C. P. A.'S OR ACCOUNTANTS
OR SOCIAL WORKERS. WHO MIGHT
HAVE DONE SOMETHING BAD EVEN IN
THAT SAME. YOU KNOW FIELD OF
WORK. AND IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THEY'RE A BAD PERSON IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THEY DESERVE THEY
SHOULDN'T GET A SECOND CHANCE-
AND IF THEY ARE REALLY
EGREGIOUS AND CHANCES ARE THEY
WILL DO SOMETHING BAD AGAIN-
AND THEY WILL HAVE TO ACCOUNT
FOR THAT SO. I REALLY APPLAUD
YOU FOR ASKING US TO BE BETTER
NEIGHBORS TO OUR NEIGHBORS- IN
MEETING PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE
AND GIVING THEM A SECOND CHANCE
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I TO SENATOR WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS- MEASURE
HERE IT'S A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE ON ONE I SIMPLY. IF WHO
HAS. DAUNTED CRIME PAID THEIR
DUES TO SOCIETY SHOULDN'T BE
BRANDED WITH A SCARLET LETTER
THE REST YOUR LIFE HOW THEY
SHOULD BE- AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO MOVE FORWARD
GAIN HOUSING- GAIN EDUCATION
AND MANY TIMES THOSE. RIVAS
CONVICTIONS OF PREVENT THAT AND
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR THIS I DID
EXPUNGEMENT RECORD A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS IN
ASSEMBLY- BUT THE TRUTH OF THE
MATTER IS WITH THE INTERNET AND
ALL THAT WE KNOW NOTHING'S EVER.
EVER GONE REAL SO THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ONE'S PAST COMING
BACK TO HAUNT HIM WILL HAPPEN
IF ONE TRULY WANTS TO LOOK FAR
ENOUGH THIS JUST PUTS A
FIREWALL. AND ALLOW THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO MOVE FOR WITH
THEIR LIFE- NO LONGER HAVING
NECESSARY TO CHECK THE BOX THE
AGAIN THEY STILL HAVE TO ADMIT
THAT THE BEING CONVICTED BUT
THE RECORD IS SEALED TO THE
POINT OF. NOT HAVING GREAT
ACCESS BUT AS WE ALL KNOW
THROUGH THE INTERNET NOTHING
HAS EVER GONE AWAY AS WE'VE
SEEN IN SO MANY WAYS OF. COMING
BACK WHO HAVE NOT COMMITTED
CRIMINAL OFFENSES TO HAVE THEIR
PAST BROUGHT UP BY SOMETHING
THAT HE DID. YOU KNOW- VIA THE
INTERNET- FIFTEEN YEARS AGO SO
ON THAT NOTE- WE HAVE A MOTION
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE EVERY
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR COM
LONGER. WELL THE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON SB
SEVEN THREE ONE. SB SEVEN THREE
ONE DURAZO DO PASS AS AMENDED.
NEW PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD ART
PROVIDE A TRUE BOGUE NO
TROUBLED NO COM LOGGER.
KAMLAGER EYES SKINNER AND
WIENER. WIENER AYE. THE MEASURE
HAS THREE VOTES YOU WILL PUT IT
ON HOLDS THREE ONE AND- THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND NOW WE HAVE
MISTER JONES FEES RUDY WILL
TAKE- S. B. FIVE THREE EIGHT.
THERE. VERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE ON THE TIMING OF THE
PRESENTATION AS WELL AS- THE
UNIVERSE CONSPIRED AGAINST ME
TO HAVE BOTH MY BILLS IN
JUDICIARY AND A- PUBLIC SAFETY
HURT AT THE SAME TIME SO
APPRECIATE YOU ARE. COMMITTING
THAT- FIRST I'D LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING ON THIS BILLS HAVE
BEEN THE- ALMOST A TWO YEAR-
EXPERIENCE AND WE'VE HAD GREAT
CONVERSATIONS. I THINK WE'VE
GONE TO GREAT POINT ON THIS
ISSUE. ESPECIALLY WITH THE NEW
AMENDMENTS TO THEBILL THAT I
AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT AND PROMOTE.
SO SENATE SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY EIGHT WITH THE CAME A
MINUTE WITH THE COMMITTEE ADMIN
METS MODERNIZES THE DEFINITION
OF MAIL. AND PROTECTS ALL FORMS
OF MAIL THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
DELIVERY PROCESS. CURRENTLY THE
DEFINITION MALE ONLY PROTECTS
USPS MAIL. THIS DEFINITION
SIMPLY OUTDATED. TODAY WE HAVE
MANY MAIL CARRIER OPTIONS AND
MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF MALE
RANGING FROM POSTCARDS TO LARGE
ENVELOPES AND PACKAGES. ALL THE
SHOULD BE AWARDED THE SAME
THEFT PROTECTION AS U. S. P. S.
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE
MAIL. BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT
CARVE IT NINETEEN SITUATION
ONLINE SALES HAVE INCREASED
EXPONENTIALLY. IN FACT BETWEEN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR ONLINE SALES
INCREASED FORTY NINE PERCENT.
IN THE COUNTRY. WHILE SHOPPING
ONLINE CAN BE EASIER AND SAFER
UNFORTUNATELY THESE WITH MALAN
TENSIONS ARE INCREASINGLY
STEALING PACKAGES. THESE
THIEVES ARE OFTEN REFERRED TO
AS PORCH PIRATES. A
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
PORCH PIRACY OCCURS IN
CALIFORNIA IN 20001930% OF ALL
STOLEN PACKAGES ACROSS THE
NATION WERE STOLEN IN THIS
STATE. THESE PACKAGES CONTAIN A
WIDE VARIETY OF ESSENTIAL ITEMS
SUCH AS MEDICATIONS AND FOOD.
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS RELY ON PACKAGE
DELIVERY FOR SURVIVAL IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
WE MUST TAKE EVERY STEP TO STOP
PORCH PIRACY. THIS UPDATED
DEFINITION OF MAIL WILL HELP
COMBAT PORCH PIRACY BY
PROTECTING ALL TYPES OF MAIL
INCLUDING PACKAGES FROM ALL
TYPES OF MAIL CARRIERS- MADAM
CHAIR I BELIEVE. THAT I HAD
THANK YOU FOR THIS AND-
REQUESTED AYE VOTE FROM THE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES IN ONE SECOND. YOU DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD SUPPORT SO WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD TO-
LET'S BEGIN IT WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE AND ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. SCENE NINE. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE HAVE NONE-
LET'S SEE THANK YOU WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARSES MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS GOING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIVE EIGHT
WILL BEGIN. FOUR COMMENTS AND
SUPPORT. SB THREE FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
END OF LINE EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. KAREN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
NOT SURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA- NATION IN SUPPORT
OF THAT NOW AT. YEAH WE. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MATTER IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE M. CHECK A LINE
JUST ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WOODS IS FROM S. B. FOR SB
THREE FIVE EIGHT. SURE SORT
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE FIVE EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO. RECOMMEND ONE
MORE TIME. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT COMING
FOR- THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT OF THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION- WE I BELIEVE WE
HAVE- TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. SECRETARY LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON AND IGNACIO AT
NINE THIS DO WE HAVE LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON ON THE LINE.
LAST WEEK CALDWELL HOUSTON.
THANK YOU MR THE CALL WILL HE
SAID WOULD YOU MIND- PLEASE ADD
BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON I ACTUALLY THOUGHT MR
NONDOES NOT GOING TO GO FIRST-
BUT I WILL SAY THIS VERY
BRIEFLY- COMMITTEE SB THREE
FIVE EIGHT IS UNNECESSARY AND
BAD POLICY. ENTERING UNDER
SOMEONE'S PROPERTY WITH THE
INTENT TO STEAL OF PACKAGES
ALREADY CRIMINALIZED UNDER A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA
AND FEDERAL STATUTE- I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT AS THE
ACLU HAS RAISED. THAT IT CAN BE
USED IN A VERY DISCRIMINATORY
MANNER. I WOULD GIVE THE
EXAMPLE OF MY EXTREMELY DIVERSE
NEIGHBORHOODS I STILL SEE NEXT
DOOR HELLO- FOR THE FISHER.
QUOTE UNQUOTE BLACK MALE AND
THE LATINO MALES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND I AM VERY
CONCERNED MY AGE MY GROUP IS
VERY CONCERNED. THAT THIS COULD
BE. VERY BAD FOR THE LOWER
INCOME AND MINORITY COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD BE HIT THE HARDEST
WITH THIS MONTH THAT I WOULD
REQUEST A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS COVER HOUSTON-
MISTER NAZARIAN ON THIS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
MR NOT SO AND THEN THIS ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. WE DO NOT SHOW HIM
CONNECTED. OKAY SO WHILE WE
WAIT- FOR MISTER- AT NINE THIS
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO ONE THREE TWO
HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY THREE C. AND NOT- ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SB THREE FIVE EIGHT
SEEN NONE. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WILLING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARE VERSUS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN AN OP. I'M SORRY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE ARE NOT
POSITION OF SB THREE FIVE EIGHT
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. FOR COMMON IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. IN LINE
SEVEN HUNDRED ONE HERE MY COULD
OPEN. CORRECT ME ON BEHALF OF
AN ISSUE JUSTICE AND RESPECT
FOR OPPOSITION. BANDIT LINE
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CLAN BACCHUS GRAYSON YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION HELLO BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND MADAM
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT. MUINTIR IS
DEEP AND AVOIDS SILVA- FIVE SO
HAS MISTER HERNANDEZ- MADE
HIMSELF AVAILABLE YET. MISTER
HERNANDEZ IF YOU ARE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO
WE CAN IDENTIFY YOUR LINE. I DO
NOT SHOW THAT HE HAS CONNECTED.
DIAZ CONNECTED OKAY IT'S NOT HE
HAS NOT HELPED WE HAVE NOT COME
OKAY AND WE'VE TAKEN ALL OUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION VIA THE
TELEPHONE LINE. CORRECT YES
OKAY THEN WE'LL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO S. B. THREE FIVE
EIGHT. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU. NOW I KNOW THIS BILL IS
CHANGED. ARMS BUT WHAT I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT WOULD APPEAR.
THAT THE NEED TO AND ALSO KNOW
THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS CHRIS. IF I
UNDERSTAND ANALYSIS RATE SORRY
IT WOULD APPEAR THAT. WE NEED
TO MAKE THIS MODIFICATION
BECAUSE- THE WILD CURRENT LAW
COVERS THE THEFT OF US PS
DELIVERY IT DOES NOT. THE
PRIVATE SECTOR DELIVERY SUSPECT
CORRECT THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING-
I'M OF COURSE ALWAYS HESITANT
TO. EITHER EXPAND STATUTES OR
ADD BUBBLERS AND SUCH BUT IF
THERE. IS IN FACT THE. IT IS
TRUE THAT WHENEVER WE DID I
IMAGINE WHENEVER WE DID THE
INITIAL STATUTES THERE MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN. AS MUCH AS PRIVATE
SECTOR TYPE DELIVERY SUCH AS
AMAZON FEDEX AND SUCH- BUT I
WOULD APPRECIATE I SUPPOSE
KNOWING EITHER FROM THE TERROR
FROM THE FROM THE BEAUTY
CONSULTANT JUST THE- WHETHER
THIS IS DUPLICATIVE OF CURRENT
LAW. OR WHETHER WE ARE
ADDRESSING- SOMETHING THAT IS-
WOULDN'T WE MIGHT CALL
AMBIGUOUS IN CURRENT LAW. IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WHAT
CURRENTLY IS ON THE BOOKS AS IT
RELATES TO US. POSTAL SERVICE-
THAT THAT WORKERS ALREADY ON
THE BOARD BOOKS ENERGY STATED
IT JUST EXPANDS IT TO COVER.
THOSE YOU KNOW PRIVATE.
DELIVERIES LIKE UPS- FEDEX
FEDERAL EXPRESS AMAZON THINGS
OF THAT NATURE BECAUSE AGAIN.
UNDER YEARS AGO. ALONG WITH OUR
TRADITIONAL MALE STARTED THERE
WAS NO ADDITIONAL COMPETITION I
MIGHT WRITE MISS COMMITTEE AND
MY DESCRIPTION OF THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING OKAY YES. SO I
DON'T SEE IT AS AN EXPANSION OF.
A CRIME SO TO SPEAK JUST. WHERE
FORGET IS WHAT THE- WHAT THE OF
A MALE AND ALLOW YEAH YES. OKAY
YOU YOU NEED ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MATTER. NOW
HURRY WALLS I TO HEAD CONCERNS
AS IT RELATES TO. THIS IN ITS
INITIAL FORM BECAUSE I TO AS A
CENTER SKINNER STATED R. M.
ALWAYS LEERY OF EXPANDING. OR
ARE CREATING NEW CRIMES AND
THAT'S TRUE SOMETIMES- TARGETED
WHO THEY'RE TRYING TO GET AT
AND CAN CAST A MUCH WIDER
BLANKET IN ARNETT I SHOULD SAY
THAN SHOULD. BUT I THINK THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE IN
LIGHT OF. THE FACT THAT MOST OF
THE SERVICES NOW IF DROPPED
WHAT THE US POSTAL SERVICE ONLY
ONCE DID I MEA. I AM BLOWN
AWAY ANY TIME AT OUR HOME THE
NUMBER. AMAZON OR FEDEX OR
VARIOUS EARS ARE ON THE STREET
EVERY DAY DELIVERING WHAT WAS
ONCE TRADITIONAL MALE SILVA ARE
AND THAT IS REALLY WHAT A LOT
OF THESE ARE TARGETING NOW IS
THOSE PACKAGES THAT ARE
DELIVERED- VIA THE- THAT.
SYSTEM OR SERVICE I SHOULD SAY
SO- WITH THAT YOU KNOW I'VE WAS
WILLING TO. MOVE FOR WITH THIS
AND I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
ARE WILLING TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE WEREN'T. EXPANDING
CRIMES ARE CREATING WOBBLIES
WHERE THEY DIDN'T EXIST SO.
THAT WAS THE CASE- I'M FINE
WITH THE MEASURE- WE'RE SEEKING
A MOTION- ON BEHALF OF. SB
THREE FIVE EIGHT. SENATOR
WIENER ALL OF THE BILL AND I'M
I ALSO- I HAD SERIOUS CONCERNS
WITHOUT WAS DRAFTED BY- I AGREE
WITH THE CHAIR THAT I THINK
THIS- CREATES PARITY THAT WOULD
NOT. FOR SCHEME IN TERMS OF
THESE OTHER SERVICES- WHEN THE
PENAL CODE WAS DRAFTED SO ALL
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. WE HAVE
A MOTION- IT'S DO PASS PASS
AMENDED THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED
THOSE AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON SB
THREE FIVE EIGHT. RIGHT MAY
MAKE ALL I'M SORRY YOU MAY
CLOSE I'M SORRY I'M. SOARER
ACCEPTED LATE LAST WEEK WE DID
ATTEMPT TO. REACH OUT TO ALL
THE PREVIOUS OPPOSITION TO THE
PREVIOUS ITERATION OF THE BILL
SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THE
CALLER'S CONCERNS THAT LANGUAGE
IT IS WHAT HAS BEEN RECENT MOVE
THE INTENT. AND THE- INJURING
THE CARTILAGE- WE REMOVED ALL
THAT IN RESPONSE TO A CENTER
SKINNER AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES RE. CONCERNS
ABOUT EXPANDING- CRIMES AGAIN
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
JUST TO EXPAND THE DEFINITION
WHAT IS MALE NOT WHAT THE CRIME
IS. ARE NOT MORE CRIMES SO-
THANK YOUS MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION. IN APPRECIATE I'VE A-
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON S. B. THREE FIVE
EIGHT SB THREE FIVE EIGHT TWO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOTH I DROVE
A I CALM. CAMARGO NOT VOTING
SKINNER SKINNER AYE WINNER.
WIENER. FIVE FOUR ZERO. USE OF
ZERO THANK YOU. NATURALLY YOU
HAVE SENATOR BACK WORKS AS
SEVEN SEVEN FAR. YOU KNOW. FOR
SENATOR WIENER AYE MEANS BECKER
SURE. THANK YOU ARE YOU HAVE TO
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER. HAVE BEEN
YOUR FAMILIAR R. K. COMMON
CALIFORNIA FILL MURDER WAS
PEOPLE TO ANYONE WHO'S INVOLVED
A CRIME THAT RESULTED IN DEATH.
BUT SEVEN WHO DID NOT COMMIT
COULD BE CHARGED WITH THREE
MORE. AND THEN BE SENT FOR LIFE
WITHOUT. IT'S YOU KNOW TWENTY
TWO THE LEGISLATURE PAY. CENTER
SCANNERS AS FORTY THIRTY SO.
WHICH THIS. THOSE OVERLY PETER
TO THOSE DID NOT KILL OR INTENT
KILL. IT ALSO A LOT OF FOR
PEOPLE WHO A PLEA DEAL TO LESS
CHARGES. SUCH AS MAN. TO PAY
FOR RE. THREE REALLY PUT IN THE
HARD TO IMPROVE OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM. IN A LOT OF THE
HARDWARE WITH FOR THIRTY SEVEN.
SINCE FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
COURTS OF REASONS THAT FIVE
ONLY TO MURDER AND NOT
ATTEMPTED MURDER. THIS CALL
ACROSS THE BOARD PEOPLE FROM
ACROSS FOR REESE. THIS LED TO
AN ABSURD AND SAID WHERE PEOPLE
ARE OUT FOR FREE. IF THE VICTIM
DOES. BUT OUR IN HOUSE IF TO
NOT DIE. FURTHERMORE ALTHOUGH
FOURTEEN SEVEN A LOT OF PATHWAY.
WHO TOOK PLEADED TO CHARGE SUCH
AS- TO PLY FROM. THIS BILL TO
NOT A X. INCLUDE THOSE P. FOR
RESENTENCING. AS THIS LED TO.
WITH LEAST COUPLE PEOPLE. ARE
STILL SERVING TECH AND- EVEN
THOUGH THEY SHOULD BE A. FOR
THESE REASONS I BRING SB SO
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH CLEAR
EXISTING LAW. TO INCLUDE BONTA
MAN. AND ATTEMPTED CONVICT. AS
ELVES FOR RELEASE UNDER SB
FOURTEENTH SEVEN. THIS
PHARMACIST OF IN CAR PEOPLE
THAT THE PUBLIC DEEM TO BE NEXT.
BY THE TECHNICAL LANGUAGE OF
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. AND THE
THOUSANDS OF SIMILAR PEOPLE WHO
DID NOT FILE PETITIONS YET
BECAUSE THE COURT RULINGS. WITH
ME TODAY FOR ANY ERA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. AJ CORRECTIONS
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE STATE
PUBLIC DEFENDER. THANK YOU- AND
I RESPECTFULLY URGE I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU WE'LL START WITH YOUR
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES EVER
JOINT FONG TIME OF FIVE MINUTES
SERVICE. YOUR LEAD ONE THIS.
SCRIPT SINCE. AB YOUR FIRST
PROGRAMMING OKAY HERE. THANK
YOU THIS IS A NEED GOOD EVENING
I AM A MEMBER OF THE CAL PUBLIC
DEFENDER OF SAID AS WELL AS A
LIFETIME PUBLIC DEFENDER- AS-
CENTER BACK THERE ARE YOU STATE.
YOU WHY PASS SENATOR SKINNER'S.
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SO AND BACK
INTO EIGHTEEN. TO REDUCE THE OF
P. NEED SO WHEN PRISON TERMS
THEY WERE NOT THE ACTUAL KILLER
DID NOT SHOW INTENT KILL.
UNFORTUNATELY SO TWENTY THE
COURTS SISTER INTO. FOR THIRTY
SEVEN THE LEAD OUT CALL P. SO
THE READ THAT WE NEED AS SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE. ISSUE AS SENATOR
BACKROOM. INCLUDE PEOPLE. HAD
LESSER INCLUDED OFFENSES LIKE
VOLUNTARY. AND LIKE WE PEOPLE
AT THE TIME MURDER TWO IN THOSE.
WHO SERVING LENGTHY. THAT THEY
IN HERE. OR PRIOR YOUR SOME
ELSE. AND THEY COULD BE DOING
DECADE. YOU THOUGH THEY WERE DE
LAST CULPABLE BY THE TO. WHO
SAID THEIR CASE. SO IF THIS. SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL COME WITH
STRONG LAYING. THAT A PERSON
HAS A RIGHT A FULL OF THE
PETITION. BUT THEY HAVE A TO
CAL POINT TO A THEM IN AS A NEW
HEARING WITH NO SHORT CUTS
ALLOWED THE COURTS. AND I THINK
WE WE'RE LOOKING AT IS IF YOU
SMALL. WHICH WILL LEAD TO
BANNER FOR K. NOT JUST THE
HUNDRED CHIU FILE PETITION IN
LAW IN THE- TO NEW. A HEARING
AND NOT THE DROUGHT BUT DID A-
BECAUSE OF THE RANGE FOR SO.
BUT ALL THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
TWENTY HELP CLEAN UP RECORD TO
HELP THEM THREE IN. DENTISTRY
AND THEIR. FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE ONE ALSO USED ARE NEEDED
RACIAL FOR. BECAUSE IN THE PAST
THE NATIONAL DEBT NOT PROBABLY
CONCEPT. AND FELONY MURDER
THEORY. WERE USED FOR. AGAINST
BLACK YOU. WHAT NEXT YEAR'S
ASIAN ARE. THEY WERE ALSO
DISHED. USED AGAINST WHEN. WHO
ARE WRAPPED IN THAT AT THEIR
LOVED ONE AND PROSECUTE. AND
PERHAPS SETTLED BUT WILL HAVE
BEEN IN KNOWLEDGE- UNDER THE
RULING. SB SEVEN FIVE WILL IN
AND OUR FUN FAIRNESS AND
CRIMINAL SAYS. HOUSE SO WORLD
IMPROVE EQUAL. DEEPER AND
SERRATION OF THESE. I AM ABLE
TO FILE FOR A PETITION TO BE
RESENTENCED MEANWHILE THOSE WHO
WERE BOWLED WENT TO TRIAL LAST
THEIR TRIALS PEOPLE HAVE NOW
BEEN RESENTENCED UNDER FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN AND BEEN RELEASED.
ALL CALIFORNIANS NOT JUST THOSE
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM WILL SEE BENEFITS TO
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. IN
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET SAVINGS IS
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR PER PERSON WHO WAS
RELEASED AND THAT'S THE NUMBER.
IT'S NOT A CRIMINAL DEFENSE
NUMBER THAT'S OF LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE NUMBER EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
TO INCARCERATED PERSON- BUT
ALSO THINK ABOUT THE LAST YEAR
WHERE. WE'VE HAD NEEDLESS
TRAGIC COBIT DEATHS IN CUSTODY
RIGHT WE'VE HAD A KOREAN CDC
OURS TRACKER. TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BEST OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN TWENTY TWO STAFF
MEMBER DEATHS FOR A TOTAL OF
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX LOST
LIVES THIS LAST YEAR DUE TO
COPE ED. IN OUR- YEAH COMMITTEE
TENSIONS VENDORS. SO ONE LAST
POINT I WOULD MAKE IS THAT I
KNOW CDA THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION HAS SOME
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BASED
UPON THE CONCERN THAT PEOPLE
WILL NOT BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
BOTH FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE MAKE SURE THAT%
SOMEONE DID ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR UNDERLYING CONTACT JUST
NOT THE OVER ARCHING MURDER
THAT SOMEONE ELSE COMMITTED-
AND SECONDARILY- I KNOW CBA'S
PERSPECTIVE IS THESE PEOPLE BUT
THE LESSER INCLUDED OFFENSES.
AREN'T FACING A LOT OF TIME
BECAUSE THEY'RE BASED TERM IS
YOU KNOW AT MOST ELEVEN YEARS
BUT THAT'S EXPLORING. AND HENCE
MINTS THAT CAN ADD TEN YEARS
TWENTY YEARS TO THESE INITIAL
BASED TERMS SO THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE. WHO ARE SERVING A
LOT OF TIME FOR THESE LESSER
OFFENSES HE DESERVES AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE RESENTENCED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO THE SECOND WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON- THIS IS AJ
CORRECTIONS I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
NON CAPITAL LITIGATION AT THE
OFFICE IN THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER- PROPITIOUS STATED
PURPOSE OF- SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH TO ENSURE THAT EACH
PERSON SHOULD BE PUNISHED FOR
HIS OR HER ACTIONS ACCORDING TO
HIS OR HER OWN LEVEL OF THE
INDIVIDUAL CULPABILITY. BUT AS
US SENATOR BAKER IMAGE HERE AND
HAVE ALREADY TOUCHED ON SOME
JUDICIAL INTERPRETATIONS HAVE
CREATED GAPS IN THE LAW LEADING
TO UNFAIR AND IS SENATOR
BACKERS SAID SOMETIMES TRULY
ABSURD RESULTS. SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE- DEALS WITH THREE OF THOSE.
WHARTON GAPS BUT FIRST. ONE
THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED
INCIDENTS ARE SOME COURTS ARE
EXCLUDING- FROM SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN ANYONE CONVICTED
OF ATTEMPTED MURDER WHICH MEANS
THAT A NON SHOOTER WHO CAN BE
LIABLE FOR WHO CAN'T BE LIABLE
FOR MURDER IF THE VICTIM IS
SHOT AND KILLED WILL FACE HARSH
PUNISHMENT IF THE SAME VICTIM
SURVIVES I HAVE A REAL LIFE
EXAMPLE. A PENDING CASE TWO
VERY YOUNG WOMEN AND A MAN WENT
OUT TO PAINT GRAFFITI WHEN
SOMEONE TRIED TO STOP ONE OF
THE WOMEN FROM TAGGING A
BUILDING THE MAN GOT OUT OF THE
CAR WITH A GUN AND SHOT TWO
PEOPLE ONE OF THOSE VICTIMS
DIED THE OTHER SURVIVED. THE
YOUNG WOMEN DIDN'T INTEND FOR
EITHER MAN TO BE SHOT OR KILLED
AND UNDER THE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THEY CAN
NO LONGER BE CONVICTED OF THE.
MURDER OF THE ONE WHO DIED. BUT
THE COURT. IT ADDS TO THE
VICTIMS SERVED. THE TWO WOMEN
WERE PROPERLY CONVICTED OF
ATTEMPTED MURDER AND THEY CAN
SPEND WHAT. SB ZERO POINT TWO.
CAME TRUE IN THIS CASE MAKING
SPEND DECADES IN PRISON AS A
RESULT- SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
CLARIFIES WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
OBVIOUS A DEFENDANT SHOULD NOT
BE IN A WORSE POSITION BECAUSE
THE SHOOTERS VICTIM SURVIVES-
SECONDLY. MANY MINOR
PARTICIPANTS IN CRIMES THAT
WENT BAD WE'RE ALLOWED TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO MANSLAUGHTER IN ORDER
TO AVOID BEING PROSECUTED FOR
MURDERS THEY DIDN'T COMMIT. IF
THEY PLAYED GUILTY TO MURDER
UNDER FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
EIGHT NOW BE ALLOWED TO FILE A
PETITION TO GET THAT CONVICTION
SET ASIDE BUT BECAUSE THEY
PLAYED TO THE LESSER CRIME OF
MANSLAUGHTER THEY CAN'T FILE A
PETITION AND THEY ARE PUNISHED
FOR THE KILLING. AND AS WAS
POINTED OUT THESE ARE OFTEN
BELIEVES CUTTING CULPABLE.
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE CASE.
THAT'S ANOTHER INJUSTICE- THE
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL REMEDY.
FINALLY- IT'S IN- IN DESIGNING-
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
SENATOR SKINNER MADE SURE THAT
PETITIONERS ALMOST ALL OF WHOM
ARE INDIGENT HAVE LEGAL
REPRESENTATION IN THESE CASES
THIS FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT IS
CRUCIAL BECAUSE THERE'S ALWAYS
A PROSECUTOR IN COURT OPPOSING
THEM AND OFTEN BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE ARE IN PRISON THEY
AREN'T EVEN IN COURT- IF
THERE'S NOBODY THERE TO SPEAK
FOR THEM. SOME COURTS HAVE MIS
READ THE STATUTE AND ALL BUT
ELIMINATED THE RIGHT TO
APPOINTED COUNSEL US SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL
CORRECT THAT SO- WE DO URGE YOU
TO PASS IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOW LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES AND
FORTY TWO OLD THREE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE I SEE NO
WITNESSES HERE IN THIS ROOM NOW
WILL MOVE OVER TO THE OVERFLOW
ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO
ONE DESIRING TO SPEAK THERE.
NOW MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES AND WE'RE LOOKING
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. ALL RIGHT
APPROACH TO SPEND ON THE PHONE
LINE TRIBUNE SUPPORTERS SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. PLEASE. OUR FIRST LINE IS
EIGHT SEVEN SIX PLEASE TAKE
YOUR NAME PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RESPONSIBLE MILLER SAYS TO THIS
AND ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
RESTORE JUSTICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL NOT A
GOOD LINE OF EIGHT EIGHT NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLAY CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND WITH THEIR PERMISSION FOR
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER
AND TO COURT THANK YOU. NOW
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT HAS A
MENTOR FOR SMART JEFF IF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
AND NOW THE LAN LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I RECOMMEND GOING BACK
AND FORTH ACLU'S CALIFORNIA
ACTION. ALL LINES YOU KNOW A
BIGGER CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK.
NUMBER EIGHT NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NO GOOD LINE SEVEN SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CARE NUMBERS ISN'T HAPPENING
LIKE YOU KNOW WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE NINE ZERO
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. COULD NOT
SEE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE COSPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER IS SIX FOUR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KATE TAPIOCA I WAS HONORED TO
WORK WITH UNDER SKINNER ON
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AND I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. RIGHT NOW
WE'LL GO TO LINE ITEM. EIGHT
NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS KERRY MOJICA A
CONCERNED CITIZEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MAILONLINE SIX SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
SIX SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS ALEX BUCKLEY-
ON BEHALF OF THE US PROSTITUTES
COLLECTIVE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. AND NOW WILL BE COULD
LINE EIGHT NINE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OR TINA BROWN I AM
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBERS FROM
AND ALL DAY AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. FINALLY HAVE HIS EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALLISON HUNTER
AND I AM A COMMUNITY MEMBER
WITH A LOVED ONE YEAH DOT AND I
SUPPORT TAX. SEVEN SEVEN FIVE.
THANK YOU THAT WAS THE LAST ONE
WE HAVE AN APPOINTMENT AT THIS
TIME. JUST THREE TO CHECK
LARGEST ONE MORE TIME BEFORE WE
MOVE ON. BUT SINCE WE DO HAVE
ONE WAY TO GET THE LINE NUMBER
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I AM LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NO WONDER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC OFFERED
FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THAT WAS THE LAST ONE WE
HAD WE CAN. THIS MODERATOR NOW
LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE
SHOW ONLY ONE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION OUT TO MR LAWRIE
MARSH MISTER MORRIS ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
AM SORT OF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS LEARN MORE
SOMEBODY UP AT THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. ONE SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WAS
APPROVED ITS STATED PURPOSE WAS
TO REDUCE LENGTHY SENTENCES
THAT WERE DISPROPORTIONATE TO
THE CULPABILITY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL. THE PUNISHMENT FOR
FIRST DEGREE MURDER IN THE
DEATHS IMPRISONMENT IN THE
STATE PRISON FOR LIFE WITHOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE OR
IMPRISONMENT IN STATE PRISON
FOR A TERM OF TWENTY FIVE YEARS
TO LIFE. THUNDERSTRUCK FOR
SECOND DEGREE MURDER SUSPECT
STATE PRISON TERM OF FIFTEEN
YEARS TO LIFE. THE CHANGES IN
COMPOSITION SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AND COROLLARY DECISIONS
FROM THE SUPREME COURT WERE
PREMISED ON THE IDEA THAT THE
SENTENCES WERE UNDULY HARSH FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO DID NOT
MANIFEST AN INTENT TO KILL.
HOWEVER THE SENTENCES IMPOSED
FOR THE CRIMES OF VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER AND ATTEMPTED
MURDER ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
SHORTER. THAN THE SENTENCES
IMPOSED FOR MURDER. THE
VOLUNTARY MAN. IS IMPRISONMENT
FOR THREE SIX OR ELEVEN YEARS
THE PUNISHMENT FOR ATTEMPTED
MURDER IS IMPRISONMENT FOR FIVE
SEVEN OR NINE YEARS IF THE JURY
FINDS A PREMEDITATION
ALLEGATION TO BE TRUE WHICH
DEMONSTRATES AN INTENT TO KILL
AND FALLS OUTSIDE OF BOTH
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND THIS
BILL. THEN THE PUNISHMENT IS
LIFE WITH THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE AFTER SEVEN YEARS. L. AS
A DRAMATIC DEPARTURE FROM THE
IDEA OF DISPROPORTION ALLEN THE-THAT WAS THE BASIS OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. NOT ONE
STATE OR FEDERAL COURT HAS EVER
HELD THAT THE SENTENCES IMPOSED
FOR VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER
ATTEMPTED MURDER OR
PREMEDITATED ATTEMPTED MURDER
ARE QUOTE NOT COMMENSURATE WITH
THE CULPABILITY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AND QUOTE. MOREOVER
NOTHING IN THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN INDICATED THAT THE
SENTENCES FOR THE CRIMES
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER OR
ATTEMPTED MURDER OR NOT
COMMENSURATE WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CULPABILITY FOR
THE CRIME. ARE WE SAYING THAT
THE EXISTING SENTENCING TRIADS
FOR VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER AND
ATTEMPTED MURDER ARE TOO HARSH
IMBUE THE ACTIONS OF THE
DEFENDANT WHAT THEN IS THE
PROPER PUNISHMENT FOR PEOPLE
GOING TEND TO KILL. ANY
ENHANCEMENTS OR PERSONAL IN
THAT THEY CANNOT BE ADDED ON
EITHERA FELONY MURDER RULE
THEORY OR A NATURAL ONE PROBLEM
CONSEQUENCES THERE. IN ADDITION
TO THE SUBSTANTIVE OBJECTIONS
TO THIS BILL THERE ARE
LOGISTICAL ISSUES IN THIS BILL
SIMILAR TO THOSE IN SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS STILL THE
SUBJECT OF EXTENSIVE LITIGATION.
USUALLY THE APPLICATION OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE TWO
CONVICTIONS THAT RESULTED FROM
NEGOTIATED PLEASE THAT CONTAIN
NO ADMISSIBLE RECORD OF
CONVICTION FOR AN EVIDENTIARY
HEARING IS PROBLEMATIC TO SAY
THE LEAST. ADDITIONALLY THE
REAL LIFE AFFECTED THE NUMBER
OF THE PROCEDURAL PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL WOULD BE TO ALLOW
EVERYONE CONVICTED OF
MANSLAUGHTER OR ATTEMPTED
MURDER TO SUCCESSFULLY
PETITIONED TO HAVE A
RESENTENCING HEARING REGARDLESS
OF THE UNDERLYING THEORY
ADVANCED BY THE PROSECUTION
COUPLED WITH THE BURDEN ON THE
PROSECUTION TO PROVE BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT THE
PETITIONERS IN ELIGIBILITY FOR
RESENTENCING SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE WILL EFFECTIVELY
AUTHORIZED THE RELEASE OF THOSE
WHO ATTEMPTED TO KILL AND THOSE
WHO PLAYED MAJOR ROLES IN THE
KILLING OF OTHERS. WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO FINDING REASONABLE
AND MEASURED APPROACHES TO
FELONY MURDER REPORT HOWEVER
THIS BILL FALLS FAR SHORT OF
THAT GOAL AND CREATE SOME
POTENTIALLY DISASTROUS AND
COSTLY PROBLEMS THAT RENDER
THIS BILL ON WORKABLE IF
APPROVED IT WOULD CREATE
NOTHING SHORT OF A WINDFALL FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ENGAGED IN
CONCERTED EFFORTS TO TAKE A
HUMAN LIFE AND WHO HAVE BEEN
JUSTLY AND APPROPRIATELY
PUNISHED US. FOR A NO VOTE.
THANKS SIR. THANK YOU. NOW
LET'S MOVE BACK TO FORTY TWO HE
WILL HEAR IN THE CHAMBER HERE I
SEE NO WITNESSES ARE. AND
SOPRON IN OPPOSITION WILLING
TO- WANTING TO TESTIFY WILL
MOVE NOW TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NO WITNESSES THERE. SOON
NOW MISS A MODERATOR WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN Q. WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. I WANTED TO
WISH MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION IT'S ONE AND ZERO.
ONE IN Q. WILL TAKE THAT LINE
NOW. MY NUMBER NINE ZERO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I APOLOGIZE
I AM AT THE LONG PART BECAUSE I
DIDN'T NOT OPPOSE THIS I AM
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT- WE GOT
CUT OFF BEFORE I COULD PUSH THE
BUTTON BUT I AM CRISTINA HE
ROBIN PLAN ON WITH ALL OF US
AND THEM SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AND
I WOULD PREVENT COMMUNITIES
.ORG. AND I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY I AM IN THE COURT. OF
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY
LIKE TO WE HAVE IN OPPOSITE TO
WISHING TO TRANSFER TO SUPPORT.
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN A POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO TWO
TIME. AND I'M SHOWING NO LINES
IN OPPOSITION I'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR AN OPERATOR ALLUDED TO GIVE
TESTIMONY THANK YOU APPRECIATE
IT WE'RE GOING TO BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO THIS
MEASURE SENATOR WINNER. SOONER
WHEN WE HAVE A MOTION ABOUT FOR
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO THIS
NO QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR BAKER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I THINK RECONSIDERATION
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ARE WE HAVE A MOTION TO DO
FAST TO BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE BRADFORD HI I
PROVIDE A CHOI BOGUE NOW. TO
ABOVE NO COM LONGER. COMMA ICE.
WE WIENER II THREE VOTES DAVID.
THREE ONE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NOW WE
WILL MOVE TO NOW THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER. OUR MOVE TO FILE
ITEM T. AND S. B. THREE FIVE
SEVEN. SENATOR WIENER FROM YOUR
DUSTER FROM THE PODIUM WHATEVER
YOU WHATEVER YOUR PLEASURE OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND.
YEAH WHEN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
AND COLLEAGUES- I'M PRESENTING
SENATE BILL THREE FIVE SEVEN-
WHICH REPEALS PROVISIONS AND
OUR PENAL CODE THAT CRIMINALISE
LOITERING WITH INTENT TO ENGAGE
IN SEX WORK RELATED OFFENSES.
SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN ALSO
PERMITS THE SEALING OF RECORDS
FOR ANYONE PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED
OF THIS LOITERING OFFENSE AND
PROVIDES FOR RESENTENCING FOR
ANYONE CURRENTLY SERVING A
SENTENCE FOR THIS OFFENCE. SEN
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT LOUIS DURING
FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PROSTITUTION- IS NOT ONE OF
LIKE THE OLD SCHOOL OFFENSES IN
THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE'S
BEEN AROUND FOREVER. IT WAS PUT
INTO THE PENAL CODE IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE. AND IT WAS- DONE
AN EFFORT TO QUOTE UNQUOTE
CLEAN UP THE NEIGHBORHOODS OF
UNDESIRABLE- QUOTE UNQUOTE.
PEOPLE THIS MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSES FAILED TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IS ENFORCED
AGAINST BLACK AND BROWN WOMEN
AND TRANS WOMAN. I DO TO THE
BROAD AND SUBJECTIVE NATURE OF
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS OFFENSE
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS GIVEN THE
PERMISSION TO PROFILE PEOPLE TO
STOP PEOPLE TO ARREST PEOPLE
FOR INHERENTLY DISCRIMINATORY
REASONS SUCH AS WHAT KIND OF
CLOTHING. A PERSON IS WEARING
WHO THEY'RE TALKING TO HOW
THEY'RE WALKING IN OTHER WRDS
YOU YOU'RE WEARING TIGHT
CLOTHES YOU'RE TALKING TO
PEOPLE- THERE WAS SEX WORK
HAPPENING HERE- LAST WEEK SO
THEREFORE I THINK YOU'RE-
LOITERING WITH THE INTENT TO
COMMIT PROSTITUTION. AND SO THE
OFFICER CAN ARREST THE PERSON
THIS LAW AND CURRENTLY. ENGAGES
IN PROFILING- CRIMINALIZING
PEOPLE FOR LOITERING WITH
INTENT TO ENGAGE IN SEX WORK
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES
MISTRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TARGET
COMMUNITIES THIS MISTRUST IS
DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE IT REINFORCES THAT
STREET BASED SEX WORKERS- AND
PARTICULARLY IN CHEMICAL BROWN
COMMUNITIES AND TRANS
COMMUNITIES. I THINK THOSE TO
THEM THAT THEY SHOULD AT ALL
COSTS AVOID LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MODERATOR CAN YOU SHE WOULD
GOING ON ONLINE OR HAVE SOMEONE
MEET THEIR DEVICES PLEASE.
CONTINUES WE ARE IDENTIFYING
THE PROBLEM IF YOU ARE ON THE
LINE PLEASE UTILIZE YOUR MUTE
BUTTON WHEN NOT SPEAKING THANK
YOU. TO THIS LAW- CREATES
MISTRUST BETWEEN POLICE AND-
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
TRANS COMMUNITIES- AND SINGLES
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY SHOULD NOT
TRUST EVEN REPORTING CRIMES TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT GET. ARRESTED THEMSELVES.
ON ONE PEOPLE INCLUDING
SURVIVORS OF SEX TRAFFICKING
ARRESTED FOR LOITERING- THEY
SUBSEQUENTLY FACE MORE BARRIERS
TO ACCESS SAFE HOUSING AND
LEGAL EMPLOYMENT. EARLIER THIS
YEAR NEW YORK STATE REPEALED A
VERY SIMILAR OFFENSE THAT
CRIMINALIZED LOITERING WITH
INTENT TO ENGAGE IN SEX WORK
AND TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO DO
THE SAME. THIS BILL DOES NOT
DECRIMINALIZE SOLICITING OR
ENGAGING IN SEX WORK THAT IS A
CONVERSATION. FOR ANOTHER DAY-
SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN SIMPLY
ELIMINATES AN ANTI LOITERING
OFFENSE THAT RESULTS IN THE
LEGAL PROFILING TARGETING AND
HARASSMENT OF LGBTQ PEOPLE
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
SIMPLY FOR EXISTING AND SIMPLY
BASED ON THE WAY THAT THEY LOOK
THE WAY THEY WALK. ETCETERA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS- WITH ME TODAY IS
TESTIFIED BY PHONE ARAFAT TO
MOST OF US WHO IS THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF FATIMA
SPEAKS. AND CELESTINA PAROLE
THE OUT REACH MANAGER AT SAINT
JAMES INFIRMARY THANK YOU. PART
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE READY
YOU HAVE A TOTAL FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL CHAU. TO RUNCORN FIRST.
ALTHOUGH FIRST SO HELLO
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS BETWEEN
DECEMBER ARGUMENT ON THE G. Q.
I A AVERAGE AND AVERAGES AND
ACTIVISTS AND ALSO THE CEO AND
PRESIDENT. OF THE TEAM'S
MICHELE- SEE. I'M HERE TODAY I
COME THIS WOMAN THAT.
RECOGNITION OF THE PEOPLE OF
RUSSIA FROM ORDERING THE INTENT
TO COMMIT PROSTITUTION AND THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ARE BLACK.
WE'RE WE'RE IN A CITY WHERE.
EIGHT OF 8% OF THE POPULATION
IS BLACK. SO THIS BRINGS TO
MIND TERRORISM TOM LIKE. THE
JIM CROW LAWS OF NINETEEN
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES OF THE
STATE'S LAWS THAT WERE SPECIFIC
TO AND DIRECTION NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BLACK PEOPLE CREATED
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
SOME SUPPORTING- ARMS WILL
CONTRIBUTE SERVICES STOPPING
SHORT AND- GIVE YOU LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE LATITUDE TO
CONTINUALLY HARASSED AROUND
WOMEN AND TRANS WOMEN OF COLOR
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THE
STYLE OF DRESS FOR THE LOCATION
OF THE- OFFICE AND HAPPEN TO
SEE THE MAN. AT THE TIME THAT
THEY ENCOUNTER IN THE BUSINESS
THIS ORDER IS ALSO USED TO
LEASE THE LATITUDE TO RATIONAL
REGISTRY BASED TRANS WOMEN SUCH
MORE BLUE COLLAR SCHOOL ALREADY
AMONG THE MOST MORE WHO ARE AND
HAVE SUFFERED. THE MOST TO
BEING ATTACKED AND MURDERED
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WITH
THE TWENTY SIX- TRIED WOMEN. OF
COLOR MURDERED. IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS- AND NOW WE'RE GETTING
PERSONS AND- TO. FOR A
NECESSARY WAY TO MAKE IT LIVING
IS I WILL AND- THOMAS UP BILL
BECAUSE THE- AS WRITTEN
CRIMINALIZED STREET BY FOR IS
BEING. BY OUR YEARS TO ALL THE
FORM MCCOY. HOUSE PROBLEM CARE-
SENATE SUPPORT. YOU ALSO PUT
THE BILL BE IT WOULD SHOW TO
ALL COST WORKING OF THOSE WHO
CRIMINAL LAW- TWENTY LOWER
RIVER ORDINANCES AND- AND THE
CLASSES. THE LAW HAS BEEN
LEGALLY IN LOW. WOULD HELP YOU
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IS AND- THE
LOWER IS. ARMS IT IS. BY AND
THE COMPLETELY IN TOTALLY. THE
COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE LOOK
SPECIFICALLY SO WOMEN OF COLOR-
BECAUSE THIS ORDINANCE YOU KNOW
WATERING. CONTENT FOR
PROSECUTION STRIKES THE STREET
BRIDGE WORKER MORE HARSHLY THAN
ANY OTHER ASPECT OF HIS
BUSINESS AND MOST OF THE STREET
BRIDGE WORKERS ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. TRANSWOMEN OF COLOR DO
YOU A. LOT SO YOU KNOW OR BLACK.
IN A CAR AND WE ARE VERY. WARM
MORE CRIMINAL. AND BEING OLD
WITHOUT BREADWINNERS ANY
REGARDS OF BARRIERS IT CREATES.
THAT JUST BUT BACK THE STREET.
SOME I'M HERE TONIGHT TO
SUPPORT. SENATE BILL CLINTON.
THANK FOR THIS. HELLO MY NAME
IS VALENTINO PEARL SHE HEARD. I
AM FORMER SEX WORKER AND
CURRENT QUARTER OF SEX WORKER
COMMUNITY I THE OUTREACH
DIRECTOR OF SAINT JAMES
INFIRMARY WE ARE UP HERE
BIGGEST HEALTH CLINIC COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION RUN BY AND FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER SEX WORKERS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. WE ARE ALSO COSPONSORED
THE BILL. WE GO OUT ON THE
STREET BECAUSE SUPPORTER
COMMUNITIES LIVING OR WORKING
ON THE STREET SEVERAL TIMES A
WEEK. MANY SEX WORKERS RETURNED
TO THE STREETS BY LACK OF
ACCESS. FOR ONLINE ADVERTISING
AND BETTING OPTIONS AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF FOSTA SESTA. THIS
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS MORE
HEARING WITH INTENT TO COMMIT
PROSTITUTION WHICH WE'RE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT TODAY. WE'RE
DESIGN WITHOUT INPUT BY THE
PEOPLE AFFECTED AS IS ALMOST
ALWAYS THE CASE. WE AFFECTED
SEX WORKERS INCLUDING IF NOT
ESPECIALLY UNDERAGE GIRLS
TRANSWOMEN BLACK WOMEN MIGRANT
CORE I'M HOUSE. COERCIVITY
TRAFFIC TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY AT HIGH RISK OF
VIOLENCE AND YOU COULD TEACH
DEPORTATION SHOULD BE PUSHED
OUT ONTO THE STREET MAKES THEM
VULNERABLE TO VIOLENT ARREST
INCARCERATION A RECORD AND IT
MICHAEL OF SYSTEMIC ABUSE THAT
LEAVES THEM WITH NO OTHER
OPTION. BUT ST DATES WORK. WHY
DO PEOPLE FOR THEIR- AND THEN
FURTHER CRIMINALIZING THEM BUT
THEIR EXISTENCE IN PUBLIC BY
THE SAME SYSTEM. YOU'RE NOT THE
ONLY ONE GOT ON OUR STREETS
EITHER THERE ARE ALSO NOT
WORKING PEOPLE BEING HARASSED
AND BEEN ARRESTED FOR THEIR
SUPPOSED INTENT. THE WAY THE
ADDRESS THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN
OR GENDER EXPRESSION. JUDGES
RIGHT TO TAKE UP SPACE AND
EXPRESS THEMSELVES WEARING A
SHORT SKIRT. HE JOB DREADLOCKS
OR ANY OTHER EXPRESSION OF
THEMSELVES WITHOUT BEING
CRIMINALIZED FOR THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN RELIGION GENDER OR
SURVIVAL WE ALL DESERVE TO
EXIST IN PUBLIC PEACEFULLY
WITHOUT FEAR OF ARREST. PLEASE
SUPPORT TRUE PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
ALL PLEASE JOIN US IN
SUPPORTING SB THREE FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HEARING TODAY. I DON'T THINK
I'M GOING FROM BEING THANK YOU
NOW WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES
INSIDE OF FORTY TWO ALL THREE I
SEE THERE ARE NONE HERE.
WANTING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
LOOKING TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NO ONE THERE EITHER WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MISS
MODERATOR DO WE ARE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. THREE FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER. FOR
CALM INFO. OF S. B. THREE FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND A LINE EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE EUROS WHAT YOUR MIKE OF
THE OPEN. THANK YOU CAN MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. STRONG SUPPORT OFFICE
STATING SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL AID AT WORK LEERINK
POSITIVE WOMEN'S NETWORK USA.
RELIGIOUS COALITION FOR
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE. AND GO
PUBLIC DEFENDER OR IN THE
QUEUE. WHAT BEHIND BARS AND THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. DO NEXT
WITNESS. BLIND EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. I ACTUALLY MANAGED ON
BEHALF OF SEX WORKERS OUTREACH
PROJECT LOS ANGELES WE ARE CO
SPONSORING THE BILL AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE AT
NINE HUNDRED NINE YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING GOING BACK
IT'S A CO SPONSOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND TO READ
INTO THE RECORD CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE HELLO
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
HEY WE ROAD ISLAND. INDUSTRY
LABOR IS AN ARTIST SITUATION.
ENISHI EXISTENCE THANK YOU. AN
ONLINE NINE HUNDRED SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI THIS
IS CESAR ESPINOSA PER AS I'M A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND THE
SEX INDUSTRY AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE DECRIMINALIZE SEX WORK
CALIFORNIA COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SENATE BILL. THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. ONE SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE YOUR MY KIDS UP AND.
ANY MERGING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
NINE HUNDRED TEN YOUR MY KIDS
UP AND- HI THIS IS MICHELLE THE
REQUESTED- WITH THE TRANS
LATINA COALITION AND WE ARE
PROUD SPONSORS OF THE SPELL AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
NINE HUNDRED TWELVE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY FUND BETTER- I AM A
MEMBER OF WALK AWAY AND A BOX
CUTTER SB. THREE FIFTY SEVEN.
LINE NINE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI THIS
IS KATIE FROM INSTRUCTORS
PROJECT FROM URBAN JUSTICE
CENTER I WANT STRONG SUPPORT
AND- THIS LEGISLATION THANK.
ONE EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. BUT
AFTERNOON LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. HI I'M KRISTIN
DEANGELO UNDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SERVICE
OUTREACH PROJECT SACRAMENTO AND
I'M ALSO SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY THIS LAW
CRYSTALLINE- I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
ONE SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MY
COULD OPEN. HEY ALEX MARGULIES
ON BEHALF OF THE US PROSTITUTES
COLLECTIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN AS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS LAW HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED ALL
WOMEN- OF COLOR- IN WHO LIVE IN
POVERTY AND- OR THAT. OF THE
SENATE HELP. IN SUPPORT. BLIND
AT NINE HUNDRED FIVE YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS A CRISIS
WITH SEX WORKERS OUTREACH
PROJECT LOS ANGELES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIVE SEVEN
THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS KRISTA PSYCHO
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION SURVIVOR IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
BLIND AND NINE HUNDRED YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS SAM CHOI NINETY ANTI
TRAFFICKING A PROJECT MANAGER
AT ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGAL
OUTREACH AND A PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT THANK YOU. AND
ALIGNED NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN
YOUR MY KIDS UP. HI MY NAME IS
MAKAYLA I AM A MAN NUMBER OF
CLEAR THE BORDERING RIGHT TO
PRIVACY AND I SUPPORT SB THREE
FIVE SEVEN COMMANDED POLITY
READY WITH ALL SEX WORKERS
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE AND HELP
PEOPLE THANK YOU. N. MISTER
TERRY WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. SHE
CHECKED LONG JUST ONE MORE TIME
TO SEE IF THERE IS ANYONE STILL
DESIROUS OF TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIVE SEVEN.
SURE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THREE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN IT'S ONE. ZERO AND WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AND A LINE NINE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN YEAR MY COULD OPEN.
OKAY POLICE ON. FIND FOR YOU
KNOW. AND INTO THE KITCHEN IF
YOU'RE IN THE- ABOUT THAT AT
THE MINIMUM A LITTLE I'M NOT
ALLOWED MANY OF THEM WILL BE IN
THE FURTHER AND I DON'T.
WELCOME OF THE MILLENNIAL. I'M
I'M I'M I'M- I'M A POLICY.
ABOUT BUT IF DON'T KNOW OUR
BASIC GARY CURRICULA ALL THE
LOOKING FOR CRUZ WORKED ON A
LOT OF CLIENTS YOU KNOW THE
AMOUNT OF POLICE UP AND WILL BE
MORE AND LOOKED OFFICE COULD
GIVE PEOPLE BE A IN THE IDEAL.
MY NAME IS LI. I AM A TRYING.
WOMAN I AM ONLY OKAY IT IS THAT
THE NOTHING. ON AND I AM. I
WOULD RATHER BE I WOULD BE
WHERE. THEN IT- TO BE PROFILE
BY THE- AND I MEAN OF AS THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE FURTHER AT THIS
TIME. Q. NOW MOVE TO OFFICE. I
SEE THERE'S NO LEAD WITNESS AN
OPPOSITE. OF SB THREE FIVE. I'M
LOOKING HERE IN THE ROOM A
FORTY TWO OH THREE I SEE NO ON
HERE EITHER I'M LOOKING TO ROOM
TWENTY FOR YOU THERE'S NO ONE
THERE. MODERATOR WILL NOW GO TO
PHONE LINES- AND SEE IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES IN Q. AND
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE FIVE
SEVEN. YOUR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE GIVE THEM THEIR LINE. MISTER
CHAIR LOOKED LIKE THEY
DISCONNECTED- WONDERING AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE FIVE
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO.
IN LINE
NINE HUNDRED SIX FOR MY COULD
OPEN. ADJOURNMENTS. WHAT JUST
ONE MOMENT WHILE I GET THEM
BACK PLEASE. ALL RIGHT LAND
NINE HUNDRED SIX YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS WHILE COMPLICATED
I PULLED THAT- THIS IS BRANDED
UP ON BEHALF OF SHARE A- BEING
WE HAVE BEEN FOR THE WEAKNESS
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ZOR
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS A IT
RELATES TO A THREE THREE FIVE
SEVEN FROM ANY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR CALM WATER HI
I JUST WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
YOU KNOW I. SEXES OKAY HAVING
SEX IS OKAY. PAYING FOR SEX IS
OKAY- BUT BEING PROFILED
BECAUSE OF YOUR BODY. AND
ASSUME TO BE A PROSTITUTE AND
LOITERING IT IS NOT OKAY. AS A
WOMAN- WHO. HAS HAD EXPERIENCES
WHERE FOLKS EITHER HAVE A
FETISH OR IDEALIZING OR ARE-
REALLY SORT OF DIMINISHING. MY
PERSONHOOD I'M BASED ON MY BODY
AND HAVE MADE ASSUMPTIONS AND
PRESUMPTIONS ABOUT WHAT. WHO I
AM AND WHAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
BILL. THAT SPEAKS TO THOSE
KINDS OF STEREO TYPES- AND MIS
CHARACTERIZATIONS- AND THE
MARGINALIZATION THAT HAPPENS
FOR SO MANY WOMEN AND FOR SO
MANY TRANS WOMEN- AND SO I WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE WITH
ASTON I COULD BE CONSIDERED A
CO AUTHOR BECAUSE I THINK THIS
KINDOF. DISCUSSION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
AND YOUR WITHOUT THAT YOU. AND
IT IS A COMMON TO QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. KERN NINE ON
IS OUR MOTION ON SB THREE FIVE
SEVEN. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR COM LARGER WE- HAVE A
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AT THREE THREE FIVE SEVEN.
SB THREE FIVE SEVENTY PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD ARE
ADVERTISED CHOI BOGUE NO JOB NO
KAMLAGER COMMA- I SKINNER
WIENER WIENER AYE. THE MEASURE
HAS THREE VOTES THREE TO ONE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OPTION MEMBER. NOW WE'LL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM. ELEVEN- S. B.
THREE FIVE SEVEN. WELCOME
SENATOR BRADFORD OR YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB. FIVE SIX
SEVEN. THANK YOU- FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN NINE AS DISAPPROVES UPON
THE STATE FELONY THIS
DETERMINATE SENTENCING LAW THAT
WAS. PROVE THE NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO AND IT JUST CREATES A
PRESUMPTIVE OF SENTENCING
JUDGMENT NOT TO EXCEED THE MID
TERM UNLESS THERE'S A GOOD.
ACTIVATING US CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT JUSTIFIED THE IMPOSITION
OF P RETURN SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
PROVIDES THAT WOUND UP FOR
TERMS IMPOSED THERE HAS TO BE
CERTAIN SUPPORTING FACTS SUCH
AS STIPULATED BY THE DEFENDED
AND SUBMITTED TO A JURY
IMPROVING BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT. OUR FOUND AND DETERMINED
BY THE COURT IN A BENCH TRIAL
IN INSTANCE WHERE THERE WAS NO
TAKING- AUTHORS AMENDMENTS IN
COMMITTEE TO REQUIRE THE TROUT.
REQUIRED THE TRIAL ON THE
SUBSTANTIVE CHARGES BE
SEPARATED FROM THE TRIAL ON THE
AGGRAVATED FACTORS IF DEFENDED
THE REQUESTED- AGAIN AS OF
20001077% OF STATE PRISON
INMATES WERE SERVING
INDETERMINATE SENTENCE MOST
CONVICTED FELONS IN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE A DETERMINATE SENTENCE
BASED ON THE TRIAD OF SENTENCE
STRUCTURE WITH LOWER MIDDLE AND
UPPER TERMS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE THE PENAL CODE SECTION
ELEVEN SEVENTY STATES THAT IF
THE STATUE SPECIFIES. THREE
POSSIBLE SENTENCE. IN TERMS TO
CHOICE OF THE PROPER TERM REST
WITH THE DISCRETION OF THE
COURT- THAT EXISTING LAW SUNSET
IT. SUNSETS I SHOULD SAY IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
BEFORE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
PENAL CODE SECTION ELEVEN
SEVENTY BE REQUIRED THE JUDGES
IMPOSE A MID TERM. IN
SENTENCING THE LESS THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN AGGRAVATION OR
MITIGATION OF A CRIME THAT
WARRANTS A LOWER OR UPPER TERM
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. THE US
SUPREME COURT HELD IN
CUNNINGHAM VERSUS CALIFORNIA
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DETERMINANT
SENTENCING LAW WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THE COURT
RULED THAT CALIFORNIA'S LAW.
IMPERMISSIBLY ALLOWED JUDGES TO
IMPOSE AN UPPER MAXIMUM TERM
BASED UPON AGGRAVATING FACTS
THAT WERE NEVER PRESENTED TO A
JURY. AND DEEM TO BE TRUE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT THUS
VIOLATING THE SIXTH AMENDMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION- RIGHT TO JURY
TRIAL BY JURY AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN A LEGISLATIVE WITH
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED. SB FORTY
TO FIX ITS CONSTITUTIONALITY
PROBLEM AND TO DO SO WHILE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND THE
SENTENCE TO SENTENCING
STRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA IS
REVIEW. THE SUNSET ON SB FORTY
HAS BEEN EXTENDED. MULTIPLE
TIMES VIA S. B. I FOR SIX THREE
A. B. FIVE NINETY AND IS NOW
AGAIN- DUE TO SUNSET IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WHILE IT
IS APPROPRIATE TO PUNISH PEOPLE
FOR COMMITTING CRIME TO HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GIVE.
IMPACTED PEOPLE PROPER DUE
PROCESS. THAT IS BUILT ON
FAIRNESS AND FACT THAT FOSTERS
REHABILITATION AND ALSO
ACHIEVES A PUBLIC SAFETY GOAL
THIS IS A PERFECT OF THIS BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. AND I HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I HAVE- JOHN J. VASQUEZ
WHO WORKED FOR WORKS AS A
SPACIOUS SAY PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATION DEFENSE AND
POLICY COORDINATOR FOR
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND MY
OTHER WITH THIS IS STEPHEN MARK
MA KELT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CRIMINAL ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. AND MR MCHALE HAS
FORTY THREE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
AS AN ATTORNEY IN HIS-
CERTIFIED SPECIALIST IN
CRIMINAL LAW. AND ACTORS AT A
TESTIMONY WILL TAKE. ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS BY MR ASCUS.
ON THAT NOTE I ASKED FOR A VOTE.
I'M SORRY I'M IN CHARGE. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE FOR BRADFORD.
IT'S BEEN A LONG LONG DAY. MMHM
OKAY. DO WE HAVE WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES DO WE HAVE
JOHN VASQUEZ ON THE LINE OR
STEVEN MARKET. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. MY NAME IS JAY
VAZQUEZ I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
SUPPORTIVE MANAGEMENT POLICY
COORDINATOR OKAY YOU UNITED
PROVISIONAL TO JUSTICE AND
POLITICAL SPONSOR OF. THAT SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN. I'M ALSO
MILLION CALL. HOW DO YOU SERVE
FIVE YEARS AFTER THE PROCESS.
THE AUTHENTICATED. SIXTY SO MY
FRIEDMAN PROVOKES. NUMENERA IN
PARTS OF THE PEOPLE PARTIALLY
AND THE HIGHWAY OF THE
COMMISSION. ON HOW TO MANY
FACTORS. WHICH WERE NEVER
PROVEN TO BE TRUE BY GERMAN.
WOULD YOU MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. PARTICIPANT USUAL
PLACE HOLDING ON UNPROVEN
ACCUSATIONS FROM TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE. MAJORITY OF
VIETNAM MEDALS. I COME ACROSS.
C. MOBILE AND IT WAS A HARD ARE
BLACK AND BROWN. SB FIVE
HUNDRED. NOT A GET OUT OF YOUR
FREE CARD. ONE SEVEN ALLOWING
JUDGES TOLD REPORTERS FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. ALL PROVIDE A
OPPORTUNITY. IT IS. NOT A VALID
DAY- COMMITTEE BACK BEFORE YOU.
YOUR MIND SURE USUALLY HARDER
THANK ARE NOT AROUND OUT
LITERALLY. ALL THE HARD WORK.
BECAUSE HELLO TAXPAYERS MONEY.
WE THOUSAND FOR EACH ADDITIONAL
YEAR ON THE TERM. I THINK IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN ALSO WHEN LAW
WITH THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
YOU SUPREME COURT IS.
CUNNINGHAM CALIFORNIA. SAID
RENDON ANY TAX THEY DEPEND
GREAT POTENTIAL CENTER MUST BE
FOUND BY GERMAN NOT A JUDGE AND
I WAS ON A DOUBT. NEARLY FIVE
HUNDRED. AT THE- WHAT DO YOU
REASONS ONLY QUIT YOUR I HOPE
TO THANK YOU. FOR THE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- IT'S OUR BEST
GUESS IS MR STEVEN MARKET ON
THE LINE. YES I AM THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- THE LEGISLATURE
RESPONDED WITH SB FORTY VERY
QUICKLY AFTER CUNNINGHAM
DECISION HOWEVER. WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE REFORM FIX THE
PROBLEM. OUR COURTS ARE STILL
REQUIRED TO STATE ON THE RECORD
WHICH FAXIAN AGGRAVATION WERE
FOUND TRUE BY THE JUDGE IN
ORDER TO JUSTIFY AN OPPORTUNE.
THIS IS EXACTLY THE SAME
JUDICIALFACT FINDING THE
CUNNINGHAM FOUND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. UNDER SB FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN WHAT A PROSECUTOR
THINKS THEY HAVE AN AGGRAVATED
CASE THEY WILL ADD AGGRAVATING
FACTORS TO THE INFORMATION
WHICH CURRENTLY CHARGES FOR
CRIMES AND ENHANCEMENTS. IF THE
CASE GOES TO TRIAL AND ONLY
THREE OUT OF A HUNDRED CASES GO
TO TRIAL. THE COURT WILL
BIFURCATE THE AGGRAVATING
FACTORS AND THE JURY WILL
RECEIVE EVIDENCE ON THE CHARGES
IN HERE AND ENHANCEMENTS IF THE
DEFENDANT IS FOUND GUILTY THEN
THE AGGRAVATING FACTORS WOULD
BE PRESENTED TO THE JURY.
HOWEVER IN THE REAL WORLD THE
STRUCTURE STEP WILL SELDOM
OCCUR AND WILL TAKE VERY LITTLE
COURT TIME OVERALL. FOR EXAMPLE
IN CURRENT PRACTICE PRIOR
CONVICTIONS OR BIFURCATED IN
JUST THIS WAY. OFTEN THE
DEFENDANT AFTER BEING CONVICTED
WILL BAN ADMIT THE PRIORS OR
WAIVE JURY AND WHAT THE COURT
DECIDES THE PRIORS. AND THIS IS
A VRY STANDARD PROCEDURE TODAY
AND IT DOES NOT ADD
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE AVERAGE
TIME FOR TRIALS IT'S VERY
LIKELY THAT. SB FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN WOULD CREATE A SIMILAR-
EFFICIENT PROCESS OF
DETERMINING THE AGGRAVATING
FACTORS IN A TRIAL SITUATION.
SO THE BILL DOES NOTHING TO
LIMIT PROTECT PARTICIPATION OF
VICTIMS IN THE CASE. THE VICTIM
HAS A RIGHT TO EXPRESS VIEWS ON
SENTENCING WAS SET UP IN
PROPOSITION ONE FIFTEEN OTHERS-
NEITHER. SECTIONALISM SEVENTY
NOR THE STATE CONSTITUTION
LIMIT WHAT THEY CAN SAY IF THE
VICTIM WANTS TO ARGUE FOR THE
DEATH PENALTY FOR AN EMBEZZLER.
THEY'RE FREE TO DO THAT. BUT
THE COURT CANNOT ORDER THAT
UNLAWFUL ENTRY. WE CUNNINGHAM
HOLDING WAS QUOTE THE STATUTORY
MAXIMUM IS A MAXIMUM SENTENCE
OF JUDGMENT POEMS. ON THE BASIS
OF A FACT REFLECTED IN THE JURY
VERDICT OR ADMITTED BY THE
DEFENDANT. TODAY A CALIFORNIA
JUDGE MAY NOT IMPOSE THE
AGGRAVATED TERM WITHOUT
SPECIFICALLY FINDING SOME
AGGRAVATING FACTORS. BUT THOSE
FACTS HAVE NOT BEEN FOUND BY
THE JURY OR ADMITTED BY THE
DEFENDANT HENCE THE SYSTEM IS
STILL A VIOLATION OF THE SIXTH
AMENDMENT. SB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
WILL FIX THAT AND DO IT
EFFICIENTLY. WE ASK FOR OUR
VOTE AND I WILL REMAIN
AVAILABLE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR MARKET- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO- ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE CNN. ARE
THERE ANY WITTICISM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE. FIVE SIX
SEVEN. SEEING NONE THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR THIS MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR COMMENTS AND SUPPORT
S. B. FIVE SIX SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. RECOMMEND
AGAIN ONE. ZERO THANK YOU
MODERATE WIND SEVEN HA. YOU'RE
WELCOME LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE YOU MAKE IT UP BUT-
AB MARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
IT LINE EIGHT HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BLIND NINE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
EVENING SHARON SENATORS THIS IS
MICHAEL KESSLER WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. BY NINE HUNDRED ONE HERE
MY COULD OPEN. NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE ARE CO
SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE AFTER
SUPPORT. AN ONLINE SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. ON BEHALF OF MYSELF OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED CITIZENS-
THEN PACKED IT BY THE UNFAIR
LAWS- I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. FIVE SIX SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR HE
PLEASE- CHECK THE LINES ONE
MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE WE'VE
HEARD OF ALL THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVEN. SURE
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT COMING.
HAVE OU HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION- TO. OPPOSITION HERE.
YES MAKING IT MORE AN ACTOR I
AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. PERFECT LAUREN ARE
PLEASE. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BORN AFTER
I'VE AN ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CRUZ AND I SPENT FOUR AND
A HALF YEARS AS A DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL DOING CRIMINAL
APPELLATE WORK BUT HE GETTING
KIND OF SPEED MANUTIUS
CALIFORNIA'S. WE'LL SEND THEM.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN. AS THE BILL HAS
NOTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
WHEN CUNNINGHAM VERSUS
CALIFORNIA HELP THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DETERMINATE
SENTENCING SCHEME I THINK THE
GOOD. WAS NOT SUFFICIENTLY
ADVISORY. THE THREE PROPOSED
PRISON TERMS THE MEDICATED THE
MIDDLE AND AGGRAVATED THE JUDGE
WAS REQUIRED TO IMPOSE THE
MIDDLE TERM AND LET THE
CONTRACTORS AN AGGRAVATION. THE
MIDDLE TERM THAT OPERATED AT
THE STATUTORY MAXIMUM LEGALLY
AND ANY FACTORS IN AGGRAVATION
HAD TO BE QUITE IMPRUDENT
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT TO A
JURY. WHAT THE POTENTIAL FOR
COSTLY. THREE MONTHS AFTER
CUNNINGHAM THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SENATE BILL FORTY.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN MODEL.
PARDON LITTLE BIT APPOINT UNDER
MODEL THE FEDERAL SENTENCING
SCHEME APPROVED BY THE SUPREME
COURT IT GAVE JUDGES TRUE
DISCRETIONARY POWER TO TAKE A
HOLISTIC VIEW OF THE CASE AND
IMPOSE THE APPROPRIATE
PREFERABLE WE ALSO NOTE THAT
THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION IS
LIMITED JUDGES CANNOT IMPOSE A
SENTENCE THAT IS ARBITRARY
CAPRICIOUS OR- OR EVEN. GET
DEFENDANT CAN SHOWER THAT FOR
THE DISCRETION AGGRAVATING.
MUST BE SUPPORTED BY
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE. EVIDENCE
THAT IS A REASONABLE CREDIBLE
AND SALAS AL YOU SO THE
SENTENCING HEARING THE
DEFENDANT IS EMPOWERED TO
PRESENT HIS EVIDENCE AND
CHALLENGE ANY EVIDENCE IN THE
CORPORATION REPORT THAT THE
PROSECUTOR PRESENT THAT THEY
FEEL. IT'S NOT TRUE OR UNFAIR
OR SHOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
SIXTY KIND OF UNWIND THE CLOCK
FOURTEEN YEARS AND IMPLEMENT
THE MORE COSTLY ALTERNATIVES SB
FORTY. WHICH WOULD BE AMENDED
THAT HAS BEEN ACCEPTED WE
CREATE A BIFURCATED PENALTY
PAID FOR EVERY FELONY CASE
WHERE AN AGGRAVATED TERM WITH
THE APPROPRIATE. MY FIRST
CONCERN AFTER LEARNING ABOUT
THIS AMENDMENT YESTERDAY I WELL
IT DOESN'T DRAW SOME OF THE
CONCERNS BE RAISED AND OUR
OPPOSITION LETTER. WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHAT THE PENALTY PHASE
BIFURCATE A PENALTY PHASE
YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
THERE IS A TOUCHSTONE IN PENAL
CODE SECTION ONE NINETY POINT
THREE WHICH STRUCTURES THE
CAPITAL CASE HELP YOU PAID.
WHICH IS THE ONLY. WHERE THERE
IS A VERY SUBSTANTIVE AN
EXTENSIVE PENALTY PHASE BUT
IT'S NOT A PERFECT TECHNOLOGY.
WE'RE DEALING WITH Y. VICTIMS.
AND DISCLOSURE CAN BE DELAYED
OR PIECEMEAL. ACTUALLY TRUE IN
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES WE NOW
KNOW THE SOCIETY BECAUSE THE
COMPLEX RELATIONSHIPS AND
TRAUMA VICTIMS- COME OUT RIGHT
AWAY WITH EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED TO THEM SO THE
QUESTION IS. CAN MEET PEOPLE
AND MEN AT ANYTIME. TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF VICTIMS IN THE CASE
AND TO GIVE THE DEFENDANT
PROPER NOTICE OF THE FACTORS IN
AGGRAVATION OCCURRED THEY'RE
GOING TO SEEK EMPLOYMENT. PART
OF THE CONCERN IS RELATED TO A
TWENTY TWENTY HEY FROM THE
SUPREME COURT THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT PEOPLE THE
ANDERSON. OR DEFENDANT IS
ENTITLED TO ADEQUATE NOTICE. OF
ANY FACTOR THAT IS GOING TO BE
HERE JOIN. HER CONTENT. WHAT WE
HAVE TO PLEAD IMPROVE THESE AT
A PRELIMINARY HEARING WOULD OF
COURSE HAVE THE DISCRETION TO
STRIKE THEM. IF I THREE FINE
ACTORS AN APPLICATION WAT THEY
FIND COURT OVER TO COURT BE
ABLE TO STRIKE THEM IMPOSE THE
MIDDLE OR MITIGATED TERM.
WITHOUT FURTHER DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT THE PENALTY PHASE
TRIAL FOR FELONY COOKBOOK LIKE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AND LITIGATION OVER
LACK THAT WILL. RESULT IN.
INCONSISTENT AND NON UNIFORM
SENTENCING. THIS AFTER WOULD
YOU MIND WRAPPING EVENT WERE
RIGHT ABOUT FIVE MINUTES. YES
ANOTHER CONCERN ARE RAISING
COSTS A TWENTY ELEVEN REPORT ON
THE DEATH PENALTY IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT AT THE ADDITIONAL COST
INCURRED BY PENALTY PHASES OF
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THE
DEATH PENALTY IS EXPENSIVE MUCH
MORE INVOLVED FOR YEAR TWELVE
JURORS THAT ARE CAPABLE OF
CONSIDERING JUST PASSIONATELY A
FANFIC HIGH SKILLED ARE NOT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO KEEP
UP ALL THE CONFLICTING TO
EMBARK FELONY PENALTY PHASE
WITH MUCH MORE EMOTIONALLY
INTENSE EVIDENCE- IT'S OUR
POSITION THAT JUDGES ARE ABLE
TO HANDLE AND MORE
DISPASSIONATELY HANDLE THIS
EVIDENCE. AND FOR THAT REASON
YOU MUCH MEMBERS ON SB. FIFTY
FIVE SIX SEVEN THANK YOUNG CARE.
LET'S ON TO WHO IN ROOM TWO
THREE SEEN NONE ARE THEY ANY
WHAT IS TO FORTY WISH TO. UP SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN SEEN NONE. THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WANTING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE THIS.
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WHEN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO U. S.
B. FIVE SIX SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO THANK YOU MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SURE
AS OF RIGHT NOW WE HAVE NO
COMMENT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATE IF YOU WILL PLEASE AT.
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE
SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. SURE FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FIVE SIX SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. COMMANDER
CAN. ONE ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH. OKAY
DO WE GIVE ENOUGH TIME TO PAY
FOR THE OPPOSITION. ARE WE OK
TO MOVE ON OKAY. OKAY THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MATTER IF YOU
SEE THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS DO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. WE HAVE A MOTION
TO MOVE THE BILL BY SENATOR
SCOTT WIENER ANY OTHER
DISCUSSIONS OR COMMENTS ON S.
B. FIVE SIX SEVEN FROM OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR
BOXER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU FOR OF THE
TESTIMONY OF THOSE AND SUPPORT
AS WELL AS THOSE OPPOSITION
THINGS DISTRICT FOR MEASURE
THAT HELPS US TO- ILLUMINATE
AND- SET TO TERMINATE SENTENCES
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
COMMITTED CRIMES AND- BUT NOT
UNNECESSARILY OVER SENTENCING
SIMPLY BASED ON. FACTS THERE
WEREN'T PROVEN SHOW- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD- AND
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD I'D CHOKE
NO TROUBLE NO COM LONGER COME
LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER I
WIENER WINNER ICE FORTY ONE THE
BILL IS OUT WITH FIVE AT FOUR
AYE AYES AND ONE NO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS SB
FIVE EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
BRADFORD SENATOR FASTER. FIVE
THANK YOU OF THIS FIVE EIGHTY
SIX- CRIMINALLY LEGAL PROCESS
THE STATE AUTHORIZES COUNTIES
TO CHARGE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
THIS BILLS SIMPLY LEMONADE SOME
OF THOSE FEES ARE AS WE ALL
KNOW MANY TIMES- THE COURTS
IMPOSE THESE TREES AND THEY
CONSIDER THEM TO BE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS- THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
BURDENED WITH UNTIL PAID IN
FULL. AND THESE FEES ARE
REGULARLY ORDERED AS A CIVIL
JUDGMENTS AND THEY ARE REFERRED
TO LOCAL COLLECTION AGENCIES.
CLAUGHTON ADD ADDITIONAL COST
TO THE CHARGES EVEN FRENCH
JUDGE CHUCK BOARD CAN- GARNISH
WAGES ARE MY INTERCEPTOR TAX
REFUNDS I LOVE YOUR BANK
ACCOUNTS. UNTIL THE FEES ARE
PAID IN FULL- THIS IS FALLING
THE GREAT WORK TO SENATOR
MITCHELL DID IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THROUGH S. B. FOR ALL
ONE FOUR FOUR THAT ELIMINATED
ALL THESE CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES- AND ALSO
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL FROM LAST YEAR
INCORPORATED IN FUNDED TO
ELIMINATION OF TWENTY THREE
FEES. FROM S. B. ONE FORTY FOUR
VIA THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT THIS BILL SYMPTOMS SIMPLY
CONTINUE- THAT- IMPORTANT WORK
AS PART OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM FRAMEWORK THAT WE'VE
STARTED HERE AND THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY- S. B. EIGHT.
SIX FIVE EIGHT SIX I'M SORRY
WOULD IN THE ASSESSMENT AND
COLLECTION OF THE REMAINING
SIXTY SEVEN A MINISTRY TO FEES
IMPOSED AGAINST PEOPLE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND- WE
HAVE A LITANY OF WHAT THOSE
ARE- THIS BILL WILL ALSO-
ELIMINATES UNPAID FEES OF ANY
COURT IMPOSE COSTS. ELIMINATED
IN THE BILL EFFECTIVE JANUARY
OF. TWENTY TWENTY TWO- THIS- IN.
ABUSING MINISTRY FEES BALANCE
STATE AND COUNTY BUDGETS ON THE
BACKS OF THOSE WHO CAN LEAST
AFFORD IT. THE MOST CURRENT OUR
SPONSORS TO DO THIS WORK I'VE
FOUND THAT THESE FEES ARE
INCREDIBLY BURDENS AND INCREASE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS IN LIMIT
EMPLOYMENT PROSPECTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS SENDING SEEKING RE
ENTERED OUR COMMUNITIES. AND TO
A LITANY OF OTHER REASONS- YOU
KNOW IT DISPROPORTIONATELY.
HARMS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES-
JUST TO SHOULD BE BASED ON
ONE'S ABILITY TO PAY FEES THAT
WERE TACKED ON SO- HERE WITH US
TODAY ARE HAVE TWO WITNESSES-
FOR SYNCING YOUR TESTS US IN
YOUR ON THE STAFF. COMMUNITY
ORGANISING GROUP ORGANIZER WITH
ALL OF US ARE NINE- WHO WORKS
AT TI IN MASS INCARCERATION
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND SYSTEMATIC
RACISM CALIFORNIA AND BRANDON
GREEN IS DIRECTOR RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE PROGRAM ACT
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND BRENDAN PROVIDES OUR
PROGRAMMATIC VISION AND
LEADERSHIP IN ADVANCING RATIO
ANY KIND OF JUSTICE IN THE
STATE. AND ON THAT NOTE ON THIS
REQUEST FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD I WILL NOW
GO OUT TO OUR LEAD WITNESS
SAYS- DO WE HAVE HENRY ORTIZ
AND BRANDON GREEN ON THE LINE.
YES I'M I'M I'M HERE I'M
LOOKING AT HIM IS THIS HENRY.
ORTIZ THIS IS A GENERAL TWEET
ALL OF US ARE NOT SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER. PLEASE LEAVE ME. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TO
BOTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. I SPENT
THAT HALF MY LIFE IN PRISON
WHEN INTERNET YOUNG PERSON AND-
WHILE LOOKING BACK IS BY- YOU
KNOW THE WAR ON DRUGS- THE GANG
HAS WITH THE GANG INJUNCTIONS
TOUGH ON CRIME. ALL THESE
DIFFERENT JOBS- MANDATORY
SENTENCES. YOU KNOW ALL THESE
ENHANCEMENTS GUIDED MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATE THERE REALLY
INCARCERATED. THAT CRAP BECAUSE
MY LEGS BUT INCARCERATED THE
CRAP OUT OF THOSE- ANY TARGET
THAT SHOULDN'T AND ALMOST
COMMITTED GENOCIDE. AMONG
STUDENTS- I DON'T I DON'T THINK
IT'S EVER BEEN USED IT'S EVER
BEEN INCARCERATED- IN OUR
COUNTRY'S HISTORY AS A
PRECAUTION ADDED US. INTO IN
DOING THAT WE NOW ARE EXPOSED
TO HAVING ALL THE GIFTS BUT
MOVES IN OURS OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
AND HUMAN RIGHTS. BY AM HAVING
TO GO THROUGH ALL THE DIFFERENT
ABUSES THAT WE GO ON THE SYSTEM
EVERY DAY. I AND ONE OF THOSE
ABUSES LEGISLATION BY
RESTITUTION. I WAS FORCED TO
PAY RESTITUTION I THINK I HAD
LIKE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
SHIP EVEN THOUGH I BARELY HAD
ENOUGH- YEAH I MEAN THEY HAVE
RESOURCES FOR REPRESENTATION
RIGHT VERY FORTUNATE THAT I HAD
A- COURT APPOINTED ATTORNEY- IN
AND THEN. ON TOP OF THAT IT
STARTED CHARGING US 22% BY MY
FIRST YEAR AND TO MY THIRTY
YEAR MY RESTITUTION WENT ALL
THE WAY TO SIXTY FIVE PERCENT.
AND A ONE ALREADY TAKING THE
MONEY THAT THEY WERE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FROM MEETING FROM.
EIGHT CENTS TO TWELVE CENTS.
THE GOOD JOBS WHAT YOU'LL GET.
THE END I WILL THIRTY SINCE
ADDED. SATURDAY WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND- ARE. BUT HE SAID.
AND ON TOP THAT WHAT WAS MUCH.
CERTAINLY WHAT THE- WORK HARD
FOR THAT WAS TAX WELL- IF I-
YOU WHICH WILL BEATING ANY
OTHER. MONEY SENT TO FROM
DIFFERENT AT. JERRY ACT I UP.
BY DESERVE BAND EVAN AND
THERE'S THAT WERE. AND ACTION
ARE TO BE. OUR SYSTEM IN ABOUT
FIFTEEN MINUTES AT SEVEN OF WE
HAVE A STOP. SO WE'RE GOING
HAVE TO MOVE ON TO THE- WITNESS
APOLOGIZE FOR CUTTING YOU
SHORT- DO WE HAVE OUR NEXT.
WITNESS MISTER RUNNING GREEN ON
THE LINE- YES. PLEASE PER MR
GREEN THANK YOU AND- M. WE ARE
GOING TO BE JUST MAKING SURE
WE'RE WE'RE SEEING ON TIME.
MEDIAEVAL MINING BRINGING
BRINGING OF THE DIRECTOR OF THE
RACIAL ECONOMICJUSTICE PROGRAM
AT ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'M TESTIFYING GAME CORNER AT
THE FIVE EIGHTY SIX. PIPER
JAFFRAY GET BEEN YEARS IN THE
MAKING. AT AB EIGHTY SIXTY NINE
FAMILY RECEIVED. ADVOCATE THE
MEMBERS OF THAT REJECTED
CALIFORNIA COALITION EXACTLY
FOUGHT FOR LOCAL WIND ALAMEDA
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO LOCKED IN
LEGAL CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. TWO
YEARS WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT PATH
AB. EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE TO ONE
EIGHTY TWENTY THREE CORAL
MINISTRY BE. MR THE GREAT START
BUT NOW WE HAVE AT LEGISLATURE.
VISA ON THEM IN A THE REMAINING
SIXTY THREE. NOT ONLY IS THIS
IT MORTGAGE WHY WHAT THE BILL
MARLIN THE FEDEX TO WHO WE ARE
CALIFORNIANS. IN CALIFORNIA
GREENCORE CASE THE TWENTY YEAR
ARGUED THAT THE IMPOSITION OF
ON AFFORDABLE FEE ON INDIAN
PEOPLE IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS ALSO
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. NOW THE
CURRENT BLOOD THEY TO TAKE BOLD
ACTION IN THE BOOK. WRITTEN
LEGISLATION LIKE THE RIGHT TO
GET BACK IN EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE AB THE TASK FORCE TO
STUDY AND DEVELOP REPARATION
PROPOSALS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. THE LEGISLATURE
COMPLETELY CLEARLY COMMUNICATED
COMMITMENT TO RACIAL JUSTICE
WITH THE PATENT SB FIVE EIGHTY
SIX. OF THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM HAS DEVASTATED BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITY. THANK MEANS
THEY HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY
THE- BILL THE BILL PARK AT THE
TOP IN THE CELEBRATE THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BE COMMUNITY
AND ALREADY GETTING UNFAIR AND
YET RACIALIZED AGGRESSIVE
TACTICS. IT'S NO TIME TO THE
LIGHT AND WITH THE STATE- BUT
NOW IT'S TIME TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT. PROJECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE NOT
GOING MOVE- TO WITNESS HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO A THREE C. NINE.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WAS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU- SEEN NONE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY AT
THE TELECONFERENCE ARTIST IS-
JUST A QUICK COMMENT I'VE BEEN
INFORMED THAT- DUE TO THE- TO
THE RESTRICTIONS OF TIME HAVING
TO AND THEN AT SEVEN IF WE DO
NOT. HEAR FROM OUR POSITION
AND- HOWEVER OUR COMMENTS MADE
ON IN TIME. WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO TAKE A VOTE ON THIS BILL- SO
WE ARE GOING TO BE VERY A VERY
STRICT ON TIME. MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL'S WAGES AS DEFINED
IN- IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY SIX WILL BEGIN. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE EIGHT SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THANK YOU MODERATE TO PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SURE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
FIVE PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN LINE EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
EVENING LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WHY NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT- MY COULD
OPEN. WHY NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT- MY COULD OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE. WHY NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. CHIU PERFECT YOU
CAN BALANCE THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
BLIND SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
MARGUERITE ON BEHALF OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
AND THEIR LOVED ONES IN SUPPORT.
AND LINE EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. MARTIN
RADAKOVICH ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE TWO MORE PEOPLE WAITING
TO COMMENT. WHY NOT NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
REMEMBERS CHRISTOLOGY OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND LINE
NINE HUNDRED SIXTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. INSURANCE SENATORS
AND SINCE MICHAEL GOT SIR WILL
PEOPLE SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH HILDREN COLIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THAT TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS LAUREN AFTER ARE YOU ON
THE LINE MISS AFTER. NO IT'S
WARY MORE SIR I'M SORRY. I
APOLOGIZE I. LERI MORRIS I
APOLOGIZE MY MISTAKE- IS MISTER
LARRY MORRISON- LEAD OPPOSITION
ON THE LINE. YES- TERMINA
MEMBERS LARRY MORE SOME BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
MERCIFULLY FOR THE LAST TIME
TODAY WE ARE REGRETFULLY
OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY SIX WHICH WOULD
ELIMINATE A VAST ARRAY OF BEES
COLLECTED UPON CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS WE BELIEVE THE LOSS
OF THESE PREPAYMENTS WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
THE NUMBER OF AREAS INCLUDING
COURT FACILITIES MAINTENANCE
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES AND
DISTRIBUTION OF VICTIM
RESTITUTION WE RECOGNIZE
LEGISLATORS CONCERNED WITH
IMPOSING FINES AND ASSESSMENTS
A DEFENDANT CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY WE SURE OF THOSE WE WOULD
SUPPORT LEGISLATION REQUIRES A
COURT TO DETERMINE A
DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO PAY
PRIOR TO IMPOSITION OF A
PARTICULAR BAIT. SUCH A POLICY
WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH THE
COURT OF APPEALS DECISION AND
PEOPLE BURDENS DRAINAGE AND
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT ALLIES
IN POVERTY WHILE STILL
AUTHORIZES THE COLLECTION OF
MONIES TO SUPPORT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INFRASTRUCTURE
UNFORTUNATELY THE WHOLESALE
ELIMINATION CANCELLATION OF THE
ASSESSMENTS AND PAYMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL WILL HAVE
DEALER JERRY IS A FAX ON
PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT VICTIMS
AND IRONICALLY EVEN DEFENDANTS
IN CRIMINAL CASES FOR EXAMPLE
THE INTEREST RATE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED BY THE LOCAL SECTION
TWELVE FOURTEEN POINT FIVE HELP
SUPPORT COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES
WHICH ARE ALREADY BELEAGUERED
FINANCIALLY. BETTER OFF IN A
CRITICAL RESOURCE FOR PERSONS
IN CRIMINAL CIVIL CASES MIGHT
NOT OTHERWISE HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGAL RESEARCH MATERIALS FOR
PROFESSIONALS NUMEROUS OTHER
FEES ELIMINATED BY THIS BILL
HELP ON THE COLLECTION AND
DISTRIBUTION OF VICTIM
RESTITUTION PAYMENTS OTHER P.
IS LIMITED BY THIS BILL SUPPORT
THE VICTIM RESTITUTION BUT AS
YOU KNOW VICTIMS OF CRIME ARE
OFTEN MEMBERS OF
UNDERREPRESENTED POPULATIONS
WHO RELY ON THESE VICTIM
RESTITUTION FUNDS TO TRY TO PUT
THEIR LIVES BACK TOGETHER AFTER
SUFFERING FINANCIALLY
PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY AS
CRIME VICTIMS AGAIN WE HOPE
SENATOR BRADFORD WILL REVISIT
THE PORTIONS OF THE BILL THAT
WE CAN IMPORTANT SERVICES THAT
BENEFIT- CRITICAL JUSTICE
OBJECTIVES. IN THE MEANTIME. WE
ASK FOR A NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MOORE'S
LET'S MOVE ON TO A WITNESSES
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
C. NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES TWENTY. WE WILL WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY OPPOSITE OF S.
FIVE SIX. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY SIX WILL BEGIN.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. FIVE EIGHT SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO.
THANK YOU MODERATE CAN PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
WAITING TO TESTIFY AND THAT
LINE AT NINE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS UP. JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF COLLEAGUES
WITH URBAN COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE OR THE UNDERLYING
POLICY BUT HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE FISCAL IMPACT ON COUNTIES
AND ARE GRATEFUL THE AUTHOR IS
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE- SENATOR
BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU I JUST THINK
THIS TO THIS REPORT I THINK SHE
SAID OH I APOLOGIZE SENATORS
SKINNER THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU-
I KNOW THAT WE ARE ABOUT TO RUN
OUT OF TIME BUT I JUST WANT TO
INDICATE THAT. DID DURING THE
LAST RECESSION MANY OF THESE
FEES WERE GREATLY INCREASED
BECAUSE- OUR COURTS ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THERE WAS SO MUCH
PRESSURE ECONOMICALLY HOWEVER
AS WE INCREASE THOSE FEES THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO WERE BEING
CHARGED AND WERE ALSO UNDER
TERRIBLE ECONOMIC PRESSURE. AND
WE ARE FACING THAT AGAIN RIGHT
NOW. AND I THINK THAT WE REALLY
THE- PURPOSE OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SHOULD NOT BE TO
TRY TO FINANCE IT ON THE BACKS
OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO WE ARE
THAT- WE ARE- IT FOR THAT ARE
WITHIN THAT SYSTEM SO I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BILL AND I.
AM GLAD TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS
REGARDING SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX.
OKAY TO HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR KAMLAGER THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
COME LONGER- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FIFTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIXTY PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD
BRADFORD DIETRO BOKE NO ABOVE
NO COM LONGER. KAMLAGER AYE
SKINNER AYE FINNER AYE WIENER.
RIGHT WIENER HI THE BILL IS F.
FORTY ONE. THE TICKET BACK TO
THE CENTER PRESS THANK YOU.
MUMBAI SZCZUR- NOW CONSULTING
WILL OPEN THOSE OUTSTANDING-
ITEMS THAT WE STILL HAVE OUR
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON. SB
THIRTY. SB THIRTY FIVE. SB
THIRTY FIVE AMBER LAGER. NOT
VOTING VOTES FOR ZERO BEST
PHOTOS FORTY ZERO. KNOX'S
HUSBAND EIGHTEEN TO NINETY NINE
LEYVA. VOTERS FORTY ZERO COM
MARKER KAMLAGER I. FIVE ZERO.
SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE TORONTO
VOTE IS THREE TO ONE SKINNER I
FINNER I'D- FORTY ONE. FIVE SB.
SEVEN THIRTY ONE FOUR ONE. SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE THAT IS OUT
FOUR TO ONE. SB SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE BECKER- THREE TO ONE
SKINNER. I DINNER I VOTES FOR
ONE. IT MEASURES OUT SB. SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE FOUR TO ONE. SB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN WIENER WE'RE
SORRY YOUR CONFERENCES ENDING
NOW PLEASE HANG UP SKINNER. BYE
SKINNER I VOTERS FOUR TO ONE S.
B. THREE FIVE SEVEN IS OUT FOUR
TO ONE. I BELIEVE THAT IF THIS
THANK YOU VERY. SORRY. I JUST
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
A PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY AND IF
YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE PUBLIC- THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
OR VISIT THE WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AN
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE ON BOTH-
COLLEAGUES AND FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN COPPER CORPORATION
AND WE HAVE BEEN COMPLETED. THE-GENDER FOR TODAY'S PUBLIC
SAFETY HEARING WE STAND
ADJOURNED.